hey everyone welcome to another video by
simply learn
in today's session we're going to be
looking at top interview questions asked
for full stack development now the video
covers a wide range of technologies but
before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update
so here's what's in store for us first
we look at the commonly asked questions
on git
then we'll move on to front-end
development technologies like html css
javascript react.js and angular
from there we'll move on to sql
node php
selenium
maven jenkins and docker
now all of these questions will help you
crack your next interview if you're
hoping to become a full stack developer
then you're in the right place now
without further ado let's begin so let's
just get into those source code
management and we're going to focus
specifically on git the reason being is
that get is really the most popular
source code management solution right
now there are other technologies out
there but for the types of distributed
environments that we have uh source code
management with git is probably the most
effective so the first question you'll
be asked when it comes to git is to talk
about the difference between centralized
and distributed version control and if
we look at the way that the two are set
up older technologies such as older
versions of team foundation server
though the current version does actually
have get in it but older versions
required a centralized server for you to
check in and check out of code the
developer in the centralized system does
not have all the files uh for the
application and if the centralized
server crashes then you actually lose
all of the history of your code now in
contrast a distributed model actually we
do check in our code to a server however
for you to be effective and building out
your solution you actually check out all
of the code for the solution directly
onto your local development machine so
you can actually have a copy of the
entire solution running on your local
machine this allows you to be able to
work effectively offline it really
allows for scalability when it comes to
building out your team so if you have a
team that may be in europe you can
actually then scale that team with
people from asia from north america or
south america very easily and not have
to worry about whether or not they have
the right code or the wrong code and in
addition to that if the actual main
server where you're checking in your
code does crash it's not a big deal
because you actually have each person
has a copy of the code so as soon as the
server comes back up you have to check
back in and everybody's running back as
if there was nothing that happened at
all so one of the questions you'll be
asked is to give the answer to some of
the commands you use for working with
git so if you were to be asked the
question is what is the git command that
downloads any repository from github to
your computer on the screen we have four
options we have git push get fork get
clone and get commit the answer in this
instance would be git clone now if you
want to be able to push code from your
local system to a github repository
using git then first of all you want to
be able to do is connect the local
repository to a remote repository
and in the example you may want to talk
about using the command get remote add
origin and then the actual path to a
github repository you could if you
wanted to actually at this point also
talk about other repositories such as
get lab that you can also work with or a
private git repository that would be
used just for the development team once
you've actually then added the local
repository into your local computer then
the second action you want to use is a
push which is to actually push your
local files out to the master
environment so you use the command git
push origin master so one question you
may be asked is what is the difference
between a bare repository and a standard
way of initializing a get repository so
let's look through what is the standard
way so the standard way using git init
allows you to create a working directory
using the command git init and then the
folder that creates is the folder that
creates all the revision history related
to the work that you're doing in
contrast using the bear way you have a
different commands for setting that up
so it would be git init dash dash bear
and it does not contain any working or
checked out source files locally on your
machine in addition the revision history
is actually stored in the root folder
versus a subfolder that you would have
with the normal git in it initialization
so which of the following cli commands
would you be used to rename a file so we
have git rm git mv get rm-r or none the
above well in this instance it would be
gate mv a question that you'll be asked
around commit is going to be what is the
process to revert a commit that has
already been pushed and made public and
there are two ways you can address this
the first is to actually
address the bad file in the new commit
and you can use the command git commit
dash m and then put in a comment for why
that file is being removed the second is
to actually create a new commit that
actually undoes all the changes that
were made with the bad commit and then
to do that you would use git revert and
then the commit id and the commit id and
it could be something such as 560e
0938f but you'd have to find that from
the the commit that you had made but
that would allow you to revert any bad
files that you had submitted so the two
ways of being able to get files from a
get repository and you're gonna be asked
to explain the difference between git
fetch and get paul so get fetch allows
you to fetch and download only new data
from a new repository it does not
integrate any of the new data into your
working files and it can be undone at
any time if you wanted to break out the
remote tracking branches in contrast git
pull updates the current head branch
with the latest changes from the remote
server so you get all of the files and
downloaded it downloads new data and
integrates it with the current working
files you have on your system and it
tries to merge remote changes with your
local ones so one of the questions
you'll get asked about get is what is a
gate stash so as a developer you will be
working on the current branch within a
solution but what happens if you come up
with an idea where it's something that
will take a different amount of time for
you to be able to complete but you don't
want to interrupt the mainline branch so
what you can actually do is you can
actually create a branch that allows you
to start working on your own work
outside of the main line branch and this
is called git stash allows you to be
able to modify your files without
interrupting the mainline branch so you
once you start talking about branching
and get be prepared to answer and
explain the concept of branching so
essentially what it allows you to do is
have a mainline master branch that has
all the code that the team is checking
in and checking out against but allows
you to have an indefinite number of
branches that allows for new features to
be built in parallel to the mainline
branch and then at some point be
reintroduced to the mainline branch to
allow the team to add in new features
and so if we look through the merge and
get rebase these are the two features
that you'd be using continuously to be
able to talk about how you take a branch
and merge it back into the mainline
branch so on the left hand side we have
git merge which allows you to take the
code that you're creating and merge it
back into the master on the right hand
side what you have is a slightly
different approach this is for projects
where you reach a point in a project
where you go okay we're going to
effectively restart the project at this
point in time and we want to ignore the
complete history that's happened before
that and that's called get rebase and
that would allow you to rewrite the
project history by creating a brand new
mainline branch that ignores all other
previous branches that have happened
before it you can if you want to very
quickly and easily find out all the
files that have been used to make a
particular commit so when somebody asks
you the question how do you find a list
of files has been changed in a
particular commit you can actually say
that all you have to go is find the
command get diff dash tree dash r and
then the hash that you would use for the
commit and that would actually then give
you a breakdown of all the files that
have been made with that particular
commit a question you'll be asked when
you're talking about merging files is
what is a merge conflict in git and how
can it be resolved so essentially a
merge conflict is when you have two or
more branches that are competing with
commits in git and you have to be able
to determine which is the appropriate
files that need to be submitted and this
is where you would go in and to actually
help resolve this issue you'd actually
go in and manually edit the conflicted
files to select the changes you want to
keep in the final merge so let me go
through the steps that you would take to
be able to illustrate this when you're
talking about this particular question
in your interview now there are
essentially four stages the first would
be under the repository name you want to
select a pull request and you want to be
able to show how that pull request would
be demonstrated inside of github so
within the pull request there's going to
be a highlight of conflict markers and
you'll be able to select which conflicts
and you want to keep on which you want
to merge and which ones you want to
change so it's a step through how you
would actually resolve a merge conflict
and the first step would be under github
you want to be able to pull the
repository name and then the pull
request around that repository in the
pull request list click the pull request
with a merge conflict and that you'd
like to be able to resolve they'll pull
up a file that will list out all of the
conflicts for you near the bottom of
that file will be a list of the requests
that need to be resolved and then if you
need to make a decision on which
branches you want to keep or which ones
you want to change that will have to be
something you have to put in
instructions inside of the file you'll
actually see that there are conflict
markers within the instructions which
are going to ask you which files you
want to change which ones you want to
keep if you have more than one merge
conflict in your file scroll down to the
next set of conflict markers and repeat
steps four and five until you resolve
all of the conflicts you will want to
mark your file as resolved in github so
that the repository knows that you are
having everything resolved if you have
more than one file with a conflict then
you want to go then onto the next file
and start working on those files and
just keep repeating the steps we've done
up to this point until you have all the
conflicts resolved and then once you
have all of the resolutions created then
you want to select the button which is
commit merge and then merge all your
files back into github and this will
take care and manage the resolution of
the merge conflict within github so you
can also do this through command line
and with the command line you want to
use get bash and so when you want to as
a first step open up get bash and then
navigate to the local get repository and
command line by using the cd change
directory and then list out the actual
folder where you actually are putting
all of your code and then you want to be
able to generate a list of the files
that are affected with the merge
conflict and in this instance here you
can actually see the file style guide.md
has a merge conflict in it and as before
with working with github you actually go
through and use a text address and use
any text editor but as you go through
then edit out what you want to keep and
what you want to uh manage in your
conflict so you actually have a
resolution that's been created so that
you'll be able to then once you're using
the conflict markers you can actually
merge your files together so that the
solution itself will allow you to
incorporate your commits effectively
into the resolution once you've gone
through and applied your changes you're
able to then merge the conflicted
commits into a single commit and able to
push that up to your remote repository
so html stands for hypertext markup
language it is the most widely used
language for developing web applications
it was created by berners-lee in the
year 1991 but it was published in the
year 1995. html4 was a popular
breakthrough version and got published
in the year 1991.
this version gained a lot of popularity
and was adopted all over the globe for
developing web applications so without
further ado let's get started with the
interview questions based on html it's
the first question
what is html html stands for hypertext
markup language and it is the language
of the internet it is a standard text
formatting language used for creating
and displaying pages on internet html
documents are made up of the elements
and tags that format it properly and
display it on pages
so we have our next question now
what are html tags
so the answer for this question is html
tags are used for placing the elements
in a proper and appropriate format tags
use the symbols greater than and less
than to set them apart from the html
content
the html tags need not to be closed
always for example in case of images the
closing tags are not required for an
image tag
now followed by the second question we
have our third question what are html
attributes the attributes are the
properties that can be added to an html
tag that change the way the tag behaves
or displayed for example an image tag
an image stack has src attribute with
which you can use the source from which
you have to display the image from
now the attributes are added right after
the name of the html tag inside the
brackets the attributes can only be
added to opening or self-closing tags
but never in closing tags
now followed by third question we have
our next question what is mark you in
html mark you is used for scrolling text
on a web page it scrolls the image or
text up down left or right automatically
to apply for a marquee you have to use
marquee tags
now we have our fifth question how do
you separate a section of text in html
we separate a section of text in html
using the below tags which are the break
tag paragraph tag and block code
the break tag is used to separate a line
of text it breaks the current line and
shifts the flow of the text line to a
new line followed by that we have the
paragraph line the paragraph line is
used to write a paragraph of text and
third one the blog code the blog code
tag is used to define large quoted
sections
now we have our sixth question define
the types of lists in html so we have
the three types of lists in html which
are the ordered list unordered list and
definition list so first we'll discuss
the ordered list the ordered list uses o
l tag and displace elements in a
numbered format next we have the
unordered list the unordered list uses
ul tag and displace elements in a
bulleted format thirdly we have the
definition list the definition list uses
dl dt and dd tags and displays elements
in the form of definition
like a dictionary
next we have our seventh question
how do you align list of elements in an
html file we can align the list elements
in an html file by using indents if you
indent each nested list and further than
the parent list then you can easily
align and determine the various lists
and the elements that it contains
now we have our eighth question
differentiate between ordered list and
unordered list so the answer for this
question is an unordered list uses ul
tags and each element of the list is
written between li tags the items are
displayed as bullets rather than numbers
now coming into ordered list so for
creating an ordered list you'll be using
ol tags and each element inside the list
as written using li tags the list items
are displayed using numbers rather than
bullet points
now we have a sample on the screen right
now so the first three elements are
a set of unordered lists which are
represented using bullet packs and the
second set which is the coffee tea and
milk is an ordered list which is
represented using numbers
now moving ahead we have the ninth
question how do you display a table in
html webpage so the table and html can
be created or displayed using the table
tag
so it also uses to manage the layout of
the page for example header section
navigation bar body content photo
section etc etc so given below are a
list of html tags used for displaying
table in an html webpage so we have
table t r th etc etc table is used to
define a table tr is used to define a
row in a table th for header td for a
cell caption is used to define a caption
and we have the call group which is used
to specify a group of one or more
columns in a table for formatting next
we have call which is used with call
group element to specify column
properties for each column next we have
t body which is used to group the body
content in a table next we have t head t
footer which are used for header content
and footer content respectively moving
forward we have our 10th question
how do you display the given table in an
html web page so the answer for this
question is written on the right side
part of my screen this is the sample
code which you can use to represent or
display a table which is given in this
particular format over here now followed
by this we have our 11th question how do
we insert a comment in html so the
answer for this question is
we can insert a comment in html by
beginning with lesser than sign and
ending with a greater than sign for
example as shown in the right side part
of my screen which is hello world now
moving ahead we have our 12th question
how do you insert a copyright symbol in
html so you can insert a copyright
symbol by using ampersand copy semicolon
or ampersand hashtag 169 semicolon in an
html file now moving ahead we have our
13th question so what is a white space
in html so the answer for this question
is an empty sequence of space characters
is called as white space in html this
white space is considered as a single
space character in html white space
helps the browser to merge multiple
spaces into one single space and so
taking care of indentation becomes
easier
whitespace helps in better organizing
the content and tags making them
readable and easy to understand
with this let's move into the 14th
question
how do you create links in different
sections within the same html web page
so the answer is anchor tags we can use
anchor tag along with referencing
through the use of hashtag symbol to
create several links to different
sections within the same web page moving
ahead we have the 15th question how do
you create a hyperlink in html so the
answer is we can use anchor tag again
here the same thing we can use anchor
tag to create a hyperlink within the
html that links to another web page the
hyperlink can be added to images too now
moving ahead into our 16th question
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
define an image map so the answer for
this question is an image map in html
helps in linking with the different
kinds of web pages using the single
image it can be used for defining spaces
in the images that are made part of the
image mapping process
moving ahead we have our 17th question
why do we use stylesheet in html a
stylesheet helps in creating a
well-defined template for html web page
that is both consistent as well as
portable a single stylesheet template
can be linked to various web pages which
makes it easier to maintain and change
the look of the website now the 18th
question
what is semantic in html
so the answer for this question is
semantic html is a coding style it is
the use of html markup to reinforce the
semantics or the meaning of the content
for example the semantic html b tag is
not used for bold statement as well as i
tag which is not used for italic instead
we use strong and em tags
now followed by the 18 question we have
our 19th question
what is svg in html so the html svg is
used to describe the vector or raster
graphics svg images and their behaviors
are defined in xml text sheets it is
mostly used for vector type diagrams
like pie charts two dimensional graphs
in an xy coordinate system now moving
ahead we have our 20th question what
would happen if there is no text between
the html tags so the answer for this
question is really simple there would be
nothing to format if there is no text
present in between the tags therefore
nothing will appear on the screen some
tags such as the tags with our closing
tag like image tag do not require any
text between them
now followed by the 20th question we
have our next question how do you create
nested web pages in an html so nested
web pages basically mean a web page
within a web page we can create nested
web pages in html using the built-in
iframe tag the html live frame tag
defines an inline frame for example
which is displayed on the right side
part of my screen you can see the iframe
source
which redirects the user to simply
learn's official web page
now followed by that we have our 22nd
question how do you add buttons in html
so we can use the built-in button tag in
html to add buttons to the html web page
so on the right hand part of my screen
you can see the implementation of button
to an html web page now followed by 20
second question we have our 23rd
question
what are the different types of headings
in html so the answer for this question
is there are basically six types of
heading tags in html which are defined
with h1 to h6 stacks
each type of the heading tag displays
different text size from another
where h1 is being the largest and h6 is
being the smallest so on the right hand
part of my screen you can see the
implementation of heading tags from h1
to h6 now the
output for this particular code segment
is the h1 h2 s3 h4 h5 h6 so you can see
that h1 is being the biggest one and h6
is being the smallest one now moving
ahead into our 24th question how do you
insert an image in the html web page so
the answer for this question is you can
insert an image in the html webpage by
using the following code which is
displayed on the right side part of my
screen you can see we have a image
source is equals to tulip.jpeg
which is used for inserting an image
into your html webpage
now our 25th question what is the alt
attribute in html now the answer for
this question is the alt attribute is
used for displaying the text in place of
an image whenever the image cannot be
loaded due to any technical issue
so basically when you have poor internet
connection and you are trying to load an
image you can see some sort of text in
place of an image so that particular
text is nothing but the alt attribute
now moving ahead we have our 26th
question
how are hyperlinks inserted in the html
webpage you can insert a hyperlink in
the html webpage by using the following
code which is present on the right side
part of my screen
you can use the anchor tag along with h
reference and inside that particular tag
you can use the url to which you want
your users to redirect to
now followed by this we have our 27th
question how do you add color to the
text in html so the answer for this
question is you can add color to the
text by using the following code which
is present on the right side part of my
screen where you can add a red color and
blue color green color to this
particular paragraph and headings now
followed by 27th question we have our
28th question
how do you add css styling in html so
there are three particular ways to add
css to your html there are inline css
external style sheet and internal style
sheet we'll discuss each of these
methods in a bit more detail first we
have the inline css
so it is used when less amount of
styling is needed or in cases where only
a single element has to be styled to use
inline styles add the style attribute in
the relevant tag now moving ahead we
have the external style sheet this is
used when the style is applied to many
elements or html pages each page must
link to the style sheet using the link
tag
now we have the last one which is the
internal style sheet it is used when a
single html document has a unique style
and several elements need to be styled
to follow the format internal style
sheet is added in the head section of
the html page by
style tag now followed by this we have
our 29th question
what hierarchy do the style sheets
follow
the answer for this question is if a
single selector includes three different
style definitions the definition that is
closest to the actual tag takes
precedence inline style takes priority
over embedded style sheets which takes
priority over external style sheets now
our last question for the session today
how do you add javascript to an html web
page so the answer for this question is
we basically have three methods to add a
javascript to our html webpage they are
inline script block and
external javascript file first we'll
discuss the inline
you can add javascript to your html
elements directly whenever a certain
event occurs javascript code can be
added using attributes of the html tags
that support it now the next one that is
the script block you can define a script
block anywhere inside the html code
which will get executed as soon as the
browser reaches to that part of the
document this is why script blocks are
usually added at the end part of the
html documents now the last one that is
the external javascript file you can
also add or import the javascript code
from a separate file and keep your html
code clutter free this is especially
useful if there is a large amount of
scripting added to the html webpage
today we're going to talk about css
interview questions
as we know it very well today in a
current scenario
you being as a front-end developer
css playing a very very important role
so in interview
what kind of to give let's talk about
those
okay so let's get started with those
questions and answers
okay
now
here
we'll talk about basic css interview
questions
now name some css frameworks as we know
it very well today in css environment
there's so many frameworks are available
okay like
we talk about css these are basically
necessary libraries which offers you
some very popular ready-made components
which you can utilize into your
existing project and without writing
much code you can really create some
awesome effects so
some of the very very popular libraries
are like in foundation bootstrap
gumby
ukit semantic ui
and many more which are available here
okay
now what do you understand by the
universal selector see universal
selector as you know it very well in css
normally we talk about specific
selectors like in talk about class
selectors id selectors
they select a specific set of elements
or a specific element
when we talk about universal selectors
universe selector is matches any element
types like instead of selecting elements
of a particular type so you talk about
like an asterisk
where all elements irrespective of what
name and what category they have it all
will be selected
next
tell us about
rule set see typically rule set is
for the identification for selector
which can be attached with
other selectors so there are normally
two rule sets are available
when we talk about declaration block and
we talk about selector so declaration
block contains one or more semicolons
separated by declarations set of styles
which we say and the selector is means
or which particular
element this css style will be
intended for
next
what are the elements of css box model
okay so we know it very well the csx box
model is all about offering you the
layout
which is a part of the design element so
in css we can see this elements are like
in images
you talk about text okay you talk about
padding which is so called
area around the content you talk about
border talk about margin
okay so you talk about this css box
model
next
difference between css3 and css2 we know
it very well css has changed a lot and
css3 has brought so many new features
so we talk about a difference so in css2
so cc splits up the different sections
of code into the modules so in css3 both
css and html were put into the single
file
in css3 there were no new way of writing
the css rules
there are new rules are available in
writing our css rules
normally in css3 it is a backward
compatibility maintained by the with a
css3
but in css2 we do not have any backward
compatibility maintained by the css2
here
now how can css be
integrated into the html page
like in order to utilize this we always
use the style sheet we use style tag
okay so multiple options are available
when we talk about using the style tag
in a head section
else we talk about inline styling with
an element itself or third we talk about
external style sheet which you can link
it with your current html page which
anyways enforce reusability
coming back what is the rgb stream
so rgb stands for red green and blue so
it represents a color in css so they are
basically uh starting with the color
number 0 goes till 256.
next
what is the purpose of developing a css
okay the main purpose of developing a
css to basically offer the visual
appearance to give the better look and
feel to your code so that your html will
offer only the skeleton part but when it
comes to the beautification
you talk about organization and
everything you talk about the css
okay so css offers the styling part of
your web page which looks more
attractive
so what is the difference between class
and id see these are two different type
of selectors are available in css
class selectors and id selectors
so class is the way of using these html
elements
so they are not unique and have multiple
elements
where the id is unique and it can be
assigned to a single element
so with css different documents can be
controlled using the single style so
style can be grouped in a complex
situation
to offer the consistent
look for the multiple html pages
so that is what the advantage is you
have it
so you can group multiple styles
together and that you can reuse over the
different pages to offer the consistent
styling
okay
now we talk about some intermediate css
interview questions
so here in the intermediate level you
will see
like the first question is like what
define a z index see zen index is
specify the stack order of the elements
that overlap each other
okay so its default value is zero and
can take both negative and positive
values
okay
the higher the z index value is stacked
above the lower index element so it
normally takes the following value talk
about like an auto number initial and
inherit
next
you talk about what are the benefits of
css sprite see the main benefit of css
sprite is
like loading a multiple image is not
an issue
okay uh blinking is not seen there are
some advantages are available like when
you talk about like
at one single or small small images
it really takes a lot of time to
download it individually so css sprites
loading multiple image is not an issue
blinking is not seen
because normally what happens blinking
happens when the image is getting loaded
so advanced downloading of asset doesn't
make a place off
until needed that's the benefit of
having the css sprites
next how can you target the h3 and h2
with the same styling so you can do the
comma separated so you can see multiple
elements can be targeted with using
comma separated so you use comma
separated values to give the consistent
style to both the elements
so name and media types allowed by css
so media types are basically a part of
your responsiveness
different media types are allowed like
in speech audio visual
tactile media
continuous or paged media grip media or
bitmap or interactive media
these are all type of medias
are allowed in css
so how can you use
css to control image repetition so we
talk about no repeat
so background repeat properties which is
available so you can see
background repeat none so that it would
not be repeated again and again within
your background
okay so we're talking about the next
questions like
about the image scrolling control how
you can control the image scrolling so
that you want the image to be remain
fixed
and rest of the part gets scrolled
so here it is the part of your
background attachment property
so here you say the background repeat no
repeat and you see background attachment
fixed so that when you scroll down your
image is not going to be scrolled
so that is the benefit of this image
control scrolling
now
name some font related css attributes
we have some options available like you
talk about font style weight
variance size
family these are the
font related css attributes
define contextual selector
so normally in css the context
contextual selectors allows developer to
specify style
of a different part of the document
okay so style which you utilize it can
be aligned directly to the static html
pages
to create independent classes
okay that's called contextual selector
so responsive web design responsive web
design is a web design which you want to
remain consistent
across multiple device screens or the
different type of screen sizes and you
want to offer the better layout which
doesn't looks bloated over the different
websites
so that's the benefit which you see when
you talk about like responsive web
design
css
nomenclature
css nomenclature means the styling
commands are written in a value on a
property fashion
okay so normally css includes a system
terminator semicolon the entire style is
wrapped in a curly braces and attached
to the dedicated selector okay so this
actually creates a style sheet that can
be applied to an html page so this is
the standard nomenclature
okay
now
coming back to the next point
advanced css interviews
i will tell you about few questions
which are normally asked as a part of
advanced css
okay
now when do you use translate instead of
absolute positioning okay so the
translate in a css
okay transform value on changing
you can talk about opacity or transform
okay so the browser reflow or repaint is
not triggered
when we talk about this translate
okay so the transform requires a browser
to create a gpu layer for
elements
okay but using the cpu changes
absolute positioning property so
translate is more efficient and result
in
shorter paint times
next name different ways to position
same aspects in css
okay
so you talk about positioning properties
okay
so there are five different positions
values are number one you talk about
fixed you talk about static
you have absolute you have got relative
i never got sticky so five different
positioning elements are available in
css
what are mixens
mixins is a similar to the function
block of code returning a single value
it is a kind of function which we say
okay
so traditionally it is used in a sas or
okay which is typically called
statically awesome style sheet so
that code that directly compiles into
the css styles
so how can you optimize the web page for
the prints
so
you actually identify a control
okay so called contents areas of a
website
a general website has a footer header
sidebar or nav bar
or
content area
so
normally we say conquer the print media
without changing the website's integrity
by using the page breaks so creating
styles for print
size
your page for print and avoid
unnecessary html table so using this you
can optimize the print of your web pages
so what is the meant by css working
under the hood so when your browser
display document it actually combine the
style
okay which presents information and
document content so the document is
actually processed in two stages number
one
conversation
okay or conversion of html and css into
the document object model so called dom
and dom display contents of browser
different between the use of id selector
and class selector we have already seen
that but this is a simple demo of how
the id selector in class selectors are
used the difference is all about using
so here you have a call id which you use
dot sorry this hash and there you use
dot
so tell us about css float property so
normally css float properties
uh of positioning an image to the right
or left as needed so it typically
including text wrapping around it so all
properties of elements used before it
remain unchanged that is known as called
float
so what do you understand with the
pseudo elements so pseudo elements are
special effects to your selectors so
normally css finds
okay using applying styles in a html
markup so if additional markup or style
is not feasible for a document then
pseudo elements help by allowing extra
markup without
interfering with the original
document
difference between
logical and physical tag so normally
logical tags focus on the content
okay
and are older as compared to the
physical ones
logical ones do not find much usage in
presentation
in terms of
utilization at the same time physical
ones find application in presentations
so how media type works in css type so
we have discussed already about a media
type
so we normally say four different type
of media properties are available i can
print speech and screens
okay like you talk about
print media screen so we use always add
the rate media print you talk about h2
so this changes according to what option
you're offering it
so guys here we have multiple css
question and frequently our css
interview questions are offered like
tell
something about css3
okay so we say css is divided into the
modules and is supported by almost every
single browser
okay it is an advanced version of css2
and offering you lot many other advanced
level features which typically in css2
we do not have that
okay
now
we talk about how css selectors used
so with the css selectors we can choose
you know any element of your html
okay so
you talk about element attribute you
talk about any child selector you can
basically select it
so what are css image scripts
so the group of image placed into the
one single image is in a css image
script it can reduce the load time
because individual images certainly take
more time so this takes more time
comparatively
so we have a god explain css
a specificity
so the css specificity is a rank or
score that decides style declarations to
be used to an element
id selectors have high specificity while
universal selector has low specificity
that's how the specificity is all about
so the four css categories that
authorize the selectors specificity
levels are ids inline element sudo and
class and style attributes
so these are the different type of
conditions based on that the specificity
is considered
define gradients in css we know the
gradient
are
again a css3 property that allows
displaying the smooth transformation
from one type of color to another color
okay
so that's really awesome technique
through which you can talk about linear
gradient or else you talk about radian
gradients multi different type of
gradients are
used and supported
so what are the properties of flexbox so
we know it flexbox are basically
designed for the alignment purpose
so typical the flex boxes are flex
direction you talk about wrap flow
content align items and the contents
like that it is once again the property
of alignment
so tell us about the usage of css box
model
so normally blocks box model is a box
binding in html elements that includes
padding border margin and the actual
content for the more better alignment
so normally the box model you get an
authority to add a border all around the
elements and define space between the
elements
so what are the position states in css
so we normally talk about four positions
in css so called relative statics
absolute and fixed
the default position is status always
static
so different between absolute and
relative in css
so normally relative is useful for some
tags in css if we write like 20 pixels
then padding shift 20 pixels in a right
but when we talk about absolute
so it is
absolute is relevant relative to the
non-static parent that means if i'm
talking about
if you say right 20 pixels the result
will be 20 pixels far from the right
edge of the parent element
that's how the relative and absolute
position is
so what is the common between class and
id see both classes are id used in html
okay for the css purpose the id is used
as an element where the class is used as
a block
so this particular information is all
about giving you the idea of like what
kind of questions
it may be asked during the time of
interview which is related to your
javascript so
this particular slides will help you to
understand what kind of questions you
may expect
from your interviewer and kind of
answers you need to get ready with
let's get started with the javascript
interview questions
so let's get started with the beginner
javascript questions we have multiple
levels available here we start with a
beginner level first
so the first question is always like
what do you understand about javascript
so we know it very well the javascript
is a very very popular scripting
language it is basically designed for
client-side scripting
and server-side scripting development
why server-side because nowadays
javascript is also used in a back-end
using node.js so that's why it is also
called for server-side development so
the question is like
uh javascript is
actually also helps the developers to
develop some more responsive html pages
okay which can be well understood and
executed by the web browser
okay which having the support
capabilities for object-oriented
programming skills
now the next question is like what is
the difference between javascript and
java see the reason is because the
javascript initials are java so
everybody think like okay there is some
relationship with the java so actually
the thing is like there is no
relationship with java i would say
javascript is object based language
whether java is object oriented language
a lot of syntax
and some standards are matching with
java that's why exactly it is saying it
is javascript
otherwise there is nothing like that
but another difference if i talk about
javascript is mainly designed to run
with the browsers where the java is
designed especially for the virtual
machine and operating system
another thing is like javascript does
not need a compilation because it is
directly used interpreter but when you
talk about java it requires a compiler
as well as the interpreter both
now
what type of various data types are
supported so all standard
data type second byte short int long
float double character boolean
these all different type of data types
are supported in
javascript also just like in traditional
programming
languages
okay
now
what are the features of javascript so
the first feature which you always
remember it's it is a lightweight
programming language it is
been interpreted by
the browsers rather than compiled
it is a cross platform that means it can
work across multiple browsers
so it is not specific to the browsers
so that we need to understand next it is
an open source hence you do not need to
pay for any licensing fees it comes free
with all different type of browsers
it is an object oriented but i would not
say that the pure object oriented i
would rather say it is an object based
language
next it can gel well
with multiple front end as well as the
back-end technologies because most of
the languages which are coming up in a
market they have a support available to
get integrated with the javascript and
due to that javascript is very very
popular so it is also used especially
for the development like a network based
application
so in case if you want to have some kind
of network centric application here the
javascript really suits very very well
okay
next question what are the advantages of
javascript so the first
advantage which we are talking about
like javascript basically have a very
very nice interactive language it is a
event-based
okay functional programming language i
would say so it is a quick feedback
because it loads very very fast
in your existing web pages
it is
giving you the support of developing a
very very rich
user interface because of that your
application look consistent across
multiple type of browsers
another is like we have a call variety
of javascript based frameworks are
available like you can talk about
angular you talk about react you talk
about vue they're all basically
different type of javascript based
frameworks that helps a developer to
enhance their skills
with writing less amount of codes
so how you create a script or how you
create an object in javascript it is
very simple the curly braces
curly braces is basically designed to
give you the feel of this is a typical
object there are a variety of ways are
there to create an object in javascript
which we're going to see
in our next video
okay
now here we see about the next set of
questions which are there with us
like how to create a array in javascript
so creating an arrays
in javascript is very very easy
now you can see the square brackets
okay they have the way to basically
create an
array in the javascript so just a square
brackets are a very very simpler way so
called laterals to create
the array objects
in javascript actually you should know
that array is also object which is a
predefined object comes with your
javascript
so called implicit objects
now what are the built-in methods
available in javascript so you remember
about these methods comes from those
built-in objects comes with your
javascript as we have mentioned in our
last slides
like math
boolean
string
okay
date they're all basically predefined
objects are available under those
objects these methods are actually
available like date if you can see it
will display the current date and time
concat to concat two different type of
string push some
adding some new records into your array
pop to remove
round to do the round
length to calculate the length of the
string so these are all some well-known
methods or frequently used methods
available in javascript
now what different type of scopes
available in javascript for the
variables now
so
scopes are basically designed to give
you the visibility
with the new program
okay so different type of scopes are
available when it's called a global
scope so global scope is having the
availability within a file
anywhere else you can access this
particular code or particular variable
that is called global scope and local
scopes are those scopes which are
accessible within a function
and hence cannot be accessed by any
other function or outside of this
function so two standard type of scopes
which are available here
now what is this keyword in javascript
this means to refer the current object
okay so whenever you see that this
keyword it is designed to refer the
current object in
javascript so we typically define
this keyword to assign the value to my
current object properties
usually this is the place where that
this keyword is mostly used
now what are the conventions of
giving the names to the variables
okay so some standard naming convention
which we should always follow
but few things as you remember there are
certain reserve keywords
are there in javascript which you cannot
offer
while giving the names to your variables
or to your functions
like if i can say var
let cons and many more which are there
available which you cannot assign to
your any existing variable
provided or functions
under your javascript
now
here they are trying to say
variable names cannot begin with any
numeric value like you cannot give
var with abc so not abc i would say
rather one two three or something like
that so they must be a combination of
i would say integer as well as a
character
okay so
they must only begin with letter or
underscore characters it is the same
like as we have it in java also
now
naming conventions are very very
important javascript is a case sensitive
hence
the small a and capital a have two
different meanings for the javascript so
that part needs to be well taken care of
now what is the callback in javascript
so you need to understand the callback
in javascript is the kind of function
which you are passing as an parameter to
the other function to execute
okay so callbacks are mainly designed
to
tell your application that
they need to wait rather than continue
to execute
so callbacks
will help you to behave asynchronously
and that's what exactly this most
valuable feature of javascript
so as i discussed already so it is where
the function needs to be passed to get
executed
so how do you debug a javascript code so
to debug your javascript code in any
browser you can just press the f12
no matter which browser you have it
either chrome
or firefox or any one you can just press
the f12 key and there
you can get this option called debugger
where you can just go and perform all
the necessary debugging related stuff
right over there
or
so many other editors like in sublime
text visual studio code
atom
they're all offering you the built-in
support to debug your javascript code
now
what is the difference between a
function declaration and function
expression so this is a very very simple
difference
so when you say
function abc here
okay so you declare as a separate
statement within the same javascript
code
okay in another example what you do you
define a function within a variable name
called a
which you can create to construct some
another object for this
that's the only difference between these
two
so this function can be called before
the function is
defined
and this will be created when the
function is pointing
and reaching it
okay so it can be used only after that
so that's what we have discussed it now
going forward
this offers the better code readability
and better code organization and that
the other part is basically used to
create a conditional or declaration
functions
so what are the ways of adding the
javascript code in an html file so they
are
i would say
two ways are available one
either you can declare it in a separate
file you can add it or second you can
write a embedded javascript code where
you can just write a javascript code
either in your head tag or body tag but
there'll be one difference like if
you're writing it as an embedded
javascript you cannot use it
for the different html file where the
internal javascript file will be limited
to that html however external javascript
will be more useful when you want to
reuse it again and again
so these were some
standard
basic javascript questions for us so
let's go ahead and talk about something
which is related to your intermediate
questions in javascript
now so what do you understand about the
cookies see the cookies are basically a
kind of a small text file
okay which is kept in your browser
and contains the information
about your client activities
okay so whenever the client is accessing
your websites
these websites can track your activities
through these particular cookies
okay so they just basically record your
general
behaviors like what you're doing with
your website so that accordingly they
can give you
the better
recommendations
now how you gonna create a cookie in
your javascript so creating a cookie
cookie is one of the property available
under your document object so that you
can create it using document.cookie
and give a key so
your all cookie are stands with your key
and value pair so you have a key you
have a value pair
so how you gonna read the cookie
so cookie you can read with the help of
the same property called document.cookie
and here you can just use this statement
like what key in value pair so whatever
the keys you have defined similar q will
be reading it to give the value of
whatever
option you want to read it
now how are you going to delete the
cookie
so
cookie can be deleted it very easily by
calling this delete cookie function
where you can just tell about
the time and duration when you want the
cookie to be get deleted
so when you set the expiry time so
cookies are deleted
after specific period of time that will
be treated as a good programming
practice
so what is the difference between a
letter and var keyword see there is a
new feature which is there added called
let keyword which is known as called
block level scope the blockable scope
means
your variable whichever you're defining
under
any block level statement will be
limited to that particular block like if
you're defining it any opening block and
closing block
so beyond that you cannot see that
suppose if we're defining it under if
block
or any block so these
type of variables are no longer
accessible outside where the var keyword
will be typically treated as a global
variable and hence it can be accessed
anywhere
so what is the closure in javascript so
closure is basically going to give you
a better way of
providing the consistent way of
developing a javascript code for the
developer so closures are basically
created whenever a variable that is
defined outside of this current scope
can be accessed within the current scope
okay that means which is
a variable which is defined outside of
this scope even using the scope
of this particular closure it can be
accessed inside too
now
what are the arrow functions in
javascript
friends arrow function in javascript is
very very popular now they're just gonna
give you a kind of alternative way of
defining the function keyword
they are just a shortcut way of
defining the function in
javascript these are the simple handy
functions i would say
so what are the different ways of html
can be accessed in javascript course so
there are multiple ways are there so you
can access using document.get element by
class name you can access git element by
id you can get access document element
by tag name and you can say
document.queryselector so these are the
multiple options are there
through which you can access the element
within your html tags
what are the ways of defining a variable
so var keyword as we discussed
you can define a variable
you can also define the variable using
const
so if you define any variable using
const so these variables will get
constantly declared and it cannot be
changed
once you define the value so any value
or any variable which is defined using
const
it cannot be changed in later stretches
what are imports and export in
javascript
so to make your javascript modular so
there's an option available of importing
and exporting it
so what exactly the difference
difference is very simple like you are
writing the set of javascript code and
if you want to get it accessed
outside in another javascript file so
how the two javascript files can
communicate with each other that is
where exactly the important export code
comes to make your javascript highly
reused and more modular
now
these are the quick example as you can
see now
two different files are there so if you
want to make your particular variable
or function accessed outside you always
use export keyword with them
and if you want to access them out you
can just use an import keyword
as you can see it is defined there
so
another file can easily access your
the content of the previous files to
make your code even more modular and
useful
so what is the difference between a
document and window in javascript see
document is the one which is a part of
your document part which user can
actually see that
okay so the document object is the
object which falls under the category of
window window is a top level object so
in javascript we have an option
available name called
bom that is called browser object model
in which the top level object which is
there that is called window and under
this we have a called document so
whatever you see
under your browser it is a part of your
document
so what are the some
javascript frameworks
and their uses see javascript frameworks
are mainly useful to make your
application more organized
with less code
and without getting into into the detail
okay so having this particular framework
will give you the opportunity so that
developer can
use the javascript in much more better
way
to write a complex code in more
simplified manner
this is where exactly
your frameworks are designed for so
there are some very prominent and useful
frameworks like in react angular
vue.js and lot many other names are
there in market
which will be using the javascript as a
core and take the entire javascript
development to the next level
so the next question is what is the
difference between
a
undefined and undeclared in javascript
see it is very simple
undefined means the variable which is
undefined
you are declaring a variable
okay
and which you haven't defined okay that
means the variable has been declared but
the value has not yet assigned that is
called undefined undeclared means the
variable which you're trying to access
that itself is not available it doesn't
even exist
so what is the difference between
undefined and null in javascript see
undefine as i already told you
it means the variable has been declared
but it is not assigned with any value
null is actually the assignment value
that
we can assign to any variable
which
contained no values as an alternative i
would say so what is the difference
between session storage and local
storage see it is very simple html5 has
offered these features to you
so the session storage and local storage
both offers you the
data which can be stored in a browser
but session storage is short-lived
the moment your page is deleted or
closed the session data is immediately
get deleted
where the local storage data is remain
for the longer period of time and the
data doesn't get deleted after the
browser history is over
okay so i would say the local storage
time span is far bigger compared to the
session storage
okay everyone so we'll have some
advanced javascript questions now
we've already seen the beginner level as
well as the intermediate level questions
now it's time to discuss about some
advanced double questions to like
the first questions like comes like how
do you empty an array in javascript so
it is very simple
if you want to assign
so there are few ways are there
number one by assigning the array length
to what to the zero
so automatically turns to empty
second is what by assigning the
completely empty array
okay the third will be by popping up all
the elements of the array
so multiple options are there and the
last which you talk about by using the
splice function so these are the four
important aspects are there
which you can treat how to
empty your
javascript
array in a very very simplified manner
now what is the difference between even
capturing and even bubbling see this is
one of the very very common question we
talk about even capturing even capturing
is actually the kind of process
where you just try to
capture the event of
most outer most element and then
propagating it to the innermost element
so even capturing is what like you're
talking about picking up the element
or picking up the event from the
outermost like you talk about called
nested div tags
so you pick up the particular
you know even from the most outer most
div tag and you're just passing it to
the innermost that is called capturing
the bubbling
is the process
okay which starts with the innermost and
goes through the outermost elements this
is an opposite direction that is called
event bubbling
so the question is one of the very very
popular like what is the strict mode in
javascript see the strict mode of
javascript is introduced
to give the more better error handling
capacity of the javascript so whenever
we talk about call strict mode so all
variables have to be declared explicitly
so you cannot leave it like that and it
cannot be assigned to the read-only
properties
so we can enable the strict mode only by
adding the user strict mode on the top
of the javascript file
now
what about
and how we would be able to get the
following output of the below javascript
code so we have a call var a equal to 10
and we have written one function in the
if block and after that we're just
capturing the value
of a and then you are printing the value
in a console.log
so what would be the output for that see
it'll be
a call then undefined
once again it'll be kind of what it'll
be
undefined how come it would be look it
is very simple
first thing
okay
in your application
you are basically saying the if
condition statement in the code will
evaluate the eval function
as you know very well what exactly the
evaluation is later on the eval
function
okay
will take the function and return the
function abc whatever the function it is
available
and then inside the if statement it
execute the abc and return the undefined
because as you know it variable the if
statement code execute at runtime was
the statement inside this if condition
is being evaluated so that's where
exactly it is
next can you write a javascript code for
adding the new element in a dynamic
manner yes exactly you can write it down
so you have this very common function
available name called
document.createelement
like people say like i want to add the
new text boxes when i click on the
button
so
i can write it very well so either it
will be a text box or it could be the
new element you want to add it so
document.createelement
is one very very common
i would say the function and later on
you can use the typical dom
functions like i can talk about the
create next node or append child so
using this combination you can easily do
so
next what is the difference between call
and apply very common question so the
call method
whatever the method you have it in a
call these
method arguments are provided
individually okay along with the this
value but in apply what happens
arguments are provided in the form of
array
along with this value that is the only
difference between call and apply
so what would be the output of the below
javascript code as you can see right now
we've written a one object name called
student provided one property called
college with abc
after reducing object.create passing
this is student as an object itself and
after that you're saying delete
student1.collagenconsole.log
student.com so what would be the value
for this
so it is very simple it is very simple
example of object orientation so the
output will be what abc as we are
accessing the property of
student object so certainly the value
will be what
abc for sure now
what would be the output for below
javascript code as you can see now we
have written a one
function
4 and it is written 11 so we are saying
type of
so this will certainly refer to what to
the error
reason is why because a function
definition can have only single
reference variable
as its name that's why exactly it will
be throwing what an error to you
how do you remove the duplicate
value from the javascript array it is
very simple we have called filter
function so the filter method i can
basically call it and three arguments it
may be expecting it the name of the
array the current element and the index
of the current element
so that it can remove all the duplicate
elements from there so how do you remove
the duplicate elements
from javascript array so the same way i
told you like
first it takes three parameters
so using the filter method and by using
the for loop so the empty array is used
for sorting all the repeating elements
so like that you can simply make it more
easy
so how can you draw a simple javascript
dom so you can see it is a very simple
javascript dom elements which are there
where you can have the document and then
the html
and followed by all child elements like
a head tag body tag body may contain
further child elements like an anchor
tag
welcome to the session on react.js
interview questions through this session
we will explore the most commonly posed
interview questions that you would face
if you walk up to a developer interview
on react.js let's start with going
through and exploring the general set of
react.js interview questions that would
be commonly asked in an interview the
first question would be what are the
features of react.js now right through
this session we would follow a common
methodology where we would explore the
question and then look at the best way
in which you could have answered that
question if posed to you during a
react.js interview so starting with the
first question what are the features of
react so react has many extensions for
complete application architecture
support jsx is used with react to
describe what the user interface should
typically look like react is broken into
small components so you look at the
complete application you want to build
break it down into individual components
and a component is typically a piece of
user interface like a function that
would return a stream of html characters
speedy performance is one of the core
features of react as only the updated
components need to be re-rendered on the
screen and not the entire page the
one-way data binding feature on the
other hand keeps everything modular and
fast the virtual dom is also a
lightweight representation of the real
dom which is again a feature with helps
speed up performance and avoids a full
page refresh and a full dom tree shake
which really speeds up performance so
what is jsx how do you answer this so
jsx is typically the extension used for
react and it's nothing but an extension
to the javascript programming language
because all that you can use inside your
browser for execution typically has to
be javascript because in html5 you
cannot have any third-party plugins
installed in the browser and that's the
reason the browser would only ship by
default with a javascript runtime engine
so by using jsx you can write html
structures in the same file that would
contain your javascript code as well
making the updates to the code very
simple so it's simple to update and make
modifications to your code because the
code and the data and the business logic
is all composed in a single file so
because the code in the business logic
is in a single file it makes
updating and incorporating change
requests to the code very simple and
easy so it's basically used with react
to describe what your user interface
should look like and it's what you
typically would term as the html
template or the view coming to the next
question can gsx be directly read by the
web browser so web browsers cannot read
jsx directly now why is that well the
reason is simple it's because they are
only built to read regular javascript
objects and jsx is not a regular
javascript objects it's a react
component so for a web browser to read a
jsx file the file needs to be
transformed into a regular javascript
object and for this there is a
javascript api called people which is
internally used by react so what do you
understand by the virtual dom that we've
been speaking about in react so react
gives a very lightweight representation
of the real dom the actual dom structure
of the page so dom is document object
model it is
an api created by w3c and it creates an
in-memory representation of the html
elements as an inverted tree structure a
balanced tree structure which is the
fastest search algorithm when you want
to search for html elements and do a
dynamic update on them but again
updating the basic dom tree structure of
the page causes a full page refresh and
if you only want to update a specific
component you wouldn't need the entire
page to be refreshed and that is where
react comes in it uses a virtual dom
which is a layer on top of the actual
dom which ensures that only a certain
part of the page is refreshed and that
speeds up performance so when the state
of an object changes virtual dom changes
only that object in the real dom instead
of updating all the objects and this is
what makes things really fast so why use
react instead of other frameworks like
angular first of all it's very easy to
create dynamic web pages dhtml where you
can update the view or the template at
runtime the components are reusable so
you reuse rather than reinvent the
performance is great since you're
working with the virtual dom you don't
need a full page refresh the
unidirectional data flow makes data move
one way there's no two-way data binding
by default and that's the reason the
page does not have to do a lot of heavy
lifting of remembering whether the view
is changing whether the the base
javascript entity class is changing and
that saves a lot of uh processing time
again to debug react is much more
simpler and that's what makes it more
popular in terms of its simplicity and
speed as compared to other frameworks
like angular what is the difference
between es5 and es6 standard so these
are scripting standards okay that are
defined by the european computer
manufacturers association or ecma and
all of the scripting languages are a
subset of the standard and are derived
from these standards to ensure that the
code will execute on all browsers and
the code that we are writing is
standards based so these are a few
instances where es6 syntax has changed
from es5 if you look at the es5 first
syntax at the top we are creating a
simple react class component and the
render function just returns a stream of
html content in ex6 there's a new
keyword that comes in which is extends
so you are extending from the base react
component and creating a custom
component and then returning a stream of
characters also the function keyword no
longer needs to be used so the exports
versus export also changes so you use
exports to export out class from a
module so that it can be accessed from
another module in es6 you simply say
export and the component require versus
import so you would require a
third-party component or an api into
your javascript file to use it in es6
it's replaced with the import statement
very similar to the syntax that we use
in code java so how do you go and create
a react app first you install node.js as
a base platform which you can download
from the node.js website next any text
editor of your choice could be atom
visual studio code or sublime text third
you create a react app using a command
prompt terminal depending on the os you
are using the command to give is create
hyphen react space my first app okay so
the command that you would give to
create a new react app is create hyphen
react hyphen app space and the name of
the application you would want to create
in this case it is my hyphen first
hyphen app and that could be a custom
name of your choice so what is an event
in react well on the web when you talk
about dynamic html it's all about
interacting with the user so the user
performs some interaction event with the
web page which could be a click of a
button a mouse move and these events in
action uh can be triggered by a user or
any system or could be pressing a key or
a mouse click etc and in response to
that event you would execute a block of
code which is called an event handler so
here we have class simple which is a
custom class that extends the base react
component the name of the function work
which triggers a simple alert message
box and a render function which returns
html when you click on the button we
would want to bind that to the event
handler this dot work and that's how you
connect a click event to an event
handler function what are synthetic
events in react well a synthetic event
is an object which acts as a cross
browser wrapper around the browser's
native event it combines the behavior of
different browsers native events into
one api which makes sure that the events
are consistent across different browsers
and this brings in the standards based
development to ensure in this digital
age the code that we are creating for
different browsers have consistency in
terms of its execution so here we see a
function action link we see a function
handle click which takes e as an event
parameter e dot prevent default ensures
that there is no error that the browser
is raising in case the event function
call is not directly compatible with
that specific browser so prevent default
is used to suppress any browser specific
errors or crashes and a simple
console.lock which will lock into the
developer tools window which says you
just clicked a link and then we've got
the return where we are returning the
view to the html template where on click
we connect to this event handler called
handle click so handle click is
basically a wrapper and the entire
action link is a wrapper object which is
a synthetic event we don't directly go
and bind to the on click and then
associate a function with it we actually
associate a synthetic object with it
which binds the base default event that
could be specific to a browser so some
browsers would probably understand an
enclave some another browser would
understand a click and to ensure that
it's consistency of syntax and from a
development perspective the code that we
write will run on all browsers we need
to take care of using the synthetic
events which isolate the developer out
from the complexity of writing code
specific to different browsers so you
just write generic code which will work
on different browsers so how do lists
work in react so the lists display data
in an ordered format the traversal of
lists is done using the map function so
here we see there is a function called
list of names which takes a variable
props as a parameter props dot names
will allow us to get a reference to all
of the array of names that are passed
constant list names is another variable
created equal to name start map and
we are using the arrow operator which is
now an ecmascript standard and
again we are using the opening tag of
the li html element the key is equal to
the name attribute so the brace bracket
will bind that to the name attribute
then we just print the name itself and
we close the ally tag so that's the
names.map function and finally we return
in an unordered list the list names
themselves so the map function will run
through an iterate over the list of
names list them in the li tag the li tag
will get injected into the unordered
list and will finally get returned out
as a stream of html elements in the next
code snippet below we create a constant
variable names we are associating it
with a set of five names and uh we
simply say render list of names names
equal to names at the moment we do that
uh we are using list of names as a
custom html element which is not system
defined it starts looking for the
function list of names passes the names
added to it iterates over it using the
map function which is an inbuilt react
function brings out all of the lists
it's very similar to a forward loop that
you would write for iteration in other
programming languages and then finally
what you get returned in the get element
by id app is nothing but a list of
simple names wrapped in a li element
that are printed on the view so why is
there a need of using keys
in lists so keys are very important in
the code snippet that we saw due to the
following reasons the first reason the
key is a unique identifier if you would
want to search for a name in the list it
is used to identify which items have
changed updated or deleted from the list
so if you want to perform clutter
operations on the data you would want to
search for which element do you want to
update or delete or change it also helps
to determine which components need to be
re-rendered instead of re-rendering all
the components every time and it
increases performance as only the
changed components have to be
re-rendered and not all the components
on the page what are forms in react so
using forms users can interact with the
application and enter required
information whenever needed so forms can
contain certain elements such as text
fields buttons checkboxes radio buttons
etc and forms are also used for many
different tasks such as user
authentication searching filtering etc
how do you create a form pretty simple
again create a custom component called
name from that will extend reactor
component we create a state variable
this dot state is equal to value we
handle the change by writing a handle
change event and we handle the submit by
writing a handle submit event in the
change event we just change the state by
saying set state of the value to
event.target.value event being a system
defined keyword passed as a parameter
and in the submit we simply alert that a
certain name was entered and we trap the
value that was entered into the form
prevent default to suppress the browser
from raising any errors on the render
function we return a form on the submit
we connect to the handle submit event
and we bind the data submitted from the
form to the handle submit event and we
pass the this pointer which is a
reference to the current context of the
view itself we open a label specify the
name we then specified input box as text
the value is set to this dot state dot
value and on change we simply connect to
the handle change event and bind to it
and pass the context of the text box
itself so the moment we change the value
in the text box as we are typing the
handle change event will receive the
updated value and set the state and when
we click on the submit button the handle
submit event handler executes and we
alert out the current value printed in
the text box and that's it so how do you
write comments in react when you're a
developer if you want to comment out
some code or if you want to set comments
to enhance the maintainability of the
code a single line comment is as simple
as given in most other programming
languages backslash asterisk to open
astrix to close multi-line commands
follow the same syntax and can span
multiple slides to add comments to
functions in terms of what the function
can do and what are the types that it
can return what is the arrow function
and how is it used so an arrow function
is a shorter way of writing a function
in react if you look at the snippet on
the top my input on change equal to we
are connecting to this dot handle change
dot bind and that's the longer version
of how you can connect it to an event
handler the shorter version is on change
equal to e arrow operator this dot
handle on change so you don't need to
call the bind explicitly you can replace
that with the arrow operator and reduce
the amount of code that you typically
write how is react different from react
native so react and react native are
completely different react was released
in 2013 it's a web-based platform it is
html compliant it generates html views
it uses css for styling and it's based
on javascript html and css react native
on the other hand is targeted to
mobility devices it's meant to create
installable apps on android and ios
released in 2015 not based on html and
css and it basically requires the
react.js api to create these installable
apps for these mobility ecosystems how
is react different from angular another
popular framework by google so angular
created by google completely based on
the model view controller pattern works
on the real dom layer and requires a
full tree shake at the tom layer to
update views and components supports
bi-directional data mining the rendering
is purely done on the client side the
performance comparatively slow react.js
on the other hand created by facebook
it's the view layer of the model view
controller pattern it works at the
virtual dom layer and it sends faster
it's unidirectional data binding and not
two-way and the rendering is typically
what is done at the server side and what
you get is a response on the client as a
stream of html characters as an output
let's talk about and discuss some
questions around react components so
what are components in react so these
are the building blocks you can think of
them as lego blocks so you break your
problem down into small parts each part
identifying a certain solution of the
problem which is what we define as a
component so they are building blocks of
a react application and a single app
usually consists of multiple components
so it splits the ui into independent
reusable pieces that can be processed
separately a component is essentially a
piece of the user interface or the html
view what is the use of render method in
react so it is compulsory for each
component to have a render method if not
there wouldn't be any html for the
component to render on your view so the
render function returns the html which
is to be displayed within a component
like you see on the screen there is a
class app that extends the react
component and it returns a simple h1
element called hello simply learn and of
course do remember to export the app out
so that it can be accessed from other
components as well if you need to render
more than one element all the elements
must be inside a single parent tag like
a div or a form what is state in react
the state of a component is an object
that holds some data within it the data
would influence the output of the
component now how do you implement state
in react so state holds the data that a
component renders on the web application
for example here we've created in the
constructor this dot state equal to and
this temporary anonymous object has two
attributes car and pi when we return we
simply return this dot state dot car and
this dot state dot by now this is how
you would create
stateful components and access the state
properties within the view how do you
update the state of a component by using
the built-in set state method you can go
ahead and update the state of the
component so here we have a simple
render function that returns the state
itself state dot message and on the on
click connects to a button press
function the moment you click on the
button the button press function sets
the state to another message so the
initial message in the constructor is
welcome to simply learn the moment you
click on the button the set state
triggers and changes it to best place to
learn so the data on the view would be
updated what are props in react well
props is just a short form for
properties and that is what allows us to
pass arguments or data to a component
props are passed to components in the
way similar to that of attributes that
are passed to an html element so how do
you pass props between two components so
let's say we have an app.js component on
the top and a main.js component at the
bottom at the top we are trying to
return this dot props dot car and the
bike so two car and bike attributes
associated with this props of the app
component in the main component when you
look at the render function we are
associating car prop equal to a value of
1 600 cc and bike prop equal to value of
1 5 150cc
and to access it if you look at the
import statement we are importing app
from app.jsx and this is how you can
cross access properties from one
component within the other so what is
the difference between state and props
well state holds information about the
components they are mutable they can be
changed they cannot be accessed by child
components and they cannot have state
props allow to pass data from one
component to the other as an argument
they are immutable they are read only
and props can be accessed by the child
component and they can have props as
well what is a higher order component in
react so these act as a container for
other components which helps in keeping
components simple and induces the
reusability factor they are generally
used when a common logic has to be used
by multiple components that's when you
group together a set of components
within a higher order component in react
how can you embed two or more components
into one this code snippet demonstrates
the app component which returns a hello
text and it has a custom tag called
simple the simple tag is defined in the
component below and it returns text
called simply learn and in the render of
the react dom
we simply go and render the app
component so hello simply learn would be
the final output and that's how you can
embed one component into the other using
this methodology what are the
differences between class and functional
components so stateful components would
extend react component in this case and
if you could look at the render it
simply renders this.props.title
the constant stateless component would
be equal to props the div tag returns
this dot props dot title so you can look
at the style very different in terms of
class and functional components one
using the arrow operator one using the
traditional class and render method so
the class component can hold or manage
state complex as compared to stateless
components can work all of the life
cycle methods of the component and it
can be reused the functional component
cannot hold a managed state they are
simple and easy to understand it does
not work with any life cycle method and
it cannot be reused let's explain the
lifecycle methods of components we've
got kenish initial state which is
executed before the creation of the
component
component
did mount which is executed when the
component gets rendered and placed on
the dom should component update which is
invoked when a component decides any
changes to the dom and returns true or
false value based on certain conditions
component did update it is invoked
immediately after the rendering takes
place component will unmount which is
invoked immediately before a component
is destroyed and unmounted permanently
let's move to the react redux set of
questions so what is redux it's an open
source javascript library used to manage
application state and react uses redux
for building the user interface what are
components of redux the first is the
store which holds the state of the
application store contains state which
defines the user interface which
triggers a set of actions which are then
sent to the reducer so store holds the
state action is the source information
for the store and reducer specifies how
the application state changes in
response to actions sent to the store
what is flux well flux is the
application architecture that facebook
uses for building web applications and
it works in this way the action is
triggered which is sent to the
dispatcher the dispatcher sends it to
the store the store sends it to the view
and the view sends it back to the action
and that's exactly how the steps would
continue in sequence so when we trigger
an action the dispatcher will get
notified once the dispatcher has dealt
with an action the stores listening to
it will get triggered the view gets
updated when the state of the store
changes user action at the view is sent
to the dispatcher to then be processed
how is redux different from flux redux
is an open source javascript library
used to manage application state the
store state is immutable it can only
have a single store and it uses the
concept of reducer flux on the other
hand is an architecture and not a
framework or library the store state is
mutable it can have multiple stores and
it uses the concept of dispatcher let's
look at some react router questions what
is a react router a react router is a
package which is used to create routing
in a react application react router is
used for developing single page web
applications it allows multiple views in
a single application by defining
multiple routes in that react
application how is react routing
different from conventional routing
react routing has a single html page it
uses or the end user rather would
navigate multiple views within the same
file called a single page app the page
does not refresh since it's a single
page file and there is improved
performance since you're not navigating
across multiple pages conventional
routing each view is a separate html
file the user would navigate multiple
files for each view the page would
refresh every time the user navigates
which would hence result in slower
performance how do you implement react
routing you can implement react routing
using a very simple method considering
the above components let's say you've
got a component called app about and
contact so here you can specify the
route path if the route part is just
slash the route defaults out it takes
you to the app component if the route is
slash about in the url given by the end
user you automatically navigate and
activate and load the about component
and if the url is slash contact it would
take you to the contact component let's
talk about react styling questions how
do you style react components either you
use inline styling by using simple css
by simply saying color blue and that's
going to be the output of the h1 element
or i could use a javascript object by
specifying a constant simple style
object and specifying a keypair value of
color background color margin font
family and apply that object as the
style parameter which would result in
this styled output how do you style
react components using a css style sheet
so here's an external style sheet so
we've written all the styling rules in a
separate css file app.css we've imported
that at the top of the app.js react
class and lo and behold you have the
output simplified as generated on your
page let's explain the use of css
modules in react so a css module file is
created.module.css is the extension the
css inside a module file is available
only for the component that is importing
it so there are no naming conflicts so
dot button is the css styling inside
button.module.css
and that is what we've imported from in
the app.js file so when you view the
button style start button is the styling
picked up from the
button.module.css file i'm sure you must
have watched our previous videos on
angular if you haven't watched them
already i suggest you go through them
for easy tutorials on various topics on
angular
now angular developers are in demand and
i'm sure you need help in cracking your
next interview so in this video i
present you some commonly asked angular
interview questions
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure you hit the subscribe button and
the bell icon to never miss an update
now let's begin
i've classified the questions into two
sections
one is the beginner level questions and
one is the advanced level questions
so now let's begin with beginner level
questions
starting with the most basic what
exactly is angular
now angular is an open source javascript
front-end framework which is completely
written in typescript
this framework brings structure and
consistency to web applications and
provides excellent scalability and
maintainability
now it's primarily aimed to develop
single page applications and is
maintained by google
it uses html syntax to express your
application's components clearly it is
designed for web desktop and mobile
platforms
next up is what exactly is typescript
now typescript is a superset of
javascript that offers excellent
consistency
it is highly recommended as it provides
some syntactic sugar and makes the code
base more comfortable to understand and
maintain
ultimately typescript code compiles down
to javascript that can run efficiently
in any environment
now typically typescript is installed as
an npm package and thus can be installed
with the following command that is npm
install hyphen g typescript
moving on to our third question
what exactly is data binding and which
type of data binding does angular deploy
now data binding is a phenomenon that
allows any internet user to manipulate
web page elements
now it generally uses dynamic html and
does not require any complex scripting
or programming
we use data binding in pages that
contain interactive components such as
forms calculators
tutorials and games
data binding makes incremental display
of a web page more convenient
when it comes to angular it uses the
two-way data binding
any changes made to the user interface
are reflected in the corresponding model
state
conversely any changes in the model
state are reflected in the ui state
this allows the framework to connect the
dom to the model data via the controller
next question what are single page
applications
now single page applications are web
applications that load just once with
new features just being mere additions
to the user interface
it does not load new html pages to
display the content
instead it's generated dynamically
this is made possible through
javascript's ability to manipulate the
dom elements on the existing page itself
an spa approach is faster thus providing
a seamless user experience
differentiate between angular and
angularjs
now here's a simple table for you so
here are the features that we're going
to differentiate the two on the basis of
first is language angularjs uses
javascript while angular uses typescript
when it comes to architecture angularjs
supports the model view controller
design while angular uses components and
directives
angularjs is not supported by mobile
browsers
while angular supports all mobile
browsers
angularjs does not support dependency
injection while angular does
when it comes to routing at route
provider is used to provide routing
information in the case of angularjs and
in case of angular at route
configuration is used to define routing
information
when it comes to management angularjs is
difficult to manage with an increase in
source code size
while angular is better structured easy
to create and can manage bigger
applications
next up what are decorators in angular
decorators are a design pattern or
functions that define how angular
features work
now they are used to make prior
modifications to a class service or
filter
angular supports four types of
decorators namely class decorators
property decorators method decorators
and parameter decorators
next question mention some advantages of
angular first up is custom components
now angular enables users to build their
own components that can pack
functionality along with rendering logic
into reusable pieces
this is achieved with the help of these
components
data binding as discussed earlier
angular enables users to effortlessly
move data from javascript code to the
view and react to users events without
having to write any code manually
angular supports dependency injection
which enables users to write modular
services and inject them wherever they
needed
when it comes to testing tests are
first-class tools and angular has been
built from ground up with testability in
mind you will have the ability to test
every part of your application and that
is highly recommended
next up is comprehensive angular is a
full-fledged framework and provides
out-of-the-box solutions for server
communication routing with your
application and more
lastly angular is cross-platform and
compatible with multiple browsers an
angular application can typically run on
all browsers be it chrome firefox safari
and operating systems like windows mac
os and linux
what's new with angular 10 first up is
that older versions of typescript are
not supported
previous versions of angular supported
typescript 3.6 3.7 and even 3.8 but with
angular 10 typescript bumped to
typescript 3.9
warnings about common js imports now
logging of unknown property bindings or
element names in templates is increased
to the error level which was previously
a warning
angular now supports an optional strict
setting which offers a stricter project
setup when you create a new workspace
there's an addition of ngcc features
with a program based entry point finder
there are common compiler updates
and updated url routing
angular 10 has several deprecated apis
that were previously redundant
with angular 10 version there have been
a number of bug fixes important ones
being the compiler avoiding undefined
expressions and the core avoiding a
migration error
new default browser configuration
browser configuration for new projects
has been upgraded to outdo older and
less used browsers
next up is core all the warnings will be
now logged in as
errors next update is converting pre-iv
code now all the pre-iv dependencies
from npm should be transformed to iv
dependencies which is supposed to take
place as a precursor to running ngtse at
the application
and lastly we have service workers for
the service worker a fix has been put in
for a situation in which there was a
chance that the service worker would not
register when there is a long running
task or a recurring timeout
next up
is what are templates in angular
now angular templates are written with
html that contains angular-specific
elements and
attributes now in combination with
model and controllers information
these templates can be rendered to
provide a dynamic view to the user now
templates are a very predominant feature
of angular that describe how information
can be displayed in the view
next question is what are annotations in
angular
now these annotations are used to create
an annotation array
they are basically the metadata set on
the class that is used to reflect the
metadata library
what are directives in angular
directives are attributes that allow the
user to write new html syntax specific
to their applications
now these execute whenever the angular
compiler finds them in the dom
now again angular supports three
different types of directives there are
component directives attribute
directives and structural directives
next up what is aot compilation and what
are some of its advantages
now aots that stands for ahead of time
compiler basically converts the angular
html and typescript into javascript code
during the build phase
that is before the browser downloads and
runs the code
so basically all the html and typescript
code is converted to javascript during
the build phase which means no
additional time is spent on converting
it into javascript later during the run
phase right so when it comes to
advantages
of course there's faster rendering there
are fewer asynchronous requests
it has smaller angular framework
download size
there's quick detection of errors and
this also offers better security
moving on to the next question what are
components
now components are the most basic
building blocks of the ui in an angular
application
now every component is associated with a
template and is a subset of directives
only one component can be instantiated
per element in a template
now an angular application typically
consists of a root component which is
basically the app component
and then it branches out into other
components creating a hierarchy
now every component is decorated with
the help of at component decorator which
provides additional information
and component must belong to the ng
module
lastly components implement something
called the lifecycle hooks you will
learn about them a little later in the
video
next up what are pipes in angular
now pipes are simple functions that are
designed to accept a particular input
value
process this value and return an output
which is a transformed value now angular
supports several built-in pipes however
you can also create custom pipes that
cater to your needs
but to speak about a few saline features
pipes are defined using the pipe symbol
pipes can be chained with other pipes
and pipes can be provided with arguments
by using the colon sign
next up what are pure pipes
now these pipes are pipes
that use pure functions
as a result of this a pure pipe doesn't
use any internal state and the output
remains the same as long as the
parameters past stay the same
angular calls a pure pipe only when it
detects a change in the parameters being
passed
now a single instance of a pure pipe is
used throughout all components
next up what are impure pipes
now for every change detection cycle in
angular
these impure pipes are called regardless
of the change in the input fields
as long as there's a change detected
these pipes are called
as a result multiple pipe instances are
created for these pipes
now inputs passed to these pipes can
also be mutable
by default all pipes are pure however
you can also mention impure pipes using
the pure property
now here's a code for specifying impure
pipes you can use the pure property and
either mention true or false true
meaning it's a pure pipe and false
indicates that it's an impure pipe
next up what is the pipe transform
interface
now as the name suggests the interface
receives an input value
and transforms it into the desired
format with a transform method
it is typically used to implement custom
pipes now here's again a small piece of
code
now you can see that the pipe transform
interface is being used which in turn
executes the transform method now this
transform method is the one that is
responsible to change your input and
give a transformed output
moving on what is ng module
now ng modules are basically containers
that reserve a block of code to an
application domain or a workflow
now the at ng module takes a metadata
object that describes how to compile a
components template
and generate an injector at runtime
in addition to this ng module also
identifies the modules components
detectives services pipes and also
ensures that it makes them public so
that external components can use them
all of this is taken care of by the ng
module
next up what are filters in angular
now filters are used to format an
expression and present it to the user
they can be used in view templates
controllers or services
now to name a few
there's
date filter which formats a date to a
specified format
there's filter filter that selects a
subset of items from an array
there's the json filter which formats an
object to adjacent string
there's limit 2 which limits an array or
a string into a specified number of
elements or characters
then there's lowercase which formats a
string to lowercase and so on
moving on to the next question what is
view encapsulation in angular
now
view encapsulation basically defines
whether the template and styles defined
within the component can affect the
application or vice versa
angular provides three encapsulation
strategies
there's emulated encapsulation which
means that the styles from the main html
propagate to the component
then there is native which indicates
that the styles from the main html do
not propagated the component meaning it
does not affect the component and lastly
there's none which means that styles
from the component propagate back to the
main html and therefore are visible to
all the components on the page now this
indicates any different types of changes
and how it is affecting the entire
application
moving on what are controllers now as
the name suggests
controllers control the data of angular
applications
they are regular javascript objects and
the ng-controller directive defines the
application controller
next question what do you understand by
scope in angular
now the scope in angular binds the html
that is basically the view and the
javascript that is the controller it is
also an object with the available
properties and methods required for your
application
now when you make a controller in
angular you pass the dollar scope object
as an argument
moving on to the most commonly asked
question explain the life cycle hooks in
angular
as discussed earlier every component in
angular has a life cycle
angular creates and renders these
components and also destroys them before
removing them from the document object
model
it is achieved with the help of these
life cycle hooks now let's have a look
at them
first up is ng on changes now this
responds when angular sets or resets
data bound input properties
ng on it
is a hook that initializes the directive
or a component after angular first
displays the data bound properties and
sets the components input properties
ng do check detects and acts upon the
changes that angular can't or won't
detect on its own
ng after content init responds after ng
projects external content into the
components view
ng after content checked response after
angular checks the content projected
into the component
ng after viewing it responds after
angular initializes the components views
and child views
ng after view checked responds after
angular checks the components views and
the child views
lastly there's ng on destroy which
cleans up just before angular destroys
the directive or the component
moving on to the next question what is
string interpolation in angular
now string interpolation is a one-way
data binding technique that is used by
angular
now it outputs the data from typescript
code to html view
it is typically denoted with the help of
curly braces and it helps display data
from the component to the view to help
you understand it's working i've created
a variable called name
here in my
app.component.ts file and
initialize it to simply learn and back
in my html file i've created
a heading tag a header tag which
displays the name of the company is
and i have interpolated here with the
help of double curly braces
so when i run the file the output looks
something like this
the name of the company is simply learn
so this is how string interpolation is
achieved in angular
moving on to next question
what are template statements
template statements are properties or
methods used in html
for responding to user events
now with these template statements the
application that you create or you're
working on can have the capability to
engage users through actions such as
submitting forms or displaying dynamic
content
most common example is the button
tag the template here is delete hero
this method is called when the user
clicks on the button
so this brings interactivity to your
application
with that we come to the end of the
first section which included the
beginner level questions
moving on let's look at some advanced
level questions
what is the difference between ahead of
time and just in time compilation
now ahead of time compilation converts
your code during the build time before
the browser downloads and runs the code
in case of just-in-time compilation this
process is a way of compiling computer
code to machine code during the
execution phase
aot ensures faster rendering to the
browser
while just in time is basically a
dynamic compilation
in case of ahead of time compiling
the user should include the hyphen
hyphen aot option with the ng build or
ng-sub command
and jit compilation is the default
compilation when you run the ng build or
ng serve cli commands
next up explain the add component
decorator
now here's a simple screenshot of what
that component decorator encompasses
is it is basically a typescript class
that is used to create
components
this genre of class is then decorated
with the at component decorator
the decorator's purpose is to accept a
meta data object that provides relevant
information about the component
now the image above shows an app
component
which is a pure typescript class
decorated with that component decorator
the object that gets accepted by the
decorator provides properties like
template url selectors
style urls
and many more now here the template url
property points to an html file defining
what you see on the application
moving ahead what are services in
angular angular services
perform tasks that are used by multiple
components
now these tasks could be data fetching
network connections or database
management among others
they perform all the operational tasks
for the components and avoid rewriting
of code
a service can be written once and then
injected into all the components that
use it
generally components are used to only
display information on the ui they do
not perform any other back-end tasks
to perform tasks like validating
information or network connections etc
you can make use of a service
one advantage is that this service can
be injected into multiple components
that make use of the same piece of code
with this you can avoid redundancy
moving on what are promises and
observables
now while both the components deal with
asynchronous events in angular
promises handle one such event at a time
while observables handle a sequence of
events over some time
so to give you a brief explanation
promises emit a single value at a time
while observables are only executed when
subscribed to them using the subscribe
method
now promises also execute immediately
after they are created and they're not
cancelable
while observables help perform
operations like for each filter retry
etc promises push errors to the child
promises and observables can be
unsubscribed to so that the listener
stops receiving further
values next up what is ng on init and
how is it defined
now again here's a small snippet of code
ng on init is a life cycle hook as we
discussed earlier and there is a
callback method that is run by angular
to indicate that a component has been
created
it takes no parameters and returns a
void type so i'm sure you can
see here in the code
it takes no parameters and returns a
void
next up explain the use of ng4 in a tag
or explain the ng for directive
now the ng for directive is basically
like a for loop it is used to build
lists and tables and html templates
so in simple terms this directive is
used to iterate over an array or an
object and create template for each such
element
now in the snippet you can see there is
let items and item list and then i have
string interpolated
the
variable item
so let item here creates a local
variable that will be available inside
the template
of items indicates
that we are iterating over the items
iterable
and the asterisk before ng4 creates a
parent template
next up what are template and reactive
forms so there are two different methods
to create forms we have the template
driven approach and we have the reactive
form approach
so let's have a look at them
in case of template driven approach the
conventional form tag is used to create
forms
angular automatically interprets
and creates a form object representation
for this tag controls can be added to
the form using the ng model tag
multiple controls can be
grouped using the ng control group
module
now a form value can be generated using
the form dot value object and form data
is exported as json values
basic html validations can be used to
validate the form fields
in the case of custom validations
directives can be used
when it comes to reactive forms
this approach basically revolves around
data flows and propagation of change
now with reactive forms the component
directly manages the data flows between
the form controls and the data models
the active forms are code driven unlike
template-driven approach
reactive forms break the traditional
declarative approach and eliminate the
anti-pattern of updating data via the
two-way data binding method
typically reactive form control creation
is synchronous and can be unit tested
with synchronous programming techniques
moving on what is bootstrap how is it
added to angular
now bootstrap is a powerful toolkit it
is a collection of basic html css and
javascript tools for creating and
building responsive web applications
there are two ways to embed bootstrap
libraries
first up is using the bootstrap cdn
which is the content delivery network
now this enables users to load the css
and javascript files remotely from its
servers
the other way is to use angular
bootstrap via npm
now this
is used to add bootstrap to your angular
project by installing it into your
project folder
now you can use commands like npm
install bootstrap and npm install jquery
to install them for your project if you
wish to learn bootstrap in detail i
highly suggest you check out our video
on angular bootstrap the tutorial
explains how to embed bootstrap and user
to create and good looking angular
applications
what is eager and lazy loading
eager loading is a default module
loading strategy
now all the feature modules under eager
loading are loaded before your
application even starts
this is typically used for small size
applications since lesser modules are
used all of these modules are loaded
initially which makes
running of these kind of applications
extremely fast
when it comes to lazy loading all the
loading happens dynamically
all feature modules are loaded on demand
it is used for bigger applications where
the modules are not required at the
start of applications
this makes the application faster since
no time is spent on loading unnecessary
modules
next up what type of dom does angular
implement
dom or document object model treats an
xml or html document as a tree structure
in which each node is an object
representing a part of the document
now angular uses the regular dom
this updates the entire tree structure
of html tags until it reaches the data
that has to be updated
now to ensure that the speed and
performance are not affected angular
implements something called as a change
detection
next up how is dependency injection
achieved in angular
now dependencies are objects or services
that a component needs to perform
functions correct
now with the help of
dependency injection
these classes can request dependencies
from external sources rather than
creating them on their own here i've
created a service called demo service
using the command ngg service demo
service
and i've also added a small snippet of
code when you create
that service
now these
services can be injected to your main
component and perform various functions
next up how does angular routing work
now i'm sure you must have observed that
the url changes every time you click on
your user interface on an application
correct every time you navigate through
the application or move from one page to
another the url changes
now this means that
the application is being routed or
you're navigating through the
application
so basically routing helps navigate
through a web application especially in
case of single page applications now as
discussed earlier single page
applications are loaded just once so any
new content that is being displayed is
just a mere addition it's not being
loaded again so routing plays a vital
role in case of single page applications
typically it is specified with the help
of the forward slash and
followed by a path that defines a new
content
now i'm just taking the same example
that i took before
this was the example for string
interpolation however you can see that
we have a navigation bar here with four
different options for that is home about
services and login and for home and
login i've created
a path and added routing to it so when i
click on the home icon
you can see that
some content is being displayed onto the
screen
and if you observe you can see that
there is
a forward slash with the path name home
here which indicates that routing has
occurred
same with login when i click on it the
path changes and the login page appears
if you wish to learn
the concept of routing i suggest you
check out a video the tutorial explains
routing in detail
moving on what are form control and form
groups
now a form control is basically a class
that enables validation
for each input field an instance of this
class is created
and these instances help check the
values of the field and see if they are
touched untouched dirty pristine valid
invalid and so on so for every field in
the form
the data that is being provided is
validated with the help of these
controls
if it is dirty it means that
the value has been changed if the data
provided holds good for a particular
condition then the
control is said to be valid and so on
with the help of these controls you can
determine if the value provided is
legitimate or not this can be achieved
with the help of form control
when it comes to form group
and the form group class represents a
group of controls
now a form
can have multiple control groups
the form group class returns true if all
the controls are valid and also provides
validation errors if any next up is how
is testing achieved in angular
now angular uses jasmine to run various
tests
the jasmine framework allows various
functionalities to write different kinds
of test cases
the task runner for these tests is
typically karma
and karma uses a configuration file to
set the startup reporters and the
testing framework
next question is what is package.json
now npm installs package.json when a new
workspace is created
now this file includes a starter set of
packages some of which are required by
angular
now typically it's organized into two
groups one is dependencies these are
essential to run your applications
and we have depth dependencies these are
essential to develop applications if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
hello this is matthew and we're going to
be going through some of the simple
questions that you would be asked during
a node.js interview
what we're going to do is we're actually
going to break out the section into
three key areas there'll be beginner
questions there'll be intermediate
questions and advanced questions
and the expectation is as you go through
this video is that these questions could
be
pushed together as you're going through
the interview kind of think of it like
this is if you answer the beginner
questions that you would get asked at
the beginning of the interview with
confidence and surety
then the client is going to then jump to
those intermediate advanced questions
quite quickly and they're looking for
people who can help them serve and solve
their problems at that more intermediate
and advanced level so let's just get
started
so the first question you're probably
going to be asked is you know you know
what is node.js you know do you know
what it's for and essentially node.js is
one of the most popular if not the most
popular open source cross-platform
javascript programs it allows you to
build out web applications that run on
the server it's extremely flexible it
allows you to implement a lot of
solutions outside of just the the core
programming runtime
and allows you to build solutions
extremely quickly in an open source
mindset for devops
it is used essentially for creating
client size web applications
we'll see this later on and you may want
to talk a little bit about
using express js and how you can build
out apis
to work with node.js and connecting to
databases such as mongodb
and that is also really good for being
able to store
data intensive applications that are
asynchronous and event driven in their
model
and this is important when you're
talking about creating applications that
can scale rapidly
so you're going to then ask be asking
how does nodejs work well node.js itself
is actually built on the v8 engine and
the v8 javascript engine is the same
engine that runs javascript in your
chrome web browser extremely fast
it allows for
high output and non-blocking
through your i o input outputs and is is
single threaded event loop
so you're going to be then asked you
know where can you use node.js and and
the reality is the applications for
node.js keep expanding but there are
some core applications that you can work
with node.js right now so such as web
applications distributed system and
network applications
probably referencing the web
applications is a really good starting
point because here you can actually talk
about maybe some examples that you've
done where you're building out some of
these web applications uh indeed one of
the things that you want to be
consistently doing and peppering your
answers with is examples of work that
you have done
now it doesn't matter if those examples
are purely experimental or
training examples that you've done the
fact that you've actually worked with
node.js and created a distributed system
or a web application
is really valuable because it shows that
the person that you're meeting with that
you have knowledge and understanding and
practical experience of applying the
theory of working with new js with the
practice of working with nodejs
so be asked about you know
essentially the i o refers to the
transfer of data in and out of uh a
system and that's really it you know and
there's a reason why google calls their
conference io it's the transfer of data
in and out of our brains at that
conference the application is same here
it's about moving data in and out of
systems through using node.js
and that every um event can be
tracked and whether it's on a physical
device and network or files within the
system again it's input and output
so let's go through and you know you're
going to be asked yo can you explain the
difference between front-end and
back-end development and this is a
question that i get asked a lot when i'm
meeting with clients um you know people
get really confused about what is the
difference between front-end and
back-end development
bottom line front-end is what gets
resolved inside of your web browser or
the app on your
mobile device back end is what gets
resolved um essentially um what we call
the the back office or server side
applications but it's becoming more and
more synonymous for what gets run in the
cloud
so web applications um really get a lot
of the functionality of web application
gets run in the front end anything with
css html5 uh client-side javascript so
you can get right in the front-end
everything else such as connecting to a
database um gets run behind the scenes
in the back end
and so you know anything that's going to
have like graphics is going to be on the
front-end uh
are going to be run on the back end and
then just finally some of the scripting
languages are used on on the front end
so html css javascript those are all
common
core scripting languages that you would
use
you can use frameworks such as angularjs
and react.js or vue
those would be a front-end frameworks
backend frameworks will include java php
python and node.js or some of the
back-end technologies you'd also throw
in their
net as well i mean it's just the whole
you know litany of front-end and
back-end technologies and frameworks
that you can use
and this is actually a good point to
kind of explain the experience you have
outside of just working with node.js but
other technologies that you've been
working with that potentially that the
client is also using
so another question you're going to be
asked when you're looking at node.js is
you know can you tell me about npm and
so when somebody asks you what is npm
the first thing you can respond is do
you mean node package manager and the
reason why you want to respond like that
is that you want to qualify that
question with understanding that you
know what they're talking about but you
want them to verify that and so node
packet manager is npm
and it's responsible for packaging all
of your modules that you're working with
in node.js and we have a whole series of
videos that we've done on node.js and
every single one of them uh includes
references to mpm
so you're gonna be asking you know so
okay you tell me um what it is you know
can you go into a little bit more um
details you can provide two main
functionalities and so one of them is
being able to
manage online repositories of modules
and packages um so you can go to like
search.nodejs.org
and you can find a packages that you can
install into your solution
such as express.js
and it also provides a command line
utility that allows you to manage
your packages very quickly through
terminal window or command line i use vs
code a lot visual studio code and it has
a command line utility built right into
it that allows me to interact with npm
so what are some of the modules in
node.js and so you know modules um in
node.js they're essentially like
javascript libraries so you can think of
some of the javascript libraries that
you may have used the functionality is
somewhat the same but they're designed
for node.js
and to run on the server and there are
ways in which you can go ahead and
create some of those modules so for
instance
if we're creating a web server you can
actually use the require commands to be
able to require that the server be there
so the example we have on the right hand
side
shows that we really do need to have
http which is a web server and we
require that to be installed and so that
if you're running that
npm package it will actually install the
http server and then uh you can actually
write some code to actually then listen
on the local host port 2000 for where
you'll be running your application
and there are just you know there's a
whole bunch of modules that uh come
with node.js right out of the gate and
here are some of the modules that you
have and we also referenced that just
earlier on http is a core module for
running a
web server
you have a utility function that is
useful for developers to
assess and features within your node.js
project you have a url module for any
url passing you'd be doing
and you also have a stream which allows
you to be able to stream data in and out
of your system and be able to manage how
that's being worked and then zlib which
allows you to compress and decompress
files so that you can keep
your storage of files
to a minimum
so a question you're going to be asked
is you know why is node.js being
preferred over end technologies such as
java and php and particularly gyro it's
a very mature stable language it's been
around for more than 20 years you know
php
runs some of them the
most powerful and largest websites out
there such as facebook so why would you
use node.js well the first response is
kind of a gimme but it is really fast
and if you watched any of the videos
that we've done on node.js
building out solutions and developing
the solutions you'll see
just how fast it is
the second is the
really kind of the secret source with
node.js is the node package manager and
no package manager allows you to install
additional functionality such as express
or [ __ ] as a database into your
solution
really quickly and there's over 000
bundles available for node package
manager
if you're building out a
real-time application that's data
intensive and you need to have apis
quickly developed then node.js is
another great it's really the great
solution for you it allows you to build
out these solutions really quickly
and there is a easy synchronization
between the server and the client
due to the code base
and then finally because the structure
of node.js is javascript if you are
making the pivot from being a front-end
web developer to node.js it's just going
to make it a lot easier for you to pick
up
node.js because you have that common
language of javascript
and on top of that javascript is the
world's most popular
scripting language
so let's talk about some of the
differences between angular node.js and
so the reason why this question may come
up is the person interviewing you is
seeing whether or not you do know the
difference between a front-end
framework and a back-end framework and
this is one of those questions where you
can go well
there are differences but the
differences are because they complement
each other
so angular is a front-end development
framework whereas node.js is a server
side in framework other differences
though between the actual frameworks
themselves is that angular is written in
typescript which is a modification of
javascript nodejs is written in c and c
plus
angular is used for building out single
page uh client-side web applications and
so that's a key word there is
client-side
whereas node.js is about building out
fast and scalable server-side network
applications and so
again the two complement each other
angular splits web applications into the
mvc and model view control components
whereas node.js generates a lot of
database grades it does more than that
as well but you can think of node.js
that glue to your database
so let's talk a little bit about when
you're connecting to a database with
node.js and so um you're going to
probably ask you know what is
the most popular database used with
node.js and there are a couple um
mongodb is largely the most popular
nosql cross-platform database
mysql is also very popular and that's a
more traditional relational database
um you would go with mongodb for really
more modern solutions when you're
looking at creating an application
that's going to really scale into just
managing masses and masses
of data that has to be
created read updated and deleted very
very quickly
for
some of the other popular libraries that
you use for node.js express.js is a very
popular one and i really like working
with express.js allows me to build out
web applications really quickly
more importantly it allows me to build
out apis very quickly and which you know
apis are essentially web applications
themselves but being able to do that
very quickly with a framework like
express.js is very useful
mongoose is an application that makes
connecting to a [ __ ] database really
easy so um here is an example of
express.js which is a in itself really a
flexible budge a solution that you can
do lots with and mongoose which is a
more
focused solution
which allows you know to you make it
easier to connect to your databases
so you know what are the pros and cons
of working with node.js there's lots of
ways we explained this earlier on that
you can actually build out
applications that run on the cloud why
would you you know what's are the pros
and cons so a pro is that
node.js is extremely fast a processing
an event based model uh it really is
fast a con is if you have something that
is a very heavy computational task it's
not so good at that
now i will caveat that this is that
node.js is getting better all the time
and so
you might have to be provide an example
of what a very heavy computational task
is and that may be
calculating
a risk on an insurance application
against
many many variables that may be
something that's seen as computationally
very heavy but what you can do in that
example is you can offload
the task to another solution that's
designed for it and use apis to pass the
data back and forth
pro
javascript is used for building out your
applications with
node.js great lots of people know
javascript
a
restriction and again this is evolving
as javascript itself evolves is that
when you do a callback you may end up
doing lots of nested callbacks
if you're doing something that's very
complicated
again another way around the con and so
this is one of the things that i always
look for is if you have a blocker or a
barrier
how do you get around that barrier and
so for instance when you're talking to
your recruiter
you can say look the reason why i use
node.js is that it's fast it's
event-based driven i can use javascript
there are some challenges and but what i
do to get around those challenges are
and that's where you can say that you
know you may run the complex script off
and you may write that in net or java or
php and then use an api to do the
response back into node.js so you get
the benefits of both worlds but minimize
the investment in having to manage a
complex environment such as java versus
a relatively simple environment with
node.js
the node package manager makes it
extremely easy to access
just an awful lot of functionality with
over 50 000 packages there's a package
for that
so from being able to have a
tool that creates unique identifiers
that you might need to have for
generating content that gets posted into
a database through to being able to
connect to databases through you know to
running so many different solutions and
the npm package manager with its access
to so many different packages makes it
great
for
getting access to all that content now
con is working with relational databases
with node.js isn't as easy as a nosql
database now you can do it and there are
ways around that and what i would do
when this question comes up is always
kind of pivot to say hey this is how you
can actually then
get around building out that application
pro for node.js designed for streaming
huge amounts of data in and out a con is
that node.js is singles threaded and so
it can be cpu intensive
but again there are ways around that and
a good way around that is uh scaling
your solution in an elastic environment
such as the cloud
so what is the command used to import an
external library and so to import an
external library the command is the
require command and so an example we
have here is uh you can start a variable
and the variable's going to be for http
and you're going to then require the
http service and that means that the
application itself won't run unless the
external library the http library is
installed
okay so those were our introductory
questions for node.js let's kind of
pivot and take a look at the
intermediate questions that you would be
asked
so what does event driven programming
mean so event driven programming means
that if something happens something else
will happen in response so for instance
if you click a mouse
that mouse click is an event that means
something has to respond to that event
uh just think of it as cause and effect
it's just the basic motion of physics so
that's what event driven programming
means you also look at it as a callback
function
so that when an element is executed
something will happen in response
so what is an event loop in node.js
so an event loop in node.js is when you
do an asynchronous call and
what that essentially means is that
you are sending out
data and then a non-blocking input
output
from node.js is pulling data back in
what is an event emitter in node.js so
an event emitter has really two areas of
focus one is that it manages
the classes that hold all the objects
within your event and we have an example
of this on the right hand side
and then whenever an event actually is
thrown
the functions are then called on that
event synchronously so for instance we
have in our example on the right hand
side we create an event and then we have
the functions and that executed in a
series from
that event
so let's talk about the api functions in
node.js so there's two types uh one is
an asynchronous non-blocking function
and the second is a synchronous blocking
function and the difference between the
two of them is asynchronous is that
there is no uh structure to the order
for how the
api is resolved synchronous means that
when the feedback from the api is
received you have to execute
the response in a series for how the
response is sent to you
so what is a package.json file so the
package.json file is at the heart of our
node.js
package when we actually will initialize
a solution a folder to be a node.js
package
you'll find that the package itself
holds all of the metadata that's
particular to the project you're working
on such as project name version
requirements it is you have to have
installed in the root of the directory
for the project and again look at any of
the videos that we have on node.js we do
have demonstrations within those videos
that actually then go through and break
out um how to create that root package
and you'll see how you can actually then
go ahead and update the instructions or
the metadata within the package
so here we have an example of what that
metadata looks like so again this kind
of continues that question of what is a
package.json file and you may be asked
you know what is the metadata and why is
it important and the metadata is a
basic
json collection of pairing of
a key details such as name version
description and then the custom version
that you put so for instance under name
you could create a name for your project
there can't be any spaces
what is the version and the description
and what is the main or starting path
for the solution typically that would be
index.js
but it could be anything.js but index.js
is typical simply because
index.html is the starting point for a
typical web application
so how would you use a url module in
node.js
so with the url module what it allows
you to do is really two things one is
that it provides the resolution and
passing of a url
for utilities in your application
and then it allows you to
extend your module with built-in
solutions and split up the web address
into a readable format
so in this example
we have the url and
the response it would would give
for that url which would then be a year
and month
and it would be in a readable format so
it would read out as
2020 and then the month
so what is express.js and you've heard
me mention this a couple of times in the
video and we actually have a separate
video on express.js and express.js is a
web application framework that allows
you to build out web solutions
for both mobile and traditional desktop
right inside of node.js so it's very
easy to use
being able to install web.js is as
simple as requiring express to be
installed in the example that we have
here on the screen it's a full solution
of showing how to actually build out a
solution with web.js
so in this example
you start off the first two lines uh
require express to be installed and the
store comes from node packet manager
then we have a simple application that
will then send to the browser window
a hello world message confirming that
express is up and running and then the
third block of content starting with
virus server actually will define the
port
where your application is going to run
so in this instance
the port is going to run on localhost
and the
port will be port 8081
and so you can actually go to localhost
colon8081 and when you do that that will
trigger the application that will
forward up the message hello world and
it's all coming from express.js
so what are streams and node.js so
streams are objects that allow you to
read and write data continuously back
and forth within your application and
there's really four different types of
streams there's readable writable duplex
and transform
the readable one stream through which
data can be read
uh the writable streams that you can
actually write to
a duplex is a stream where is both
readable and writeable
and
transform our streams that can be
manipulate the data
while it is being read or written
so how do you update and delete a
dependency so say for instance we want
to install
something like express so if you wanted
to install express what you would do is
you would just write them inside of your
project you want to go to terminal
window and write in the command npm
install express
if you want to update the
dependencies within your node package
manager to update all of them all you
have to do is
write the command npm update all
dependencies
and then if you want to explicitly
uninstall a dependency such as
express.js
that's using the uninstall command and
so that would again be going to terminal
window and you would type npm uninstall
express
and again it's really easy to create a
simple server in node.js that will run a
simple command
the http service is actually built into
node.js
you don't need to use expressjs i i
typically use express js when i want to
do a web server because typically what i
find is that i will want to go and do
something more complicated but if you
want to do something that illustrates
just the core functionality within
node.js you can actually just require
the core http service that actually
comes as part of node.js and then you
can actually then go ahead and
tell it to create a service and then to
write in plain text a command
or text string such as in this case
it'll be hello world and that would pop
out and then the final line is to then
listen that if you go to a web browser
that's on port
127.0.01 or localhost
and go to
port colon 8080 once you actually go to
that that will trigger this application
and you'll get the text hello world pop
up on your screen
so explain synchronous and non-blocking
apis in node.js
so all the apis
in node.js are asynchronous which means
that they are non-blocking which means
you can run them continuously um and
scale around that which is just
fantastic so one of the reasons why
node.js can scale so fast and the eighth
means that the apis can return data send
data after it's been called and really
increase the efficiency of events as
they are triggered within node.js
so how do you implement async and
node.js and so the example that we have
on the left hand side allows us to
trigger async and it's using the async
function and as you can see in this
example
it's actually something that can be done
very quickly in this example we're
actually
making a command to logo host and app
that's running on port 3000 and then
depending on
what we get if there's an error message
and then we'll have error message go to
the console log which is the terminal
window and if
we get a response to an application
then we'll actually get a positive
response which would be fetched response
so
again very quickly and easy that you use
the async function
to be able to build out and you to get
your
asynchronous code
so what is the purpose of module exports
so
a module export is a way to encapsulate
your the entire code for a solution in a
single package in a single file and then
you can then
share that with other developers so
you're all working from the same
environment
so what is a callback function in
node.js a callback function is
essentially that once you run and you've
triggered an event and the response has
been given
you want to be able to then have a
callback to validate that the task is
complete
all right let's move on to the final set
of questions which is advanced node.js
questions
so what is reppl in node.js so repo
stands for read eval print and loop and
this is a reference to the
unix and linux background that node.js
has
so rapple will perform the following
tasks the read will be actually
passing the javascript you'll read that
and store it in memory eval
takes and evaluates the data structure
print will then print the results often
on the console window or onto a web page
and then loop and loops the above
command until the user presses ctrl c
twice
what is the control flow function so the
control flow function is a piece of code
that runs between several of the
asynchronous functions and that's it it
actually controls how those functions
execute
so how control flow controls the
function calls and it does it through
four ways one is it controls the order
of execution
it collects the data it limits the
concurrency and then it also calls the
next step in a program again this is a
management tool for how your functions
are called within node.js
so what is the difference between fork
and spawn methods in
node.js so the essential difference
between the two of them is that if you
use the fork method it will actually
trigger and create a new instance of the
v8 engine the engine running node.js
and will then run the application in
that new instance
with spawn
it's somewhat similar it doesn't
actually generate a new v8 instance so
it's actually creating a new process but
it's within the same v8 instance as the
previous application that it was spawned
from
explain to me what is the use of buffer
class in nodejs
so with the buffer class what you're
looking at doing is you're actually
controlling the raw data of a set of
arrays and integers and the memory
allocation outside of the v8 heap buffer
class is used because pure javascript is
not compatible with binary data
what is piping in node.js
so
piping is the ability to connect the
output of one stream to another stream
that could be a data stream it could be
any stream that you're working with
but it does normally get used to pass
data from one stream to another
so what are some of the flags used in
the rewrite operation files
so r dash is used for read w's for
opening a file for writing
uh a dash is opening a file for
appending
so the collection that you have here you
don't have to really memorize all of
them but to have a few of them in the
back of your mind is always a good
reference point
so how would you open a file using
node.js
so
the syntax you would use would be the fs
dot open and that would then open up a
file
explain to me what callback hell is
so callback hell also known as the
pyramid of doom is when you have too
many
nested unreadable and unmanageable
callbacks intensively cycle within each
other and they're constantly reading to
each other and they're not able to
resolve the solution
and
this is a you know it's a big problem
and this is what why it's called
callback hell because you're not able to
finalize the the app you're working on
what is a reactive pattern in node.js
and so a reactor pattern is a concept of
non-blocking i o operations
can you explain to me the test pyramid
for node.js so the test pyramid and this
is standard for testing uh for all
devops is really split into three key
areas you have unit tests integration
tests and then end-to-end or e2e tests
the unit tests are tests that you
actually do in your raw code that you're
working on and the goal there is to be
able to validate that the code you're
writing is consistently working
integration allows you to
have tests that integrate your raw code
that you're working within your
application with other areas of an
application and then end to end is the
whole system the whole interface as it
were
for your solution
describe the exit codes of node.js
so annexa code is a specific code that
identifies the end of a specific process
and examples of exit codes are
unused uncalled fatal exception
fatal error
internal javascript evaluation area
these are all good examples of exit
codes
so what is
middleware can you explain the concept
of middleware in nodejs
so
with middleware it is the ability to be
able to connect to a system and get data
from it
that's outside of node.js so this may be
executing a type of code or updating a
modifying request in response to a
specific type of object and finishing
the request response cycle
you explain to me what are the types of
http requests that you may use when
working with node.js um there are
actually quite a lot but four of them
that you might use would be get post
head and delete
and these are if you've done any uh web
application before particularly worked
with forms inside of a web application
you're probably very familiar certainly
with get and post
again it's the request to retrieve data
post is generally used for changing
stating and data
head is similar to get um but also ask
for a response if there's no body
content so if you're using if you're
developing an api this would be a good
one to use and delete is used to delete
the predetermined source
so how would you connect to mongodb
database and with nodejs and you use
that using the [ __ ] client and the
example we have on the left hand side
and illustrates that
what is the use of node underscore emv
and so this node unsquare emv is an
environment variable that stands for
node environment in express server so
the example we have on the right hand
side allows you to illustrate how you
would do that for say a production
environment
so what are some of the various timing
features in node.js so
the timing functions that you can use
here set timeout and then clear timeout
and you to schedule code execution that
you'd have inside of your application
you also have set interval clear
interval to execute a block of code up
multiple times in your application
set intermediate and clear intermediate
to
execute code and that is at the end of
your application in this video we'll
discuss some of the frequently asked
questions in php interviews
now the questions are categorized in two
sections beginner and advanced questions
so without any further ado let us get
started with the beginner questions
now the most basic question
is what is php
so php stands for hypertext preprocessor
it is a server-side scripting language
that is embedded into html and is
generally used for dynamic web
development php is also a very
compatible language that is it also
works efficiently with almost 20
different databases such as mysql post
sql etc
next question what is a session in php
now sessions in php are used to store
data for users under a unique id which
can be then used across multiple web
pages of a website
next what is peer in php now peer
stands for php extension and application
repository
it is a framework and repository for the
reusable components focus on reusable
components of php containing code
snippets and libraries
next
is php considered a case sensitive
language so this is a very often asked
questions in interviews
so php is partially case sensitive since
variables in php are case sensitive
while functions and user defined
functions are not
next
name different types of data types in
php
so different data types in php include
integer
float string
boolean
array object
null and finally resource so there are
total eight different data types that
exist in php
next question
how is echo different from print
now echo it can output multiple strings
at a time while in case of print it can
output only a single string
now echo does not have a return value
while print always returns one
that is the reason that is echo is
faster because it does not have to
return a value while it is print is
slower in comparison to echo because it
always returns a value
now
as you can see
both of these commands echo and print
are used in the exact same way
next
what are the rules for naming a variable
now there are certain rules which you
have to follow or certain good coding
practices which you have to follow while
naming a variable in your php code so
variable name must always begin with
underscore or a letter so it cannot
begin with a number or a special
character for that matter next variable
names can include numbers but not
special characters so
suppose you want to name your variable
number one to three so you can use this
variable but you cannot use number at
the rate one two three since special
characters are not included
next a variable in php is declared using
this dollar sign followed by the
variable name
now as you can see this is how we
declare a variable dollar my underscore
variable you can also put a number in
between or at the end while naming a
variable just not at the start next
name some popular php frameworks so some
of the popular php frameworks include
symphony codeigniter
cake php and laravel
moving on how to check if a defined
variable is null or not
so is a thank function is used to check
if the defined variable has any value or
not so to use this suppose you have this
block of code in front of you so
suppose you want to check if this x
variable that you've defined is null or
not so what you do is you put the is it
function inside the if condition and it
will return
true if it's
not null
while it will return false
if it is a null value since it is not
null it returns true and we can display
echo as variable x is not null while in
the case of variable y it is a null
value sin so
the if condition will be false and it
will not display anything
next
how are objects in php passed so objects
in php are always passed by value not by
reference
next question
how to display output directly to the
browser now
in cases you want to display your output
directly onto the browser while
running a piece of code you can use it
use
these special tags
to display an output directly to the
browser now as you may notice
these tags does not contain the php
written you can use them directly and
replace php with an equal to sign
followed by what you want to display and
end it with a question mark and a
closing bracket
moving on
what is defined function used for in php
now define is used to declare a constant
in php
also in contrast to the variables
there's no need for a dollar sign before
declaring a constant since the value of
a constant does not change
this is how you can use the define
function to declare a constant suppose
you want to declare the value of pi
as 3.14 throughout your php code
and which cannot be changed so we can
use define for that
next question is related to this
question since
what is constant function in useful in
php then so constant function returns
the value of a constant it is not used
to define a constant but it returns the
value of a constant so
suppose you
define a function constant using this
defined function and you want to return
this value
you can use this constant function for
that
next
is multiple inheritance supported in php
so php only supports single level
inheritance which means a class can be
extended from only one class using the
keyword extended
next
what are the different types of loops in
php so php consists of
a while loop
a do while loop a for loop and finally
up for each loop so php consists of
total for loops
next question
how to concatenate two strings in php
now
two strings can be easily concatenated
using the dot operator in php now to do
that
i'll show you with the help of a code
suppose you want to concatenate or join
these two strings str1 hello guys and
the second string would be and welcome
to simply learn and want to display
these strings together so to do that you
need to use this dot operator in echo as
you can see
this dot operator so first you write
this name of the first string then
followed by the dot operator i've given
this space
and then the next order operator because
this is also going to considered as a
string and then the third string
variable
and this is how you concatenate two
strings
next question what is the use of
function num ar arguments now this
function as you can see
is used to return the number of
arguments pass in a function so suppose
you pass a certain number of arguments
in a function and want to know how many
values or arguments for past you can use
this function for that so suppose in
this sample code you want to know how
many arguments were passed
in this
sample function so to do that we declare
a variable number of arguments and we
will equal it to the function of number
function number argument now we will
display it
and this sample has passed three
arguments so the output would be three
moving on
what are super global variables in php
now some predefined variables in php are
known as super global variables because
they are always accessible from any
function file or class regardless of
this code so in all in all they are
globally accessible so suppose you write
a piece of code and you declare a
variable inside it it would be a local
variable and could be accessed only in
that part of the code but in case of
super global variable they are
accessible throughout the entire code
they include global server request posts
get files enb cookie and session
moving on
how to invoke single line and multi-line
comments
now a single line comment in php can be
made using this hash followed by the
comment or
double slash followed by the comment
while in case of multi-line comments you
can use this hash star and write your
comments in multiple lines and enclose
it with a star and slash
what i'm going to do now is i am going
to show you
the
use of these comments in actual vs code
now let us take this block of code for
example now suppose you want to add a
com single line comment after this
variable so what you will do is
you can use this double slash
this
is
a
variable also you can use
slash
this is also a
variable so this is a single line line
comment now if you try to write
something else
after this in the next line it will take
it as part of the code not part of the
comment so what do you do
when you need to write multiple lines of
comment so suppose
you need to write two three lines about
this
line of code what you'll do is you'll
use a slash
star
now write the comment
this
is
displaying
simply learn
so this is a three line comment
which you can end simply
by star and a slash
this is how you write single line and
multi-line comments
now let's move on to the next question
that is
name some common applications of php so
some of the
most commonly used php applications are
system functions
firm handling so php is very commonly
used to handle the forms that you see on
the web pages
cred tasks now credit tasks are create
read update and delete so when you will
be working with databases this is a very
important part of using databases that
is crud and php is used very commonly in
that
next accessing cookies variables and set
keys
and finally data encryption php provides
security through some of its frameworks
which can be used
and is used very commonly throughout a
lot of websites
so now that we have gone through the
beginner level questions that are
frequently asked in php interviews
let us now move on to the advanced level
questions
so
the first question would be how can you
execute a php script from the command
line
now a php script from a command line can
be executed
by by opening the command line
and inside the command line you have to
specify the name of the script or name
of the php file that you want to run
suppose you want to run a php underscore
script.php
so you type in the name
of the php script that you want to run
and that particular php script will be
executed
next
differentiate between a dollar variable
and double dollar variable so what is
the difference between the two
now in case of a single dollar variable
is it is a simple variable that is
simply used to store data so as we
discussed earlier
it is a variable that we defined to
store different data types that is
integer float strings etc
while
a double dollar variable is a reference
variable of variable so
this is used to reference already
existing variables now to use
or to understand how these two work
you can see this
particular block of code here now in
this code what you need to focus on is
this is a simple variable hello which
contains the string welcome to learn and
we have defined another variable as well
which contains a string hello now in
this
echo as you can notice what we are doing
is we are using this
also before that you need to notice is
this is
the same string as the name of this
variable so first we are displaying this
variable
and then we are referencing this
variable here
so what it is doing is it is referencing
the value to another variable so hello
variable is being referenced so
when you execute this block of php
script what you get the output is hello
since this is the variable hello and
after that what you'll
get is welcome to simply learn since
this variable is a reference to this
variable
next
differentiate between get and post
method
now
get method is used to submit form data
while post method is also used for the
same feature
so the difference between them is get
method sends data as part of php page
url sorry web page url while a post
method sends data through http header
in get
the data since the data has been sent
through the url it is displayed in the
url of the webpage so it is not secure
while in case of post method it is a
secure form of
data transfer
hence
when developing a website for some
security purposes
usually we prefer post method
next up
how to connect to a database using a php
script
now suppose
if you
are asked this question in an interview
what you need to do is you need to just
write this block of code and explain it
to the interview now suppose we have a
php script
and we want to connect it to a database
what we need to do is we will create
three different
variables that is server name username
and password now
what we're going to do is we will create
another variable con that will be used
to connect it and then we'll use the
mysqli functions which will then pass
these variables to create a connection
so these variable values are localhost
username password these are the default
values now to check if the connection is
connected
what we're going to do is we will
use an if condition
if the con variable
gets and connect error we will display a
error message that is connection field
if not we will display connected
successfully
now as you can see here
these names can be the name of the
server that you're trying to connect i
have used localhost username password
for the default values you can use the
name of the database that you're trying
to connect your php script to
next up
what does final class and final method
mean in php
now a final class in php means that the
class cannot be extended
while a final method means that it
cannot be overridden
now as you can see in this block of code
we have used the final keyword for a
class and the final keyword for a
function now suppose
this final class is being inherited by
this child class what the program will
return is an error because once you use
this final keyword this class can not be
inherited and similarly
suppose this function is trying to be
overridden
by this part of the code
it cannot be because we have used the
final function
next question
differentiate between function
overloading and overriding
now function overloading the same
function is used for different purposes
based on the number of arguments inside
the function while in case of function
overriding
the same name and same argument function
is used in parent and child class
respectively to change the behavior of
parent class method now let me show you
and demonstrate the difference with an
example
so
let us look at this code so suppose you
have a function named show title which
does have contain a single parameter and
displays when called upon using this
parameter displays function1
now if you want to use the same
name of the function for a different
purpose what you can do is you can
increase or change the number of
parameters inside the function that is
it now contains two parameters so when
the same function is called using two
parameters it will function differently
and display function overloading so this
is how function overloading works
next
from this piece of code we can
understand function overriding suppose
you display a function demo in a base
class and you want to override this demo
function inside the
derived class so what you do is you make
another function with the same name
inside the derived class with some
different properties as you can see it
displays something different
now you create an object for the base
class and when you use this base class
object to call this demo function you
can use the properties of this function
here while if you create another object
that is object 2 for the derived class
and you use this object to call upon the
same demo function you are overriding
this base class demo function that was
inherited instead what it will use is it
will use the properties of the derived
demo function so that is how you
overload or override a class
function in php now let's move on to the
next question that is differentiate
between equal to equal to and triple
equal operator
so a double equal operator is generally
used to check if the value of two
operands are equal or not it is
generally used in case of conditional
statements
while a triple equals to operator
performs a type save comparison which
means that will that it will only return
true if both operands have the same type
and the same value
so
you can understand this more with this
piece of code so suppose
in this case
since they both are equal it will return
true
while in this case they both have the
same
type hence it will return true now
let us
next check this equals to equal so since
they both are one and in php it will
display as true since they are equal
while when you are type checking that is
you are checking if they're equal with
the same type and same value it will
display a false since one is an integer
and the other one is a string value
also if you check two different strings
with the type save it will also display
true
next question
how does exception handling work in php
so when an exception is thrown
code following the statement will not be
executed and php will attempt to find
the first matching catch block so if an
exception is not caught a php fatal
error will be issued with an uncaught
exception an exception can be thrown and
called within php
so what we do is we use this try and
catch
method to
try the code and if an error occurs we
can catch
if an exception occurs we can throw it
and the catch function will catch
the exception and if doesn't we do not
include the catch function it will
result in a fatal error
next up
differentiate between require and
include
now require if a required file is not
found it will throw a fatal error and
stop the code execution while in case of
include if an essential file is not
found it will produce a warning and
still execute the remaining scripts
so as you can see both of these include
and require i use in the exact same way
with different functions next up
explain different types of errors in php
now php consists of mainly three errors
notice
warning and a fatal error now notice is
a non-critical error which means that
something minor went wrong during
execution and
a lot of times you just don't pay
attention to it
a warning is a critical error now it is
given in condition where suppose an
include function
that we just discussed in the previous
question
then to retrieve a non-existent file so
suppose you use an include function and
the file does not exist it will display
a warning and final is a fatal error so
it is a critical error resulting in
termination of the code so as we discuss
in the try and catch part of the
question
if an exception is thrown and we do not
have a catch function for it it will
display a fatal error which will return
in termination of the code
next question
how to call a function by a reference
so ampersand sign is used to call a
function by reference now in case of
reference the actual value is modified
if the value passed inside the function
is also modified while in case of value
the
value of the original
value does not change
so this piece of code here
is
an example of how you can call a
function by reference here as you can
see this ampersand sign
will call this function by reference and
any changes made in the variables here
will affect the original ones next
question
create a singleton class in php so how
do we create a singleton class in ph
before that let's have a look at what is
a singleton class now a singleton class
in php is a class that can have only one
object and hence provides only a single
point of access so in generally
generally in class you can create as
many objects as you want and it will in
turn create different access points into
that block of code
so in a singleton class you can only
create a single object hence singleton
so this piece of code as you can notice
is used to create a singleton class
now in to create a singleton class
you need to have the constructor
function private
now here
as you can see a singleton class is
created using this private construct
and it then
checks
if there's only one instance created and
if it is
it functions properly and displays
initialize only once
next question
how to encrypt a password using php so
php
can be used for encryption techniques
now the password underscore hash
function creates a hash password from
the password string using hashing
algorithm so suppose
you create a password string and enter
your password as password at the right
one two three and you put it inside the
password has hash function
so what it will generate is we are
echoing this generated hash
so what it will generate is
this so this is the
this is random it changes every time you
generate the password since it is
encrypted and
same when you pass
this password to the database using
hashing algorithm even in the database
the password will not be visible so your
data is secure
next question
mention different sorting functions for
errors in php now let us understand this
question in the vs code so php consists
of different sorting functions which you
can use to sort and give an array
automatically so if you want to sort an
array in ascending order what you need
to do is use this sort function so it
will sort this array in ascending order
now if you want to sort it in descending
order
use our sort that is reverse sort
similarly suppose you want to
sort an array in terms of value in
ascending order so you need to use a
sort function that is this
so in terms of value what in terms of
value means is suppose in a given error
there are keys and values so it will
sort the array based on the values that
is this 22 27 and 37 so the array will
be the same since the values are already
sorted
now if you want to sort the array in
according to key that is this
you can use k sort that is key sort
function that is provided in php so in
case of key sort
what it does is it will sort the array
in key that is the first one would be d
that is duke second m mac and the third
r that is raw
now if you want to sort
this
array
in descending order in terms of value
you use instead of a sort you use a
reverse sort similarly if you want to
sort an array in terms of key
in descending
you use k instead of k sort k r sort
that is k reverse sort so these are the
different sorting functions that are
inbuilt into php moving on
what will be the output of the following
code
now
if this code is given
let me give you some time and try to
pause this video and think of what will
be the output of the following code
so the output of this code will be 21
comma 21 or 2 1 comma 2 1
how did it happen
but before that if you got it correct
congratulations but if you want to
understand it see
a is a variable that contains the value
1 while a b is a variable that is
getting the value of a variable through
reference
now we make changes in the b variable
with 2
followed by this variable again which is
calling the value of a by reference so
if we make changes here we also make
changes in the value of a now if we
display this since the value of a is
already changed by reference it will
display 2 1 that is the value here and
again since the value of b is already 2
1 it will again display 2 1.
moving on
what are construct function and destruct
function in php so a constructor or
construct function is automatically
invoked when a new object of a class is
created and then can be used to
initialize value in class so when you
create a object
an object for a class a constructor
function is automatically invoked
but this can also be so it does not
contain any value when it is invoked but
you can also use this construct function
to initialize some properties to give
some properties to the class
which will act as its default properties
if nothing or
no new properties are given to the class
next is a destruct now a distract is
automatically invoked when an object of
a class is destructed suppose you end
the part of the code of a class you want
you are destroying the object when
you're ending the piece of code a
destruct function is automatically
invoked to clean up the resources
next
is how can php and javascript interact
now php and javascript can not directly
interact with each other since php is a
server-side scripting language while
javascript is a client-side language
but there is a way that these two
wonderful languages can interact with
each other so we can swap variables
since php can produce javascript code to
be implemented by the browser so yes you
can produce javascript code from php
which can then be implemented by a
browser and then it is probable to pass
those precise variables back to php
via a url
next question is
explain type hinting in php
now in php type hinting is used to
specify the expected data type that is
array object interface etc for an
argument in a function declaration
now during a function call suppose if
arguments does not match the expected
data type the run time will display an
error and the probe that is a fatal
error and the program will then
terminate
now in this code here what we are doing
is we are type hinting
so this is this code is for string type
hinting
and this code is for integer type
hinting now if these
particular set of functions that have
already specified the type they are
expecting does not
receive the same type of variable inside
them
the
program will return in a fatal error and
it will terminate so
moving on to our final question of this
video
write a class so yes this is a an
assignment a kind of assignment for you
guys so what you need to do is you need
to write a class to solve the following
question which i am going to say so
implement a class named basketball we
all like basketball right so implement a
class name basketball with an attribute
named baskets so you have to create an
attribute name basket and initialize it
to 0 as the starting position
and then
create a method name score now when the
score method is invoked the baskets must
increase by 1. so let's see the solution
now so this is how you create a class
that is basketball
now
inside this class what we are going to
do is we are going to initialize the
number of baskets that is this variable
as 0 as the starting position so to do
that what we're going to do is we will
be using construct function as we
discussed to initialize some
default properties for the class so this
construct function is
used to initialize this basket's
variable to 0. now suppose we do not
call this function score which is
increasing the number of baskets the
default value will be displayed as 0
every time now suppose we invoke this
core function every time a basket is
code
this will increase the number of baskets
by one
so this is pretty simple and this is how
you create a simple class which will
perform
the following question sql is a very
important technology that is used in the
iit industry
professionals working as application
developers web developers data analysts
data scientists software testers and
cyber security experts need to know sql
in this video we will cover 30 important
sql questions that are most frequently
asked in the interviews
so before i begin make sure to subscribe
to the simply launch channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
now these questions consist of a set of
theoretical and practical questions
so we will use different commands
functions joints and other
functionalities in excel to solve the
problems so let's get started with the
first question
so the first question is to state the
difference between where and having
clause in sql
now wear and having are very widely used
in sql to solve specific problems
now let's look at the difference one by
one
so where clause is used to filter the
records from the table based on the
specified condition and can be used
without the group by clause on the other
hand
having clause is used to filter the
records from groups based on specified
conditions
now where clauses cannot have aggregate
functions so you cannot use some count
average min and maximum functions in the
where clause
while in the having clause you can
operate on aggregate functions
and those aggregate functions are used
to filter values from a group
now where clause is implemented on rows
or at row level
so for each row of data you have the
where condition applied
now having clauses are implemented on
columns so for each column of data you
have the having condition applied
now another important difference between
wear and having
is that the where clause is executed
before the execution of the group by
clause and after the execution of the
from clause
on the other hand the having clause is
executed after groups are created
now we will learn more about wear and
having and understand the usage better
when we tackle practical problems in
this video
now moving to our next question which is
how is drop different from truncate
so drop and truncate are two different
commands
so drop command is used to drop the
whole table removing the table
definition and its contents
while truncate deletes all the rows from
the table
we can drop the whole table structure in
one go so the view of the table does not
exist
by using the truncate command the
existence of all the rows in the table
is lost but the view in the table exists
now integrity constraints
will be removed in drop command while
the integrity constraints will not be
removed when you use the truncate
command
now moving to our third question now
this is a practical question so we will
be using a
table which is present in my mysql
database so the table name is called
employees and i want to find the lowest
salary of the employees in each
department
you can see here this is how my
employees table
looks
and
the output query would be something like
this
so here since i want to find the lowest
salary of the employees so i'm using a
min function to find the lowest salary
in the table
and then i'm grouping
all the employees and the results by
department so let's do this on mysql
workbench
okay so here i am on my mysql workbench
first let me go ahead and create a new
sql script so i will click on this
and that will create a new script
okay so here we'll write our commands
all right
so
our question was to
find the
lowest salary
for each department
okay so i have given my comment to make
my
commands
and whatever i am doing more readable
so
first before i proceed
i need to
select my database so i'm going to use
my sql underscore intro database
so i'll write use sql underscore intro
now this database has a lot of tables
that we'll be using in this
interview questions
video i'll run it
okay
we are in our sql intro database
now there is a table called
employees let me show you the table
first
if i write select star from employees
okay so here you can see this is the
table i'm talking about
now these are the
rows
that are present in the table we have 20
rows and here you can see the different
columns we have the employee id employee
name each gender
we have the department city and salary
now this is the same table that we have
also used
in our other videos that are already
live on youtube
okay
so
let's solve our question to find the
lowest salary for each department
now
for that
i'll write select
i'll select my department column which
is dept
comma
and then to calculate the lowest salary
or to find the lowest salary i'm going
to use the min function so that will
return the minimum salary
present in the salary column
so i'll write min salary as i'm giving
an alias name as let's say
lowest
underscore salary
from
my table name that is employees
then i'll write
group by department
now i'm grouping it by department
because we want to find the lowest
salary of the employees in each
department
now let's run and see the result
there you go
i'll just
move it to the top so that you can see
the results clearly
okay so here we have total seven
departments you can see at the bottom
and
in these seven departments you can see
in sales seventy thousand let's say
dollars was the lowest salary in
marketing we had fifty five thousand
dollars as the lowest salary similarly
if i scroll down we have other
departments like
tech i.t finance and hr so
these are the lowest salary
in each department
all right
now moving to our next question
so our fourth question is
which query will help you fetch unique
values from a column in a table
so this is a multiple choice question
which is another type of question that
is often asked in the sql interviews now
we have multiple queries here and you
need to choose the right query that will
solve our problem
so
since i want to
get the unique values from a column
in a table
so the right option
would be to use the distinct keyword in
the query so if i write select
distinct followed by the column name
let's say you want to find the distinct
cities or the distinct departments in
the employees table
so the query would be select distinct
city or let's say department from the
table name that is employees
hence this is the right option if you
want to find any unique values from a
column
now moving to the
fifth question
now the fifth question says
it is actually a similar question here
we want to write the sql query to fetch
unique departments from the employees
table
so as we saw this is our employees table
and if you want to find the unique
departments from the employees table you
can just write select
distinct then followed by the column
name which is departments here so dept
from employees
let's
do this
on our mysql workbench
okay so let me just scroll down
and i'll
give a comment here
that is we want to find the unique
departments
so the query would be
select
then i'll use the distinct keyword if i
hit tab it will auto complete
then i have my column that is department
from
my table name that is employees
if i run
this query will give us
the unique departments that are present
in the table so here we have total
seven unique departments in the table
you can see here we have sales marketing
product
tech id
finance and hr
but
if you see our original table which is
the employees table
so there are total
20 records
and if you see the department column
there are
multiple departments to which each of
these employees belong to
ok
now moving ahead
now the sixth question is to write an
sql query to fetch the
unique values of departments and print
their length
now
this question consists of two parts
first we need to fetch the unique values
of departments that we saw in our fifth
question
and then we want to print the length of
each of the departments so for that i'm
using the distinct keyboard to find the
unique departments and then i am using
the
inbuilt length function that is present
in mysql to find the length of the
department and then i am
using an alias that is length underscore
department from employees so let's
see this on
our workbench
okay so let me
give a comment
i'll say
unique
departments and
length
okay so the query would be
i'll write
select
distinct
department
and then let me just scroll down
i'll give a comma
and use my inbuilt length function see
i'm hitting tab to autocomplete
and inside the length function i'll give
my column name that is
department
i'll give an alias as
department underscore
length
from my table that is
employees this is pretty simple
so first i am finding the unique
departments and then using the length
function i am finding the
length of each department
let's run and see
okay you can see the result here so
sales the length is 5
marketing the length of marketing is
nine so basically you're counting the
number of characters that are present in
each of the departments so in sales
there are total five characters in
marketing there are total nine
characters in product there are total
seven characters in it we have just two
letters i and t so hence the
length is two similarly finance is
seven and hr is two because we have just
two letters h and r
okay so this is another variation of
using distinct along with
any inbuilt function
all right
now moving to the seventh question
the question is what is the use of
dative function in sql
now dative
returns the number of days between two
date or date time or time stamp values
so d diff is another
crucial
inbuilt function that is present in
mysql
so here is how you can use the datedif
function so it will return the number of
days between two dates or date time or
time stamp value so here i have
two date values that is
10th of
april 2021 and
i have
30th of
march 2021.
so this query will give us the
total number of days that lie between
these two dates and similarly
here is another example of using the
datedif function
so i want to calculate
the total number of days that are
present between today's date so i am
using the now function and
between
20th of april 2021
so let's do this demo on the workbench
all right
first i'll give a comment
saying
dd function
ok
now the way to use this
i'll write select
and then
you can see here once i type date
mysql workbench is automatically
suggesting some of the inbuilt functions
i'm going to use datif
and within date div i am going to pass
in
two values so i am passing in two date
values let's say 2021
april
so i'll write 0 4 and let's say
10th of april
i'll give another comma
and i'll pass in my second date value
that is going to be
30th of
march
2021
all right
now another thing to note here is
the
date value should be present inside
quotations
if you want you can given alias as well
i'll write as
total days
let's run it
there you go it has given us the output
as 10 so there are total 10 days between
31st of march
to
10th of april
now let's see another example
i'll write select
date diff
and we'll pass in
my now function so the now function
returns the
current date that is today's
date
and i'll give another date value let's
say
2021
april
20th
now we'll see the results
if you want you can give an alias name
so that the output is more readable here
i'll run it
okay
so between
today's date and
my previous date that was 20th of
april
there are total 49 days
so today's date is actually
8th of june so between
20th of april and 8th of june there are
total 49 days
all right
now moving ahead
now in the eighth question we want to
write an sql query to display the
departments that have
more than two employees
so
this is our employees table that we have
been using
and here is how the
command looks like so here
we are using both group by and having
now i am grouping by department because
i want to
display the departments that have more
than two employees
now for the second filter i am using the
count function of the employee ids
and checking if the employees
in each department are more than two or
not
let's do this
let me
move down a bit
and i'll give a comment
departments with
more than
two employees
okay
now let's write our query
so i want to select
the department
and then
i'm using the count function to count
the
employee ids in each
department or the employees present in
each department
from my table that is employees
i'm going to group by
department
and then i'll use having
my count of
employee id
this should be greater than 2
so
our query will return only those
departments which have more than 2
employees
let's run and see
there you go so we have
total four departments that is sales
product tech and i.t
where we have more than
two employees you can see here sales has
four employees product has three
tech has four
and it has three the rest of the
departments like finance hr and others
have less than two employees
now if you want you can give an alias as
well
let's say as
total employees
okay
let me run it again
and here you can see i have the
column name as total employees
okay
so moving ahead
the ninth question we want to display
the details of the employees
for all the departments except marketing
now
here i have my employees table now if i
were to display all the details of the
employees apart from
marketing department
i can give a condition like where
department
not equal to marketing so this is the
way how you write not equal to so you
use the less than and greater than
symbol
another way to do is use the exclamation
mark
and give equal to so this means
select all the employees where
department is not equal to marketing
now let's do this
i'll move down a bit
and we'll give a
comment as
details of employees apart from
marketing
so the query would be select
star from employees
i am using star because i want to
display all the details that means i
want to display all the columns
then i am going to use my where
condition where
department
not equal to
marketing
i'll put marketing under
quotes
let's run it and see the results
there you go
so we have
total
18 rows of information
and if you see the department column we
have
all the departments apart from marketing
now if you remember
our employees table had total 20 rows of
information out of which two are missing
which means
there were two employees who were from
marketing department and those
departments were
not displaying
now
another way to do is
to use
exclamation mark and equal to
so this also means
select all the employees where
department is not equal to marketing
let's run this you see here
it gives us the same result and has
returned us
18 rows of information
leaving apart
the employees from the marketing
department all right
now moving ahead
so our 10th question is to write an sql
query to print the details of the
employees who have joined before
april 2010 and after
may 2005
so here is my employees table
and
this is my sql query so here we are
using just a where condition to filter
our results
and
my condition is
the employee should have joined after
may 2005 so i have written
after
31st of
may 2005 and before april 2010 which is
before
31st of
march 2010
let's do this
i'll
give a comment here
we'll write
employees
joined
before
april
2010
[Music]
and
after
may 2005
now let's write our sql query so i'll
write select
star from
employees
where
my date of join if you see here i have a
column called date of join which has the
details about the day on which the
employee had joined
the company
so i'm going to write where date of join
is greater than
31st of
may
2005 so i'll write
2005
this is one of the formats to use
date values
so this is the year value this is the
month value and this is the d value
and
my date of join
should be
less than
31st of march 2010 so i'll write
2010
march 31st
i hope
you were able to understand this
date of join greater than 31st of may
2005 means
after may 2005 and date of join less
than
31st of march
2010 this means
employees joined before 2010 april
let's run it
okay so we have total three employees in
our table you can see the
date of join
and all of them have joined
after may 2005 and before april 2010
okay
now moving ahead to the 11th question
so here we want to find the employee
with the
third highest salary from the table
so i have my employees table here
and my command would look something like
this so here we are going to explore how
to write
sub queries in sql
so
i am using a sub query here where i am
trying to find
the
employees who have the
top three salaries or the top three
employees who have the highest salaries
and from that i'm going to filter out my
third highest salary employee so let's
do it on our workbench
okay
so i'll come down and let me give a
comment as
third highest salary
okay
so
let me first write down my sql query and
then i'll explain so i'll write select
star from
after that i'll start a bracket and
write my inner query so i'll write
select
star from
employees
order by salary
descending
then i'll use my limit keyword
and i'll write limit 3
as i'll give an alias name let's say t
and then
i am
again going to use
my order by
salary
limit
1.
okay
now let me explain you the flow
so first let me run the inner query i'll
select my inner query
and i'll run it
so the inner query returns
my top three employees who have the
highest salary and this is ordered in
descending order since i used salary
descending
now let me just
use this okay now you can see it clearly
so these are my top three employees who
have the highest salary so josef has the
maximum salary followed by
angela and then we have jack now from
this i want to return
only
the record for jack because jack is the
employee
who earns the third highest salary so
for that
i am going to
use the result written by my
sub query or the inner query and on top
of this
i'm going to order the salary and say
limit equal to 1 so i'm again
ordering this salary in ascending order
so what will happen
jack will appear at the top angela will
be at the second place and joseph will
come to the third place and from there
i'm using limit1 so that i can only get
the record for jack
now if i run the entire query you see
the result i have my
employee name is jack who earns the
third highest salary
okay
now moving ahead to the 12th question
the question is to print all the
alternate records in a table
so here is my employees table and from
this table i am going to print all the
alternate records for example i am going
to print the my employee id 101 then i
am going to skip 102 and print 103
followed by 1 0 5 1 0
7 1 0 9 so all the
employee ids that have an odd value
and you can look at this example in
another way of displaying the employees
which have an employee id
of even numbers so 102 104 106 and so on
now the way to do is
either you can use a simple select
clause and say employee id
percentage or modulus 2 equal to 0 which
means i want to filter only those
employees which have an even employee id
else
what you can do is you can use a cte as
you can see here so cte or the common
table expression is a temporary named
result set that you can reference within
a select insert update or delete
statement now it is used to simplify
complex joints and sub queries and to
provide a means to query hierarchical
data
now let's
write this query on our workbench and
see how it works
before that let me explain you i am
using a few
new functions such as row number this
will
create a row number for each of the rows
or the records present in my table
and then
from this cte i am going to use my
filter class or the where clause
where rn which is row number percentage
2 equal to equal to 1 so this will
return
only the odd records from the table
let's see how to do it
okay
so
i'll give a comment
print
alternate
records
okay
now i'll start with my
simple query which is select star from
employees
where
let's say i want to find only the even
employee ids
or the employees who have an even
employee id
so i can use employee id
percentage 2 equal to 0 so it has to be
a perfect division
and the result should be 0 only then i
can get only the
even employees if i run this okay there
was an error here it should be employees
i'll run it again
you can see here i have printed the
alternate records in a table so we have
skipped one zero one because it is not
divisible by two
i've started with one zero two followed
by one zero four one zero six one zero
eight
and then finally we have
one two zero or hundred and twenty
now if you want
to print only the
odd records in the table you can use
employee id percentage to equal to one
so you can see here i have one zero one
one zero three one zero five one zero
seven up to
one one nine
now the
best way to do this is
to use a common table expression or cte
so i'll start with
my command that is with cte
as
i'll
start with my bracket i'll write select
star
comma
then i'm going to use my row number
function
so i'll write
row number
then
i'll write over
then i'll use order by
employee id
so this
row number for each of the rows is going
to be created over my employee id column
and that is sorted in
ascending order i will give an alias as
rn which stands for row number
from
my table that is
employees
i'll scroll down
and then i'm going to
close my bracket
i'll write select
let me remove the space here
okay i'll let select star from
cte
where
my
row number
percentage
2 equal to
1.
now
let's
see this from the top
so i have my commentable expression
where
i am
going to create a
row number column named as rn
and this row number column is based on
my employee id column which is sorted in
ascending order
and from that
i am going to filter only those row
number values that are not divisible by
2 or i am going to print only the
odd records from the table so lets run
it and see the results there you go so
here if you mark i have my row number
column created
and i am filtering only the odd records
in the table so it starts with 1 3 5 7
and goes up to 19
and similarly here you can see the
employee ids the name the age gender and
other information
now if you were to print
the even records in the table
the alternate even records you can use
rn percentage 2 equal to 0. let's see
the difference
i'll run this
there you go
so i have my even row numbers starting
from 2 which goes up to
20
okay so this is how you can print
alternate records in a table
now moving to the next question
now in the 13th question we want to
write an sql query to fetch
all the duplicate rows in a table now
this is another crucial interview
question that is often asked in most of
the interviews
now i have a table which is named as
duplicate table and here you can see i
have some employee id name and each and
a few records are duplicated for example
101 sam
40 the first record is duplicated and
you can see here
it has the same
values
now if you mark
103
mary and 28 is not duplicated because
here the age is different so this is a
different person
than
compared to the third
name that we have
so this is how you can find
the duplicate rules in a table so i'm
going to select my employee id name and
age and then count
all the
employee ids the names and each and
compare them with whether they are
greater than one or not so if they are
greater than one
then
i'll say that particular record is
duplicated or is present more than one
time in the table
let's
do this implementation on our workbench
okay
so i'll come down
and let me give my comment as
duplicate records
okay
so
let me first
show you the records that are present in
my table so i'll write select
star from
dup underscore
employees
i'll run it
okay you can see here i have my table
that we saw in the slides
so
employee id 101 with name sam and age
40 is duplicated
so we want to find this duplicate record
the way to do is
i'll write
select
e underscore id which is employee id
comma name comma age
comma i'm going to count all of them
so i'll write count star
as
duplicate
count this is my alias name
from
my table that is dup underscore
employees
i'll say
group by
employee id
name
and age
and then i'm going to use my having
clause saying having
count of
employee id
is greater than 1
and
count of
name should also be greater than 1
and
my count of age
should also be
greater than 1
let's run it and see the results
okay there is some error here
the name of the table should be
employees
okay
let's run again
we have
our correct result
that is employee 101 with name sam
and h40 is duplicated so the value is 2.
great
now
moving ahead
now the 14th question is a bit tricky
wherein we want to display the employees
with exactly
two
a's in their name
so you see here i have my
employee names and
there are certain employees who have
just two e's in their names so i want to
find those employees
only
now the way to do is
it is a bit tricky to understand i am
going to break it down and make you
understand
on my mysql workbench
so here you can just have a glance i
write select star from employees where
i am finding the length of my employee
name and then subtracting
my length
wherein i have
replaced my employee name that has a
with a
blank
and if this subtraction is equal to 2
then
that particular employee has two e's in
their names
so let me show this first
let me
first give my comment as
employees
with
two ease okay
so
first
i'm going to write a select statement
okay before that i'll show you
the records present in my table
okay
if you see here
shane is one of the employees that has
just one e in its name then we have mary
one a
duin has one a but if you see sarah
sarah has 2a
in the name so we want to extract sara
then
jack has one a again if you see angela
angela has 2a it doesn't matter if it is
uppercase a or lowercase a we just need
to find
if the employees have two e's in the
name
and similarly if i scroll down let me
check if we have
any other employee with two a's in their
name marcus has one david has one sophia
has one
we also have emilia that has two a's
in its name or in her name
and we also have maya
okay
now
let me go ahead and write a sql query
and then i'll explain you what i'm
trying to do
i'll write select
i'm using the length function
and
in the length function
i'm going to replace
then i'll use another function called
upper
on top of employee name
i'll write
a and then replace it with a blank so i
am using quotations to represent blank
from
employees
okay
let's run this and see the results
you see here
it has given us
the length
of the employee strings after
replacing all the a's with a blank
so here i'm essentially
converting my employee names to
uppercase
and i'm changing wherever there is an a
i'm replacing
that a with a blank
and then i'm finding the length
so this trick i'm going to use
in my
final query so i'll write select star
from
employees
where
what i'm going to do is
i'll bring this to the next line i'll
write
length of
employee name
minus
then i'm going to use my above
condition
i'll
copy this
i'll paste it here
and this value should be
2.
so what i am doing is i am first
finding out the length of my employee
name
from that
i am subtracting
the length after replacing the e is
present in the employee name with a
blank and this value should be equal to
2. the reason being we are only trying
to find the employees who have
two a's in their name
let's run and see the results
okay if you see here
we have sarah angela
emilia and maya who have
two a's in their name so we have
sarah
that has 2a angela has 2a amelia has two
a's and then maya also has 2a
okay
now moving ahead
now the 15th question is given a string
how will you extract four characters
starting from the
second position
so i have my string here
which says michael ballack now michael
ballack you must be aware he is a
popular footballer he is from germany
and also was the captain of germany
so from the string michael ballack i am
going to extract four characters
starting from the second position
you can use two inbuilt mysql functions
to
do this the first is called
sub str wherein we pass in the string
then we
give the position from where we want to
extract the characters so here i am
going to extract from the second
position so hence 2
and then the number of characters that
you want to extract which is 4. the
other way is to use the substring
function
which is again similar to the sub str
function
in the substring function also i am
first passing in my input string and
then giving my
starting position which is two and then
i want to extract 4 characters from it
let's do it
i'll give a comment
extract
strings
so here i'm going to write select
first i'm going to use sub str
which is my inbuilt function
i'm going to pass in my input string
which says
michael
ballack
and then
i'll give my starting position which is
2 and then the number of characters that
is 4.
let's run it and see the results
you can see here it has given us
i cha
so if you see m is at the first position
from the second position onwards i
needed four characters so m c h and e
these are the four characters starting
from the second position
similarly let me just copy this
and instead of
sub str i am going to use the sub string
function i will write just
ing that becomes substring
let's
select and run it
and this also returns the same result
suppose you wanted to extract
from the fourth position
you wanted to extract let's say three
characters
let's see the results
it gives us h a and e if you see here
m is the first physician i is at the
second position c is at the third
position
h starts from the fourth position
so h a and e are the next three
characters starting from the fourth
position
so hence this is the result
all right now moving ahead
now my sixteenth question is on
how does self join
work
so self join joins a table to itself so
the table must contain a column x that
acts as the primary key
and a different column let's say y that
stores values that can be matched up
with the values in column x now
this might not be really easy to
understand you'll get to know once we do
this demo so i have a table
which is called employee manager so this
is my table
now let me tell you how to interpret
this table we have five different
employees starting from employee id one
to employer d5
gary gibbs smith litham and
jimmy are the different employees we
have you have their salaries and now you
have
the employees reporting to which
manager
now if you see here
gary's manager
id is 3
so if you see a table at 3 we have smith
so gary is reporting to 3
or in other words
smith has a employee under him who is
gary similarly
gibbs is reporting to manager id 1 or
employee 1 which is gary so
gibbs manager is gary similarly if you
see for smith smith is reporting to the
person with manager id 4 or employee 4
we have latham so litham has one
employee under him who is smith
now latham in our table has no managers
then we have jimmy who's reporting to
the employee id3 who is smith
okay
now i want to
use this table and return the name of
the manager for each employee
to do that i am going to use my self
join so here i am using
a self join to join both the
tables here both the tables mean i am
using
the same table twice so i have written
select e dot employee id e dot employee
name then we have e dot manager id
then i am using another alias for
managers so m dot employee name as
manager underscore name from
employee underscore manager as e
this join means self join employee
underscore manager sm on
e dot manager id equal to e dot employee
id so this is my common column that is
employee id and manager id let's do it
all right
i'll give a comment here
saying self join
and i'll start with myself join i'll
write
select
let me first display my table i'll write
select star from
and my table name is
emp underscore manager
i'll run it
you can see the table here this is the
same table that we saw
in the slides
now i'll write my
join query i'll write select e dot
employee id
comma
e
dot
employee name
comma
e dot
manager id
comma then i am using another alias as m
for
finding the
manager name so m dot employee name as
manager name
there shouldn't be any space in the
alias name
then i'll write from
emp underscore
manager as e
join
emp underscore
manager as
m
on
e dot
manager
underscore
id equal to
m dot
emp underscore id
let me run this and we'll see the
results
there you go
so gary
reports to
the manager id3 so from the table three
is for smith so gary's manager is smith
gibbs manager is gary
smith's manager is litham and jimmy's
manager is smith
okay so this is how you can use self
join
now moving ahead with our
next question
so the 17th question
is on which of the following is called a
virtual table in sql so again we have a
multiple choice question
so the answer is
view you can see here
so view is a virtual table that has rows
and columns as they are in a real table
in the database now we can create a view
by selecting fields from one or more
tables present in the database
next moving to the 18th question
so here we want to write an sql query to
fetch the list of employees with the
same salary
again i am going to
use a self's join here wherein i'll join
the same employees table
and this is how my
query would look like so i'm
selecting distinct employee id so e dot
employee id e dot employee name e dot
salary from employees
then i'm joining
as e on employees e1 where e dot salary
equal to e1 dot salary because i want to
fetch
the list of employees with the same
salary and i'm ensuring that
the employee ids from both the tables
are different
let's do it
i'll give a
comment here and write
employees
with
same
salary
and i'll start with my
query i'll write
select
extinct
e dot
employee id
comma
i'll write e dot
employee name
comma e dot salary
from
employees
as e
then
employs as
e1
where
e dot salary equal to
e1 dot
salary
and
e dot
employee id is not equal to
e1 dot
employee id
i'll give a semicolon and let's print
the results
you see here we have
emilia
bayla
sheen and sarah who have the
same salaries so amelia and shane have
the same salary of fifty five thousand
dollars bill and sarah have the same
salary of seventy two thousand dollars
okay
now moving to the 19th question
so the question is to write an sql query
to print one row twice
in results from a table
so i have a table here called employees
and i want to print
one row twice in the results
so to solve such kind of problems
you need to use the union all operator
in sql
so union all combines the result sets of
two or more select statements
it does not remove duplicate rows
between the various select statements
all the rows are returned
so let's say i want to print the
employee name and department for those
employees who are from the hr department
now to do this we can use the union all
operator you can see it here so i am
selecting my employee name the
department from my table employs as e
then i am giving my where clause where e
dot department equal to hr
and then i'm using the union all
operator
then i'm again selecting my employee
name department from employees with
another alias as e1 where e1.department
equal to
hr so let's do this
okay
so i'll give my comment as
print
row
twice
okay
now
i'll start with my query i'll write
select
my employee name
comma the department
from
my table that is employees as e
then i'll use where
e dot department equal to
hr
then i'm going to use the union all
operator
so the union all will combine the result
set of two or more select statements
then i am going to write select
emp underscore name
comma
my department
from
employees
as
e1
where
ebon dot
department equal to
hr
i'll give a semicolon now let's run it
there you go you can see here marcus and
sophia are from the hr department and we
have printed them twice in our results
coming to the next question
the question is
using the num table
a query to add 10 when number is 0
20 the number is 1
else
print the number itself
so you can see here i have my table
called num and it has just one column
which is
num id or number id
we have some
numbers here
and
from these numbers i want to add 10 if
the number is 0 20 if the number is 1
else i would print the number itself
so
to answer this question we'll use the
case statement in sql
so the case statement is sql's way of
handling if then logic the case
statement is followed by at least one
pair of when and then statements
so here you can see i have my case
statement i'm writing one case
my column name and underscore id equal
to zero then add plus 10
if it is 1 then add plus 20
else
we'll just return the number id
now let's do this
okay
i'll give a
comment saying using
case statements
okay first of all
let me
display the values present
in my num table you can see here this is
my table and there are total 12 rows
of numbers
now let's start with our
query i'll write
select
n underscore id
comma
then i'm going to write my case
statement so i'll use the keyword as
case when
n underscore id equal to 0
i'll use then
n underscore id
plus 10
i'll write when
and underscore id equal to 1
then
n underscore id
plus 20
else
i'll just print an id
now i'll end my key statement i'll write
end as
an alias name let's say num underscore
add
from my table that is
num
let's run and see the results
okay you can see here
my first
number was 0 so since it was 0 we have
added
num id or n id plus 10 so the result is
10
now
wherever
the num id is 1 for example here we have
added 20 so the
result or the output becomes 21.
similarly here the value was 0 so we
have added 10 the output is 10
and you see here again here we had
another one so we added 1 to
20 so the result becomes 21
and for the rest of the numbers for
example 3
we had 2
the values are the same
ok
now moving ahead
so we have
a table called num1
and using this table we want to write a
query to find the sum of all positive
values and the negative values
so let's see the table first so this is
my table which is num1 you can see here
we have a list of integers
and there are positive as well as
negative integers so for positive values
and the negative values we want to find
the sum separately
so again for this we are using the
case statement you can see here i have
used two key statements
i'm writing select
and then i'm using the case to find if
the number is greater than 0 which means
it's a positive number so i'm finding
out the sum and then i'm checking
case when
the integer is less than 0 so it's a
negative number and i'm finding the sum
for the negative numbers as well
let's do this
okay
so
i'll give my comment
as
add
positive and
negative numbers
okay so let's start with our select
query
i'll write select
i'll use the sum function and inside the
sum function
i'll use my case statement so i'll write
case when
num
underscore
integer
okay before that let me just print the
values present in my
table so i'll write select star from
my table name that is num1
okay
so you can see here these are the values
or the list of integers that we have
there are some positive as well as
negative integers
okay let's continue with our query
so here i'm going to write case when
num underscore integer or int which is
my column name
if it is greater than 0
then
i'll return nom underscore
int
else i'll say 0
and end my case statement
i'll give an alias as sum of let's say
positive numbers
give a comma
then i'll use another sum function
and inside the sum function we'll use
the case statement to find
the sum of
negative numbers or integers
so i'll write num under current if it is
less than 0
then
num underscore end
else
0
and i'll end
okay
and i'll give another alias name as
let's say sum underscore any g which
stands for negative
pos is for positive integers
and then i'll write from my table that
is num1
let's
run it
okay there you go we have our results so
we have two columns
sum of positive integers and sum of
negative integers you can see the
results 19 and minus 14 respectively
okay now moving ahead
now in question number 22 we want to
list the difference between
primary key and foreign key
so as you can see here
primary key is something that can
uniquely identify a record in a table
so if you consider a school database a
primary key would ideally be
the
role number or the registration number
of the student
because that is unique to all the
students in a school
now
foreign key is the field in the table
that is
primary key to another table
so suppose you have another table called
courses to which the
students have enrolled 2.
now
if you have a roll number or
registration number column in the
course table that becomes the
foreign key
now the other difference is primary key
don't accept or cannot accept null
values
while foreign key can accept null values
you can have only one primary key in a
table but you can have more than
one foreign key in a table
now coming to the 23rd question
what is the difference between primary
key and union
so you can have only one primary key in
a table as we discussed in the previous
question
but you can have more than one unique
key in a table a primary key column
cannot have null values
but
union can accept null values
now
if you assign a column as a primary key
you create a clustered index
and similarly if you assign a column
with union
you create non-cluster index
okay
now coming to the 24th question
what is a check constant in sql
so check constraints are used while
creating tables
check constraint
helps to limit or restrict the values
that can be inserted into a column
for example
we have a
table here let's say dummy1
and
you want to ensure
that every time you insert the
age of
people or persons in the table you want
to make sure that age should be always
greater than zero reason being a person
cannot have or an animal cannot have or
a tree cannot have a negative each
similarly you can set a constant for the
salary column in a table to ensure that
it is always greater than zero because
you cannot earn a negative salary or it
cannot be less than zero
now we are going to create a dummy table
on my mysql workbench and see how
check constraints can be applied
okay
so let's give our comment as
check constraints
all right
so i'm going to create
a table
called
dummy
let's say underscore
sql
now this table
will have
a few columns first we have let's say
eid which stands for employee id
the data type is integer and
i'm going to assign employee id as my
primary key so i'll write
primary key here
okay
i'll give a comma
next we'll have a
city column
city column is of type var care or
varying character
i'll give the size as 30
and here
i'm going to apply my check constraint
to this
city column
i'm going to check
the city
should
take only
values as mumbai
let's see
i'll have my final column that is each
ages of type integer and here i'm going
to check my age should always be
greater than zero so i'll write check
age
greater than zero
okay
so our dummy sql table has
one primary key constraint and we have
applied two check constraints on city
and each column
let's run this
okay so we have created our table
successfully you can see it here
now
let's insert a few records and we can
see the difference
i'll write insert into
dummy
underscore sql
i'll write
values
i'll have my employee ids 101
i am giving my
city as mumbai
which is what we want
and let's see
i'll give my age as
10.
now this should perfectly bore because
my city is mumbai and my age is greater
than zero
so
i should be able to insert this record
successfully you can see here
i have inserted
this record to the table
i'll write select star from dummy sql so
that you can check
let's run it
there is some mistake i should write
from
okay
let's run it
you can see it here we have one record
or one row returned
now let's see we'll insert another
record
and this time i'm going to give my
employee id as 102 because it has to be
unique
and this time instead of mumbai i'm
going to give my city as let's say delhi
so i'm not following my check constant
where i am supposed to give only mumbai
i am purposely giving
delhi here to see the difference if i
run this
let's see we'll have
ages 40 which is greater than
0
let's run it
you see here we get an error saying
check constraint dummy underscore sql
underscore
check
is violated
similarly
let's see i'll change this to mumbai
again
and instead of 40 let's say i'll give us
minus 30
so your each can never be in negative
numbers
if i run this i get the same error my
check constraint has been violated
because each
should be greater than
zero
okay so this is how you can use check
constraints in sql
now coming to the 25th question
so given two tables a and b
we want to write a query to fetch values
in table b
that are not present in table a
now to answer this question
you can use the left join
so what left join does is
it returns all the rows from the left
table and only matching rows from the
right table
and i've used my
condition as a dot id which is in the
right table should be null
let's write this query on the
workbench
okay
so i'll give my comment
using
left join
first of all let me display my
tables i'll write select star from
e
where on this i have the
ids there are total five ids in table a
similarly
i'll copy this and
we'll see the values that are present in
table b
again i have five values there are a few
non-matching values as well so i want to
return those non-matching values that
are not present in table a
so for that
i'll write select
id
from
table b
i'll use left join
a
using my id column
this is another way to give the
condition
or you can use the on operator
then i'll give
bear
a dot id
is
null
let's run and see the results
there you go so 150 275
are not present in table a but are
present in table b
okay
now moving ahead
so now we look at the last set of five
questions
so these questions are based on the
popular northwind sample database
provided by microsoft now there are
several tables in this database so we
have an order table customers employee
products a region table and others
will use our microsoft sql server to
solve the five questions
so my next question which is based on
microsoft sql server
the question is using the
northwind
database find the customers who don't
have any orders
okay so i am on my microsoft sql server
management studio so this is how the
interface looks like
and here you can see i have a list of
databases now to solve the last five
questions i'm going to use the northwind
database if i expand this
i'll click on the plus sign you can see
there are a lot of tables that are
already present in the
database you can see here we have
customers employees employee territories
order details orders products region
shippers suppliers territories and more
ok
let me just collapse this
all right
so
to write my queries i am going to create
a
new query file
and here you see i am currently on my
master database i am going to change
this to
northwind database so that we can
utilize all the tables that are present
so my 26th question was to find the
customers who don't have any orders
so for that
i am going to use two tables
customers and orders
so
let me first give a comment
saying
customers
with
no orders
and now
let's go ahead and display the columns
that we have and see the
records present in the tables
customers and orders so first time
checking all the
columns and the rows present in the
customers table i'll
execute using this button or you can hit
f5 as well
okay you can see here there are total
91 customers these are all unique
customers you have total 91 unique
customer ids
you see here the company name of the
customer
you have the contact name the contact
title address city to which the
customers belong to
then the region postal code country
phone fax number
okay
now let me just copy this query
and
now we'll check for the orders table
i'll write select star from
orders
and let's execute it or run it
okay so there are
total
830 rows of information so there were
total 830 orders
or order ids we have the customer id now
this customer id is actually the
foreign key
for the orders table
but for the customers table customer id
is the primary key and in the orders
table order id is the primary key we
also have the employee id again this
employee id is the foreign key for this
orders table
we have the order date
we have the required date ship date
ship wire which means
by which medium the order was shipped we
have the free charges ship name and
sip address as well
then you have the
city from which the item was shipped the
region postal code and the country
okay
now
let me use the distinct keyword i'll
write select
dextent
i want to find the distinct
customer ids
from
my customers table
let's run and see how many
unique customer ids we have so there are
total 91 customer ids or customers
now let's check for the orders table
let's run it and see the difference now
if you see here there are total
89
customer ids in the orders table which
means
there are two customers missing from the
orders table
and that implies those two customers
don't have any orders
so to
get the result i will use two different
queries
to derive at the same
output
so i am going to select
my customer id
from
my table that is
customers
i am going to use
where
my customer id
and then i'm going to use the not in
operator
i'm going to use a sub query
select
customer id
from
my orders table
close the bracket and i'll give a
semicolon
now what this query essentially does is
it is first going to find all the
customer ids that are present in my
orders table
and
in the outer query we are only going to
return
the customers that are present in
both the tables
and
we are going to
exclude those customers which are not
present in the
orders table
so let's run and see the results we
should get two customer ids there you go
so these are the two customer ids which
are
present in the
customers table and are not present in
the orders table meaning that they don't
have any
orders in their name
now there is another way to do it
that is to use the not exist operator
wherein you can write another sub query
to get this same result we will leave
that to you you can try this out using
the not exist operator as well
coming to the 27th question
using the orders table in the northwind
database we want to find all the
month and orders
so such problems you will face while
dealing with sales data so very often
sales executives would try hard to meet
their month end targets we want to
display all the orders made on the last
day of the month
so let's solve this question on our
microsoft sql server
ok so let me first give my comment for
the 27th question
so the question is to
find all the month end orders so i'll
just write
month and orders
okay now to get the month end orders we
are going to use a
built-in
eo month function which stands for end
of month
so let's start with the query
i'll write select
we are going to select the
employee
id
comma
i also want the order id
and
we want the order date
from
my table that is
orders
i'll
then give my where clause i'll write
where
my
order date
equal to
and i'll use my
inbuilt function that is end of month
i
have hit tab to autocomplete
and inside this function i'll pass in my
order date column
then i'm going to
use the order by clause i'm going to
order it by
employee id and the order id
i'll just move down and hit tab
okay
let's
run the query there you go
we have got 26 rows of information
you see on the left side we have the
employee ids the order ids and then we
have the order date column now if you
mark the values present in the order
date column these are all
the
end of month date values you see this is
28th of feb
then we have
31st of july we have 30th of june
so on and so
forth so these are the list of all the
orders that were placed
on the last day of the month
coming to the 28th question
we want to find the top five countries
with the highest freight charges in the
year 1997.
so freight charge is the amount paid to
a carrier company for the transportation
of goods from origin to another location
the freight charge is calculated based
on the mode of transportation and the
distance between the pickup place or the
pickup location and the destination
so let's try this out on the
microsoft server management studio
okay so let me go ahead and
give my
comment
so since we want to find the top five
countries with the highest freight
charges
i'll just give my comment as
highest
free charges
okay
now
to solve this question
i'll just change this to
ghd okay
we are going to use
our
orders table
so the way to do is i'll write select
i'm going to use the
top
five so top is another
keyword or
an operator
so i'm going to find out the
ship country
and then
i'll calculate the average freight
prices so i'm going to use the average
inbuilt function
on top of my
column that is
freight
i'll give an alias as
let's
say average
fret
there should be no space i'll give a
underscore
i'll write from my table that is
orders
i'll use my where clause where
and then i am going to find the year
from my order
date column and this year should be
1997.
i'm going to
group it by
my ship country
and
i'll use
order by
my alias name that was average freight
and in descending order i'm going to
sort it
let's see the top five
shipping countries who have the highest
free charges
these are the results you have austria
switzerland sweden canada and ireland
and here you can see the average freight
prices
sorted in descending order
okay
now moving ahead to the
29th question so here we want to display
the total number of products in each
category so we have two different tables
products and categories so both these
tables we are going to use
to find a solution to this problem that
is to display the total number of
products in each category
so first let me give my comment to
display the total number of products in
each category i'll just write print
total products
okay
so
to solve this problem we are going to
use our two tables
so let me first display the rows and
columns from both the tables the first
table is products
okay it is products
let's run this and see the columns that
we have in this table
okay so you have the product id which is
the primary key you have the product
name so there are total
77 different products okay
and then you have the supplier id you
have the category id so these two
columns are the foreign key columns you
have the quantity per unit unit price
units in stock
units in order
and if you want to
reorder
some product to fill in the stocks so
you have information for that as well
and if the product has been discontinued
or not
i'll copy this and let's see what
rows and columns we have
in my categories table
okay
let me execute this
okay
so we have total eight categories of
products you can see beverages we have
dairy products
meat or poultry you have produce seafood
these are the description
[Music]
okay
now to find the total number of products
in each category
i'll write my query as
select
i'll write
category
name
comma
count
star
i'll give this an alias name as total
products
give an underscore and write products
from
my first table that is
products
given alias as p
i'm going to use an inner join
with
my categories table
and i'll give my alias as c
on my common key column that is p dot
category id
is equal to c dot
category id
then
i'm going to
group my results
based on the category names
so i'll write category
name
and we'll use the
order by clause i'll write order by
count star
as
descending
so let's see the total number of
products that we have in each category
so they shouldn't be as descending
should be just count star descending
okay
i'll select and run it
there you go
so here on the left hand side you have
the different category names and
on the right you have the
total number of
products that belong to
each of the categories
all right
now moving on to the final question
so the last question is to use the
northwind database
and using this database we want to find
the list of late orders for all the
employees
so this is a real world problem that
often occurs
so the shipment of your orders might get
delayed due to logistic issues or if the
products are not available on time there
can be various other reasons as well so
here we want to find those orders for
the employees
or where the required date is less than
the shipment date
we are going to use two different tables
that is
orders and employees
okay now let me give my comment for the
final
query that we are going to write in this
interview questions tutorial
so using the orders table i want to find
the list of orders for all the employees
so i'll just give list
of late orders
not just orders for employees i write
emp
s which stands for employees
so here i am going to use two tables
orders and employees
orders table we have already seen let's
see the rows and columns that are
present in the employees table
i'll write select star from employees
and let me run it
okay so there are total nine employees
we have
so we have the employee id this is the
primary key column which goes from one
to nine we have the last name of the
employee the first name of the employee
we have the title
then we have the
title of courtesy by the doctor
mr missus
we have the birthday of the employee the
higher date or the date of join
you have the address city region postal
code and other information
all right
so let's
see how you can join the orders table
and the employees table to get the
list of late orders and we must remember
that late orders are those where the
required date is less than equal to the
shipped date
so i'll start with select
e dot
i'll write employee id
comma
i want the
first name
comma
i'm going to count
star as
late orders
from
my table orders as o
then i'll use my inner join
i'll write employees
as
e
it doesn't matter actually if you use
small e or capital e
then i'm going to use my on condition on
e dot
on
e dot
employee id
equal to
o dot employee id
so this is my common key column that is
present in both the tables then i'll use
my where clause where
you should be careful
and you should keep the right
clause
so my required date
should be less than or equal to my
shift date
so this is my condition
and then i'm going to group by
e dot employee id
comma
e dot
first name
and then i'll use my order by clause
order by
my alias name that was late orders
and i'll arrange it in descending order
so let's run this and see our result
okay
so
you have the employee ids on the left
then you have the first name of the
employee ids and then you have the late
orders for each of these employees so if
you see here
employee id 4 has the highest number of
late orders followed by employee id
three and eight
as well as nine who have five late
orders then we have the employee id two
which has
four late orders even employee id seven
has four lead orders employee id 5 that
is steven has only one late orders
so we are done with our
demo section and we have covered all our
30 questions
out of which 25 questions were based and
used
on mysql server
and to address the last five questions
we used our northwind database that had
a lot of tables you can see it here and
using those tables we solved some
interesting questions
welcome everyone to this topic in which
we are going to talk about that what
exactly is the different maven interview
questions here now in this one we are
going to talk about what are the
different questions some couple of
questions we are going to go through and
we will try to understand that what
exactly the answers are
now uh let's talk about the first
question over here so what exactly is in
maven here so maven is nothing but a
kind of a popular open tool uh open
source build tool which is available
there now before uh maven there were a
couple of build tools which was present
like and and you know a lot of other
legacy tools was present there but
after that maven is something which was
uh released as an open source tool and
it really helps the organization to uh
automate some couple of build processes
and you know have some particular
mechanisms like build publish and deploy
of different different projects at once
itself so it's a very powerful tool
which can really help us to do the build
automations we can integrate them with
the other tools like jenkins and you
know we can automate them we can
schedule the builds so a lot of various
advantages we can get with the help of
this tool here it's primarily written in
java and uh it can be used to build up
various other kind of projects also like
c sharp scalar ruby etc so all these
other typical tools can also be built up
with the help of this tool so this tool
is primarily uh used to do the uh
particular development and management of
the artifacts in the java based projects
so uh for most of the java based
projects nowadays this is the default
tool and it's already integrated with
the eclipse also so when you go for a
new project automatically uh it will be
created for a java project you can use
it for other languages also but yes
default choice of java of of the java
programming language is maven build tool
only
now let's talk about the next question
so what does the maven help with so may
when apache maven helps to manage all
the processes such as build process
documentation
release process distribution deployment
preparing the artifact so all these
tasks is being primarily taken care by
the apache mi1 so this tool simplifies
the process of project building it also
increases the performance of the project
and the overall building process so all
these things are something which is
being taken care by the specific maven
tool here so it also uses the particular
uh you know it downloads the jar files
of the different dependencies for
example if your source code is dependent
on some of the apache web service
jar files or some of the other
third-party jar files in that case you
don't have to download those jar files
and keep in some repository or keep it
in some lib directory you just have to
mention that dependency in the maven and
that jar file will be downloaded during
the build process and will be cached
locally so that's a biggest advantage
which we get with maven that you don't
have to take care of all these
dependencies anywhere into your source
code system so maven provides easy
access to all the required information
it uh helps the developer to build the
projects and uh without you know even
worrying about the dependencies
processes or different environments or
different because it's in a kind of a
tool which can be used in any platform
linux or windows so they don't have to
do any kind of conversions so all they
have to do is that they have to just add
new dependencies and that should be
updated into the form file and depending
on that dependencies the source code
will be built up and they don't have to
refer any kind of third party jar files
so they don't have to play with the
class bars during the build process so
no customizations is actually required
with this one now the next question is
that what are the different elements
that may one take cares of so there are
different kind of elements which is
being taken care by maven so uh
the these particular parameters are
elements are bills
dependencies
reports distribution releases and
mailing list so these are the typical
different different uh elements which is
being taken care by the maven during the
build process and during the preparation
of the builds here so all these things
you can uh they can explore they can
extract on that part and they can fully
understand that how they can work on all
these different different processes now
next question is that what is the
difference primary difference between
the and and maven first of all both of
them are primarily used for the
javascript so and is the older version
and maven is something which was
launched after the ant here so and has
no formal conventions like so which can
be uh you know coded into the build.xml
file there but yes the maven has
convention so information is not
required as such in the palm.xml file
there so ant is procedural whereas maven
is declarative over here so and does not
have any kind of life cycle so it
depends on you that how you program the
and there but
maven is having a lot of life cycles
there which we can configure we can
utilize so the uh and related scripts
are not reusable because you cannot
reuse it and you have to do some kind of
customizations in order to work on that
but yes maven is not having much of the
project related any kind of dependencies
they can be easily reusable there
because there is nothing about the
palm.xml file it's just the artifact
name and the dependencies which is uh
something we can override or we can
change and then the same palm.xml file
we can reuse as such for the new project
also so that is where the reusability
comes into the picture now and is a very
specific build tool so we don't have to
there is no plugins as such which is
available there you just have to code
everything that what build process you
want to prepare
whereas in case of maven we have the
concept of plugins which can really help
us to understand that how we can make or
use of these plugins so that we can have
the reusability implemented so these are
some of the differences which is
available there between the ant and
maven here now next thing is that what
exactly isn't palm file all about so
palm file is nothing but it's kind of a
xml file which is available there and
it's have having all the information
regarding the project and the
configuration details so it primarily
used over here that how the
configuration needs to be done and how
the setup should be performed as such
here so palm.xml file is the build
script which we prepare uh you can
prepare it uh using a particular
component or you can have a particular
mechanism or if you feel that you want
to have some kind of setup so all these
things typically can be implemented can
be done with the help of build tools so
build tools can be really helpful for us
to do the automations and it can really
help us to understand that how some
build processes we can automate with
simply with the help of palm.xml file
here so the developers usually put up
everything inside these uh dependencies
in the pom.xml file here so this is the
file which is uh usually present in the
home directory it's in the current
directory so that once the build is
triggered it will be picked up from that
directory and according to the steps
according to the content of the palm.xml
file the build will be processed or will
be created here now what i'll include
into the palm file here so the different
components which is included into the
palm dot xml file here is the
dependencies
uh developers and contributors plugins
plugin configuration and resources so
these are the typical components which
is a part of a permanent xml file which
can be uh same form a lot of projects
you can do some customization and then
the same pom file can be reused for the
other projects also now what are the
minimum requirement of the elements
which is there for a palm for uh powered
xml file so without which the pound xml
file will not be validated and will will
be getting a kind of validation errors
so the minimum required elements are
project root
model version so it should be 4.0.0 the
group id of the project the artifact id
of the project and the version of the
artifact these are the minimum things
which we want to define so that we can
understand that what kind of artifact we
are trying to prepare or we are trying
to create here so these are the minimum
required elements which is required in
the palm.xml file without which the
validation of the palm file will fail
and the build will also fail here
now what exactly is the mint uh with the
term called build tool so build tool is
an essential tool is a kind of a process
for building or compiling the source
code here so it's needed or it's
required for the below for generated
processes if you want to generate the
source code if you want to compile the
source code you want to generate the
source code you want to generate some
documentation from the source code you
want to compile the source code or you
want to package the source code whether
it's a jar file it's a war file or it's
a er file so whatever the packaging mode
you want to select you will be able to
do it with the help of the particular
build tool here and if you feel that you
want to upload these particular
artifacts to the artifact tree whether
it's on remote machine or locally there
so that also you can do it with the help
of this particular build tools here so
build tools can be helpful in doing a
lot of activities for the developers
now one of the different steps which is
involved to install maven on windows now
all you have to do is that you have to
just first of all download the uh tar
file from the maven apache maven
repository there once that is done so
what happens that you have to set up
some couple of environment variables now
if you download the java jdk using the
exe file in that case the java undisco
home will be configured automatically
but if it is not available and you are
not able to run the java command line in
that case you have to set up the java
underscore home and then similarly for
maven you have to go for the maven
underscore home that particular variable
you have to configure now once that is
done all you have to do is that you have
to edit the path variable so the bin
directory of the maven extracted a
folder you have to put it up into the
path variable and once that is done what
will happen that you will be able to
check the latest version the version of
the maven over there if it is like some
old version again you have to extract
the latest version and do the steps all
together again so these are some of the
ways that in which you can actually go
for the installation or the
configurations of maven on the windows
platform
now what are the different steps which
is involved for the installation of
maven and ubuntu so ubuntu it's fine you
just download the package of java jdk
there once the jdk is installed over
there what you can do you can simply go
and say that yes i want to search for a
particular maven
package which is available there so once
the jdk is installed all you have to do
is that you have to configure the java
underscore home
m3 underscore home memo and disco home
and the path variable once all the path
variables are something which is
configured then you will be able to
check the latest version like whether
it's uh the version is correct or we are
getting the standard version over here
or not over here so that's the main
mechanism that how we will be able to
you know configure the maven on ubuntu
here now what exactly is the command to
install to char into the locals
repository now sometimes what happens
that we are not able to fetch like uh
some dependencies not present on the
particular central repository minimum
repository or your artifactory
repository in that case you have some
third-party jar which we want to install
locally onto your repository so in that
case we can go for the uh but we can
download the jar file there and then we
can run the command called mvn install
install hyphen file and then we are
giving the path like hyphen d file where
the path of the file should be provided
now once that is done so what will
happen that in the local dot m2
directory this specific artifact will be
downloaded and will be installed there
so this is a mechanism where you will be
able to configure or you will be able to
set up the artifacts locally the java
file locally here in the local
repository so next question is that how
do you know that the version of the
maven being used here so the inversion
of the movement is pretty easy to
calculate so all you have to do is that
you have to just go for mvn and space
hyphen iphone version the moment you do
that it will let you know that what jdk
or what java version you are using and
it will also show you that what
particular maven version you're going to
use here so all that details you will be
able to get with that particular command
here
now what exactly is the clean default
and frightened variable here so these
are the build cycles which is available
there in within maven so these are the
built-in build cycles so for clean what
happens that this life cycle will help
you to perform the project cleaning so
usually during the build there are some
files which is created into the target
directory so the clean life cycle is
essentially helping us to clean up all
that directory all that particular
target directory and when we talk about
the uh specific default so default
lifecycle handles the projector
deployment that is the default lifecycle
and site is something which is uh you
know helpful for creating the site
documentation
you know it's kind of a lifecycle which
is available there so clean default and
site are the different life cycles which
can perform different different kind of
attributes or different tasks here next
question
what exactly is a movement repository so
maven repository refers to the
directories of the package jar files
that contain metadata now the metadata
refers to the palm files relevant to
each project so here you can able to get
your artifacts uh stored there you can
download these artifacts also during the
maven build if you put up that
dependency you will there are different
kind of repositories which is available
there one is the local repository one is
a remote repository and one is the
central repository so these are the
different typical type of repositories
which we have where we can uh store the
artifacts also and from where we can
download the artifacts also whenever
required now the first one is the local
repository so local repository refers to
the machine of the developers itself
where all the project related files are
stored there now whenever we work on the
uh particular maven so there is an in
the home directory dot m2 folder is
created now usually whatever the
artifacts downloaded from artifactory or
from the
maven repository it gets cached locally
there and once it is downloaded next
time it will not download the same
artifacts or the same dependency
altogether again so this local
repository is something which is
available locally on the developers
machine only so it contains all the
dependent jars which a particular
developer is downloading during the
maven build now remote repositories
refers to the repository which is
present on the server and uh with from
where we will be downloading the
particular dependencies so the when when
we are running the movement build on a
fresh machine so usually over there the
local repository does not exist so in
that case what happens that the dot m2
directory is empty but the moment you
run the build what will happen that the
artifacts or the dependencies will be
downloaded from the remote repository
and uh once it is done once it's uh
downloaded it will be added or it will
be downloaded cached locally there and
it will be uh helpful in the future run
so that will be
considered as a local repository because
all the artifacts all the dependencies
are downloaded there and central
repository is something which is known
as the maven community where all the
artifacts is available there so usually
we cache or we mirror these central
repositories
as our particular remote repositories
because it could be a possibility that
these remote repositories are something
which we are hosting into our
organization and central repository is
something which is available centrally
for everyone to use it so
these are something you know uh some
kind of repositories where each and
every artifacts will be stored and
anyone will be able to have the access
to these uh particular artifacts here so
these artifacts are every artifacts
every open source uh artifacts is
something which is available over there
to these central repository now how does
the maven architecture really work here
so the main architecture really works in
the three steps the very first step is
that it reads the palm.xml file here
that's the very first step second it
downloads the dependencies uh defined in
the panel.xml file into the local
repository from the central or the
remote repository here once that is done
so it will uh you know create or
generate the reports according to the
lifecycles which you have configured
whether it's a clean
install
site
deploy package or whatever the lifecycle
you want to trigger you will be
triggering that particular life cycle
and corresponding to that the build or a
specific task will be performed so these
are the three steps in which the overall
build or any kind of uh execution of
palmer xml file really happens here now
what exactly is the maven build
lifecycle so maven lifecycle isn't
nothing but collection of steps here
that needs to be uh followed for doing a
proper uh build of a project here so
there are primary three built-in uh
cycles which is available there default
which handles the project deployment
clean which handles the project uh
cleaning there and site which handles
the creation of the project sites
documentation so these are the three
primary built-in build cycles life
cycles which is available as such
now so build lifecycle has you know
different kind of phases or the stages
here because in the previous uh
particular slide we were talking about
what what are the different uh
particular build life cycles which is
available there but these are the
different phases like what are the
different step-by-step executions like
for the deep down which is available
there inside a specific maven build life
cycle so here you can see that it's
compiling then the test compile test
execution is there then package
integration test to verify install and
the lastly deploy here so these are the
different build phases which is
available as such over here so what
exactly is the command to use to do a
particular maven site so mvn site is
something which is used to create a
maven site here now usually whatever the
artifacts is prepared that will be
prepared in the target directory so here
also you will be able to see a site
directory which is available there in
the target directory which you can refer
for the site documentations what is the
different conventions used while naming
a project in maven so usually
it involves three components
so the full name of a project in maven
includes first of all the group id
uh for example com.apache
com.example so these are some of the
particular way that where you can
provide the group id artifact id can be
exact project name like maven project or
whatever the project you are creating so
sample project example project so these
kind of things will be there in the
artifact id and lastly is the version
like which version of your artifact you
want to prepare like 1.0.0 hyphen
snapshot
2.0.0 so like this information you are
providing that what particular version
you are trying to configure here now
let's move on to the intermediate level
where we will be having a little bit
more complex questions related to the
maven here now what exactly is a maven
artifact now usually what happens that
when we do a build process as an end of
result of the build process we will get
some artifacts for example when we build
a.net project so there we will be able
to have a exe or dll files as an
artifacts
similarly in case of maven when we do a
build process there we get the different
kind of artifacts like depending on the
packaging mode like jar file
var files or the er files here so these
are something which is you know getting
generated during the build process
during the main process and you can
store them into your local repository or
you want to push them to the remote
repository it's something that totally
depends on you so maven is a tool which
can help you to create all the artifacts
whether it's a jar file whether it's a
var files or whether it's a er file here
and every artifact is having three
attributes the first one is the group id
the artifact id and a particular version
and that's how you will be able to
identify a full-fledged artifact as such
in maven so maven is not about only the
name of the jar file it's actually
referring to the attributes like crop id
the artifact id and the version of the
artifact here now what are the different
phases of the clean life cycle here so
clean is something which is being used
to clean the target directory so that a
fresh build can be triggered there so
there are three steps pretty clean clean
and post clean here so if you wish that
you want to override the particular life
cycle configurations and you want to run
some particular steps before the clean
activity so you can do it into the
pre-clean and if you want to do it like
some steps after clean then post clean
can be utilized now what are the
different phases of the site life cycle
so pre-site
site post site and site deploy so these
are the different phases which is
available there in the site life cycle
what is exactly we meant by the maven
plugin now
this is the huge difference between the
ant and maven here because in and we
were not having this that much support
of the plugins and that's the reason why
we had to deal with all the build
configurations
so we have to simply put the overall
build process that how the build should
be triggered but that is not something
which is there in case of maven in maven
we have a lot of flexibility because we
can actually put up what exactly build
configurations we want to put here we
can put some features like important
features over here in maven and uh these
plugins we can utilize for example i
want to perform a compilation now i
don't really want to do any kind of
configurations in this one so what i can
do is that i can simply use the
compilation plugin in maven and that can
really help me because i don't have to
unnecessarily write or rewrite the
configuration that how the compilation
should be done
it's something which is pre-configured
or pre-written in these plugins that i
can simply import the plug-in and i can
do the build process or the compilation
process in a pretty standard mode so i
don't really have to do any kind of
workarounds with that and simply with a
small automations i will be able to
reach that how these maven plugins can
be integrated into my palmer xml file
and i can desire or i can have some
particular procedures and some steps
executed there so that's the biggest
benefit which we really get with the
help of maven plugins now why exactly
the maven plugins are utilized so to
create a jar files to create the war
files to compile the code files to
perform the unit testing to create the
project documentation and to create the
project reports so there are a variety
of things in which we can actually use
these maven plugins through the
integrations within the palm xml file
there so it's all about the plugins you
just import the plugin and that desired
activity will be performed there now
what are the different type of plugins
which is there so
you can have either a build projects uh
for performing the build activities you
can have some build plugins for
reporting plugins also there which can
be only generated or utilized to
generate the reports to process the
reports and do any kind of formatting or
any kind of processing on the reports
here so that is where the reporting
plugins are utilized now what is exactly
the difference between the convention
and the configuration in maven so
convention is in particular process when
the developers are not required to
create the build processes so
configuration is when you know the
developers are supposed to create the
build processes so the users do not have
to rectify the configuration in detail
and once the project is created it will
automatically create a structure so they
must specify every in case of
configuration you have to provide each
and every details so that's how the uh
configurations really happens because um
you have to put every detail into the
panel xml file and that's how the
particular configurations really work as
such so this is the huge difference
between the conventions and the
configurations here
now
so why exactly said that maven uses
conventions over the configurations
maven pretty much does not puts any
efforts like on the particular
developers that they have to put each
and every configuration so there are
some ready-made
plugins which is available there and
pretty much we are making use of that so
that in such a case we don't have to
worry about the executions and we will
be able to pretty much work on that so
conventions like maven uses the
conventions incident of the
configurations so the developers just
you know they don't just have to create
the movement project the rest of the
particular structure will be compared
automatically so they are not uh you
know expecting that the developers
should be doing the configuration work
and everything should be taken care in
such a way that you just have to start
the things and the rest of the things
should be taken care by the maven itself
so maven will be
responsible because they do the plugins
it will be responsible to set up the
default architecture the default folder
structures and all you have to do is
that you have to just
place the source code in the desired
folder structure here so that's
something which you need to do as in
particular developers so what exactly is
the maven order of inheritance here so
the order of inheritance is the settings
cli parameters parent palm and the
project bomb which means that if you
have some configuration and settings
that will be the highest value then the
cli parameters are there then the parent
palm is there and then the project
prompt so this is the way that how the
uh particular parameters or the
configurations will be picked up by the
main one so that's the order so what
does the build life cycles and the
phases imply in the basic concept of
maven so build life cycles consist of a
sequence of build phases and each build
phase consists of a sequence of goals
when a phase is run uh all the goals
related to that phase and its plugins
are also compiled so you will be able to
have a lot of particular goals which is
residing inside of phase there and
similarly life cycle is nothing but a
kind of a sequence of the different
phase so life cycle comes in the top
then it comes on the phases and then it
comes on the goals here now what is the
terminology called goal in case of maven
the term a terminology goal refers to
the specific task that makes it possible
for the
project to be built and organized so
it's something which we can run so it's
a actual implementation which is going
on there for example in the build
process in the build phase i have a
different goals like clean install
package deploy these are the different
typical goals which is available there
which i can execute into the main one
here so these are the different goals
like uh which we can execute and which
we can run during a maven build next
question is what is exactly meant by the
term dependencies and the repositories
in maven here so dependencies refer to
the java libraries which we usually put
up into the bound.xml file there now
what happens that sometimes our source
code is requiring some java files like a
secondary jar files for performing the
build process so instead of downloading
it and storing it into the class path
for during the build process we just
have to specify the dependency of that
artifact what dependency we need to put
and once that dependency is put up there
we will be able to have that jar file
downloaded and cash into the local
repository during the maven build
project now if the dependencies are not
present in your local repository then
maven will try to download it from the
central repository and again if it is
not a uh you know
it's something which is available which
is downloaded from the central
repository then it will be cached
locally into the local repository so
that's the cycle which is being
implemented and utilized during this
process
now what exactly is in snapshot in maven
so snapshot refers to the version
already available in the movement report
repository it signifies the latest
development copy that's what we do with
the case of snapshot here so meven
checks for a new version of snapshot in
the remote repository for every new
build so during the build process like
you know a new snapshot version is being
downloaded and the snapshot is updated
by the data service team which uh with
updated source code every time to the
repository for each maven bit so snap
shot is something which we will be using
like very frequently we will be updating
to that and frequently we will be
updating the version to that and we will
try to explore and we'll try to do the
modifications now what are the different
type of projects available in maven so
there are thousands of java projects
which you know uh can be utilized or we
can be uh implemented by my one here so
this helps the
as the user that they as they no longer
have to remember every configurations to
set a particular project for example
spring boot spring mvc spring boot etc
these are the different projects which
is already available in maven so most of
the uh we have already discussed that
for the job-based projects maven is
something which is you know considered
as by default so a lot of organizations
are actually using it for you know
storing or utilizing it for the
particular maven project now what
exactly is the maven uh archetype over
here so maven octave refers to a maven
plugin that is uh entitled to create a
for project structure as per its
template these archetypes are just
project templates that are generated by
maven when any new project is created
there so this is something which we are
using so that we will be able to create
a fresh new projects
right so let's go on to the advanced
level of this maven questions now what
exactly is the command to create a new
project based on an archive type so mvn
archetype generate is used to create a
new java uh project based on the
archetype now this will take up some
parameters from
as an end user from you and depending on
that parameters it will create the
palm.xml file it will create the source
directories uh inside that main java
test all these different couple of
directories directly structures will be
automatically created now why we require
this command so that if you are going to
create a project from scratch from the
from the day one this command will help
you to have all the folder structures
created and then further on you can put
up your source code and those files as
such in this folder structure so that's
how is the mechanism that we will be
able to see that how the setup can be
performed really over here now what does
maven clean implies now moving clean is
a plugin that suggests that it's going
to clean the files and directories there
so whenever we do a build process
usually in the target directory we have
some class files some jar files or
whatever the generated source code which
is available that will be present in the
darker directory so the maven clean is
something which is available which is
going to clean all these directories and
why we are doing this directly structure
cleanup so that we will be able to do a
fresh uh build process and there should
not be any kind of
issues as such over here so that's the
main reason why we are looking forward
for this uh particular mechanism or for
this uh particular changes as such here
now so what exactly isn't build profile
all about so build profiles refers to
the set of configurations uh where we
can have like typically two different
kind of build processes there so if you
feel that the same pom.xml file you can
use you want to run for different
different uh particular configurations
so that you will be able to do pretty
much with the help of this component so
build profile is used to do a
customization processes so that you will
be able to have the process and you will
be able to perform the configurations
and the setups all together there so
that's a very important aspect to be
considered that which we need to uh
discuss when we talk about the build
profile so build profile whenever you
feel that you want to do some
customizations and you want to proceed
with the setup so that's where it's
utilized next thing is that what are
different type of build profiles which
is available there so the build profiles
can be done on for a particular project
like per project you can do you can uh
even do the build profiles in the
settings.xml file also and if you feel
that you want to do it into the
globalsettings.xml file so that also you
can do as such over here so there are
different ways in which you can do the
customization and once the customization
is done you will be able to have the
different uh ways of doing the setups
and the configurations over there so
what exactly is meant by the uh
particular system dependencies here so
let's talk about that also so system
dependencies refers to the uh particular
mechanisms where we feel that how the
dependencies should be you know present
there so that is something which is
having a scope of system there so these
dependencies are commonly used to help
me one know the dependencies that is
being provided by the jdk system
dependencies are mostly used to resolve
the dependencies on the artifacts that
are provided by the jdk so these
dependencies are somewhat which is being
utilized and used over here so that we
will be able to implement and go ahead
through the system dependencies what is
the reason for using an optional
dependency here so optional dependencies
are used to decrease the transitive
burden of some libraries so what happens
that when you download an artifact when
you put up a dependency so it could be a
possibility that some dependencies as in
particular optional can also be
downloaded now these are not always
required but yes sometimes what happens
that these are downloaded so that you
don't have to put uh each and every uh
artifact or dependency into the power
xml file for example you're trying to
download some apache tool and with that
some like three four jar files or three
four another dependencies are also
getting downloaded now if you are using
that dependencies that totally create
because you don't have to put that uh
list or that entry in the dependency
list in the power xml file and that can
really save your time but if you feel
that you don't want to have them and you
these are the optional ones and you
really want to
get rid of that so that also you can
exclude while downloading any kind of
dependencies so these are the optional
ones which depending on your requirement
you can utilize you can
process and if you feel that you don't
want to get it you won't want to process
it you can simply ignore it and you can
get rid of that also now what is a
dependency scope and how many type of
dependencies scope are there so there
are different type of dependencies
scores which is there which is used on
each and every stage of the build here
so compile provided runtime test system
import these are the different kind of
dependency scopes which we have using
which we can define that when exactly we
want to go ahead for a specific build
process so depending on your requirement
you can explore all these build scopes
and you can get benefits out of that
what is exactly an intransitive
dependency in maven so maven avoids the
need to find out and specify libraries
that our own dependencies require by
including the transitive dependencies
automatically so transitive dependencies
says that if he depends if x depends on
y and y depends on z then x depends on y
and both there
so which means that you are not
depending on one artifact you also need
the z artifact there with the y artifact
so that is what you need to do so that
you will get both the dependencies there
because this is normal that if you are
trying to
download some particular artifacts or
download some dependency and that
dependency is also dependent on some
other artifact or some other jar file
then you have to include both of them so
this is something which you will be able
to get so that you can easily download
all these uh dependent jar files also
and the maven build can be success how
can a maven build profile can be
activated so even build profile can be
activated through a different ways so in
explicitly using the command command
line you can talk about that which
profile you want to execute through
maven settings you can do uh based on
environment parameters os settings and
present and missing files so these are
the different ways in which you can
actually activate at which particular
profile you want to have so profiles
configurations can also be saved in
various situations and various files and
from there you will be able to refer
that which file you want to refer as
such now what is meant by the dependency
exclusion the exclusion is used to
exclude any transitive dependency
because you never know that if you are
trying to put up a dependency uh entry
in the palm xml file that artifact is
also further dependent on another
artifact so in order to feel in order to
see that you want to exclude that
dependent artifact which is being
automatically downloaded that also we
can exclude with the help of exclusion
so you can
avoid the transitive dependency with the
help of dependency exclusions here so
what exactly is in mojo so mojo is
nothing but maven plain old java object
here so it's an executable goal in maven
and a plug-in refer to the distribution
of such mozos so moses enable the maven
to extend its functionality
that already is not founded in so it's
kind of an extension which is there and
using this we can get some additional
benefits and some executions over there
so what is the command to create a new
project based on a hard drive so again
archetype is something which we normally
use to create uh the new projects now
you can give the parameters in the
command itself or you want it to in in
kind of an interactive mode where it
will take the parameters from the end
user and according to that the project
will be created onto hard drive or onto
server wherever you wish you want to
create you can create a new project
so explain about the maven settings dot
xml file so maven settings.xml file
contains the elements that are used to
define that how the movement execution
should be there so there are different
uh settings like local remote central
all these different repositories are
configured as such over here now in this
case what happens that uh usually the
configurations are done in such a way
that it can you know go for the uh
executions it can go for the build
process and the complete executions can
be
involved and can be achieved as such
here so all these executions are
something which we can really perform
and uh here we can put some credentials
how to connect to the remote repository
how to connect to remote repository all
that stuff is something which we talked
about over here what exactly is that
meant by term super bomb here so super
form refers to the default bomb of maven
so the moms of even can't derive from so
it's nothing but a reference to a parent
bomb which is available there that is a
super pump so if you define some
dependencies in that super pump
automatically the uh child bomb will
also be able to inherit all those
dependencies so we can put some uh
executions like we can put some
configuration in the super pump so that
if multiple
projects are going to refer that they
should be able to refer that easily so
that's the reason why we primarily use
the super pump so that we can have the
execution some processes
uh put up over there and all the other
projects should be effort to refer or
inherit from there so where exactly the
dependencies are stored so dependencies
are stored like in different locations
like you have the local repository
remote repositories there local
repositories on the local developers
machine and remote repository something
which is available on a server in form
of artifactory jenkins is a popular
devops open source automation server
it is used to automate the non-human
part of software development
and supports continuous integration and
continuous delivery
jenkins is a server based system that
runs in servlet containers such as
apache tomcat
we have compiled the most important
jenkins interview questions that you
might face in a jenkins or devops
interview
so without further ado let us get
started with jenkins interview questions
and answers so the first question you'll
be asked about with jenkins is explain a
master slave architecture of jenkins so
the way that jenkins is set up is that
the jenkins master will pull code from
your remote
git repository such as github and will
check that repository every time there
is a code commit it will distribute the
workload of that code and the tests that
need to be applied to that code to all
of the jenkins slaves and then on
request the jenkins master and the
slaves will then carry out all the
builds and tests to be able to produce
test reports the next question you'll be
asked is what is a jenkins file and
simply put a jenkins file is a text file
that has a definition of the jenkins
pipeline and is checked into a source
code repository and this really allows
for three distinct things to happen one
it allows for a code review and
iteration of the pipeline it permits an
audit trail for that pipeline and also
provides a single source of truth for
the pipeline which can be viewed and
edited so which of the following
commands runs jenkins from the command
line is it java jar jenkins dot war java
dash war jenkins.jar
java.jar jenkins jar java dash war
jenkins.org
and the answer is a java jar jenkins dot
wall so when working with jenkins you're
going to be asked what are the key
concepts and aspects of working with a
jenkins pipeline and you want to really
hold out your fingers here and go
through four key areas and that is
pipeline node step and stay so pipeline
refers to the user-defined model of a cd
continuous delivery pipeline node are
the machines which is which are part of
that jenkins environment within the
pipeline step is a single task that
tells jenkins what to do at that
particular point in time and then
finally stage defines a conceptually
distinct subset of tasks performed
through the entire pipeline and tasks
could be build test and deploy so which
of the following file is used to define
dependency in maven and do we have a
build.xml
b
palm.xml c dependency.xml
or d
version.xml and the answer is
palm.xml working with jenkins you're
going to be asked to explain the two
types of pipeline used in jenkins along
with the syntax and so a scripted
pipeline is based on groovyscript as
their domain specific language for
jenkins and there are one or more
noteblocks that are used throughout the
entire pipeline on the left hand side
you can actually see what the actual
script would look like and the right
hand side shows what the actual
declaration for each section of that
script would be the second type of
jenkins pipeline is a declarative
pipeline and a declarative pipeline
provides a simple and a friendly syntax
to define what the pipeline should look
like and then you can actually at this
point use an example to actually break
out how blocks are used to define the
work completed in a decorative pipeline
so how do you create a copy and backup
of jenkins well to create a backup
periodically back up jenkins to your
jenkins home directory and then create a
copy of that directory it's really as
simple as that a question you'll be
asked as well is how can you copy
jenkins from one server to another well
there essentially there are three ways
to do that one is you can move a job
from one installation of jenkins to
another by copying the corresponding job
directory the second would be to create
a copy of an existing job directory and
making a clone of that job directory but
with a different name and the third is
to rename an existing job by renaming a
directory so security is fundamental to
all the work that we do within devops
and jenkins provides the center core to
all the work that gets completed within
a devops environment there are three
ways in which you can apply security to
authenticate users effectively and when
you're asked about this question of
security within jenkins the three
responses you want to be able to provide
is a jenkins has its own internal
database that uses secured user data
from and user credentials b is you can
use a ldap or lightweight directory
access protocol server to be able to
authenticate jenkins users or c you can
actually configure jenkins to
authenticate by using such as oauth
which is a more modern method of being
able to authenticate users you're going
to be asked how to deploy a custom build
of a core plug-in within jenkins and
essentially the four steps you want to
go through are first of all copying the
dot hpi plugin file into the jenkins
home plugins subdirectory you want to
remove the plugins development directory
if there is one you want to create an
empty file called
plugin.hpi.pinned and once you've
completed these three steps restart
jenkins and your custom build plugin
should be available how can you
temporarily turn off jenkins security if
the administrative user has locked
themselves out of the admin console this
doesn't happen very often but when it
does it's good to know how you can
actually get into jenkins and be able to
resolve the problems of authenticating
effectively into the system as an
administrator so when you want to be
able to get into a jenkins environment
what you want to be able to do is locate
the config file you should see that it's
set to true which allows for security to
be enabled if you then change the user
security setting to false security will
disable allow you to make your
administrative changes and will not be
re-enabled until the next time jenkins
is restarted
so what are the ways in which a build
can be scheduled and run in jenkins well
there are four ways in which you can
identify the way a build can be
scheduled on running jenkins the first
is when source code management commits
new code into the repository you can run
jenkins at that point the second can be
the after the completion of other builds
so maybe you have multiple builds in
your project that are dependent to each
other and when so many other builds have
been executed then you can have jenkins
run you can schedule bills to run at a
specified time so you may have nightly
builds of your code that illustrates the
changes in the solution you're building
and then finally you also can manually
build a environment on request
occasionally you will want to also
restart jenkins and so it's good that
when a question around how do you
restart jenkins manually comes up that
you have the answers and there are two
ways in which you can do it one is you
can force a restart without waiting for
bills to complete by using the jenkins
url that you have for your environment
slash restart or you can allow all
running bills to complete before restart
are required in which case you would use
the command of the url for your jenkins
environment slash safe restart hey guys
welcome to a session on selenium
interview questions by simply learn in
this video we will look at most commonly
asked questions in the interview and
some guidelines on how to answer them
nowadays automation tool and especially
the selenium skills is a very key
requirement for an qa engineer or even
an automation engineer jobs so if you're
on an outlook of automation engineer or
a qa engineer positions i'm sure this
question bank will definitely help you
prepare for your interview so this video
consists of three parts basically three
different levels of set of questions one
is the beginner level second is the
intermediate level and then the advanced
level questions and each level has a set
of 10 most probable questions which you
might be asked in the interview so let's
begin with the beginner level questions
question 1 what are selenium suite
components so selenium is a set of tools
and libraries to facilitate automation
on web applications you already know
this it is not a single tool so what are
those components which are comprised in
the selenium so selenium comes with four
major components the first one is the id
id happens to be the most simplest tool
in the whole suite of selenium it is
nothing but an integrated development
environment which has a record and
playback functionality this was earlier
available as only firefox plugin however
you need to know that the new version of
selenium ide is available as a chrome
extension as well as a firefox plugin so
that means you can either use any of the
browsers that is firefox or the chrome
for recording your test scripts also you
should also know that the new id comes
with many new features and
now this new ide is become more powerful
than what was available earlier so some
of these new features are like
reusability of your test cases it comes
with a better debugger now and most
importantly it supports parallel test
execution and how does it do that it has
a utility called selenium side runner
that's about selenium id the next
component is the selenium remote control
so selenium remote control or popularly
called as selenium rc is used to write
web application test in different
programming languages it supports
multiple programming languages like java
c
perl python ruby and php it is nothing
but it's a server which interacts with
your browser using a simple http get and
post request for communication selenium
rc is also called as selenium 1.0
version or selenium core third component
selenium webdriver it is a programming
interface to run your test cases and
webdriver was introduced by simon
stewart in 2006 and this was introduced
to overcome some of the limitations of
selenium rc so rc's architecture was
very complex because it required an
additional server in its setup and why
was that additional server for
communicating with the browser and what
webdriver did was it removed this
dependency completely web driver
interacts directly with the browser and
also makes your test cases run much
faster than your rc the last component
the selenium grid a very important tool
this is used to run multiple test
scripts on multiple machines at the same
time now with the selenium webdriver you
can only do sequential execution but in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment so this grid
allows parallel execution of tests on
different browsers as well as different
operating system so the design is in
such a way that commands are distributed
on multiple machines where you want to
run the test and they are executed
simultaneously this uses a simple
hubbard node concept where hub controls
the all execution of your test cases on
the nodes and this is how we achieve
parallel execution and what is the major
advantage of having this grid it is to
reduce your overall test execution type
question two what are the limitations of
selenium now like any other tool
selenium also has certain limitations so
when you are answering this question you
will also be expected to talk about what
is the work around available for all
these limitations so let's look at them
one by one no reliable tech support of
course selenium is an open source so if
you look at it you do not have much
technical support available however
there are loads of documentation
available there are forums available
which you can refer to seleniumhq.org
is the website is your bible if you're
working with the selenium and then there
are there are a lot of selenium google
groups and the forums which are
available for any kind of support so
selenium has been there for quite some
time so it's it's one of the most mature
tool available today so even though we
do not have a technical support
available there is enough documentation
available on the internet the second
limitation selenium can test only web
application selenium is an open source
tool that is designed to automate
web-based applications on different
browsers but it cannot handle
windows gui or non-html pop-ups in the
application now what is the workaround
available for that selenium provides a
support for integrating other tools like
autoit so autoeta is a tool for handling
your windows based activity selenium
also cannot automate mobile applications
but then what is available with that it
can integrate a tool called apm tool
which is a mobile automation tool the
third limitation limited support for
image testing selenium is a de facto
tool for functional web web application
tests so standard api allows interacting
only with the browser and it's hard to
test the images based applications using
selenium what is the other tool
available securely is a very good tool
to use for image testing and this again
you can integrate securely with selenium
that's how you can achieve your image
testing through selenium but using the
security tool no built-in reporting
facility so selenium does not have any
reporting capability as such of course
it does provide a very limited reporting
capability where some basic reports are
created but definitely when you are
working in a framework you need a better
support for
good reporting tools so that way
selenium supports some of the tools like
test ng report ng and extent reports
using which you can integrate these
tools with selenium and generate
beautiful reports limited test
management selenium does not provide any
test tool integration with test
management tools may require knowledge
of programming languages so since
selenium supports multiple programming
languages the developer of the test
automation will require to have some
basic knowledge of any of the supported
programming language why one in order to
write your effective automation scripts
and of course because selenium tool you
want to use it at its full potential
question three what are the testing
types supported by selenium so selenium
supports regression testing and
functional testing these can be called
as a very high level categories so what
is regression testing regression testing
is a full or partial selection of
already executed test cases which are
re-executed to ensure your existing
functionality does not break so let's
look at what are these attributes of
regression testing and why we say that
selenium helps us in doing regression
testing so regression tests are run
every time a new fix has been received
or a new feature has been deployed so
that is called as retesting you can
always select a full suite or select a
test to test a fix or a complete product
so your selection can be based on
recently added features a test area
where most defects are there or
integration areas or even end-to-end
kind of tests you can also prioritize
your test cases based on critical
functionalities and business impact of
this test cases according to the
priority set so all this can be done
using selenium now what is the second
category of the testing which it
supports functional testing so
functional testing includes what your
smoke does sanity tests say installed as
database test basically any kind of
functionality which you are going to
test and if you look at the kind of
steps which are involved in that it
involves identification of your test
inputs expected outputs or the results
the test case logic itself and the
assertions so a typical flow will be
you identify your test inputs first then
you derive your test outcomes or the
expected outputs you design and execute
your test cases and then assert on the
expected versus action outcomes question
four what are selenium 2.0 and three
daughter versions so selenium was
introduced by a gentleman called jason
huggins way back in 2004 and that was
selenium version since then this tool
has gone through multiple changes to
make it better and better so if selenium
two dot version had a major change it
took a leap forward in terms of browser
automation the selenium rc the remote
control had a disadvantage of having the
need of an additional server to talk to
the web browsers and because of this the
text execution was much slower and the
com architecture itself became very
complex so if you look at this selenium
2 it had two components a successor to
rc and the rc itself which is called as
your core so this successor was nothing
but your web driver api so webdriver
apis made it easier to write your
automation scripts for any browser by
simply using a suitable driver for any
browser which you want to run the tests
on apart from these two components the
selenium 2.0 version also had the id and
the grid components so in summary if you
look at it selenium 2.4 version has an
ide it has selenium rc which was on its
way of deprecation webdriver api which
was just introduced in there a very very
earlier version of webdriver api and the
grid so what is selenium 3.0 consists so
selenium 3.0 rc was completely
eliminated now because in 2.0 it was
already on its path of deprecation and
webdriver replaced rc completely so if
you look at the components of 3.0 we
have ide we have a web driver and grid
as the major components so now with this
introduction of web driver a
full-fledged web driver selenium became
the most powerful tool for web
application automation question five a
very important question what is same
origin policy and how was it handled now
same origin policy is a security id
feature so it is a very important
concept in web application security
model and what is this according to this
policy a web browser allows scripts from
one web page to access the contents of
another web page provided both these
pages are on the same origin now what
does origin mean origin is nothing but a
combination of your url schema the host
number and the port number it's
basically your domain now if a such
question is asked how are you going to
explain it so let's say you have a
javascript program which runs in a
certain domain say google.com okay so
this program can access all the programs
which are from the same origin now
origin here is what google.com so for
example you can access other pages like
your google drive your google email or
your google calendar however now if you
use the same javascript right so if you
use the same script from the google.com
to access another page or an element in
a different domain say yahoo.com then
the security model of the web
application itself prohibits you to do
so so what happens because of that is
you are limited with access only to
those elements and pages which are in
the same domain but now look at the case
that you want to run your test on
multiple servers and you might also want
to access multiple domain so due to the
same origin policy you will not be able
to do so and this became a major
limitation with a very early selenium
tool so how was this handled so this got
handled by paul heman who created the
selenium remote control so he created
the selenium remote control server to
trick the browser in believing that the
selenium core and the web application
under test actually came from the same
domain and this is how the same origin
policy was handled and this selenium rc
which is selenium remote control became
the version one of selenium question six
what is celine's and how is it
classified selenium commands for
selenium ide are often called as
selenius they are a set of commands that
run your test and sequence of this
command is called as a test script now
these commands are categorized into
three major categories one is the action
command now action commands are the
commands that generally manipulate the
state of your application for example
they can do things like click on this
link or select a particular option open
a url type certain text into an input
box click or double click on any web
element and so on so these are called as
action commands the second set of
commands is the accessors now accessors
examine the state of the application and
store the results in a variable so it
basically allows the user to store
certain values to a user defined
variable for example if i want to store
the page title of a web page i can do
that by defining a user defined variable
and then these stored values can be
later used to create your assertions or
verifications in your test now few
examples of such commands are you can
just use a store story or a store text
store title or a store value so these
are some of the accessor commands the
third category is the assertions
assertions are like your accessors but
they verify the state of your
application and conforms to what is
expected so basically it is a comparison
of your actual versus expected results
there are two types of assertions
available one is the softer sessions and
the harder sessions an example of your
soft assertion can be verify title
wherein you verify the title check
whether the expected and the actual
outcomes are the same and continue with
your test case now whereas in hard
assertion is you do an assert title
using the command assert title and if at
all the assertion fails the test case
stops from executing question 7 mention
the types of web locator what is web
locator a locator is a command that
tells the selenium which ui element you
want to operate on selenium uses
locators to find and match the elements
of your web page which it needs to
interact with and there are around eight
locating techniques in selenium the
first one is by id now this is the most
common way of locating elements why
since the ids are supposed to be unique
for each element the ids can also be
dynamic in nature so you can identify
them by inspecting the attributes of the
web element so let's look at an example
so if we go to a facebook right so if
you go to the facebook and say if i want
to identify this element email so if you
look at this highlighted text here it
has a unique id which is email so if i
am going to operate on this particular
element email i can directly use the id
locating technique link text and the
partial link text so this type of
locator applies only to the hyperlink
text so we access the link by using this
locator which needs the hyperlink text
to be provided so for link text you can
give a complete text in the link text or
let let's look at an example of that so
let's if you go to say one of the
e-commerce site which is say amazon dot
in and say you want to click on this
two-day steel link so if you look here
in amazon.com there are a lot of
hyperlinks available here and if an
example if you have to take an example
say we want to click on the today's tree
now if you inspect this element you will
see that it has an anchor tag a it has
an associated href link here and also it
has a text which says today's deal right
which is what is displayed on your web
page now similarly there is also a link
available here called customer service
so if you inspect that customer service
it also has something similar what the
today's deal had it has an anchor tab it
has an edge riffling and it has a long
text which says customer service which
is what is displayed now if you have to
use your web locator which is a linked
text you need to provide the complete
text which is displayed on your web page
and there is another way of using the
link text by saying partial link text
where you can just give a partial text
which can be matched against the
complete text of your link and this is
how you can use your partial link text
or the link text the next id is by name
so locating elements by name is very
similar to locating by id just that your
attribute instead of using an id you're
going to use name in this case now if
you look at the same example of say
facebook we identified this email
element using its id you can also locate
the same element by using the name
attribute which is also unique in this
case which has a value called email tag
name that's the next identifier so
locate element using tag name of the
element now say if you want to identify
all the elements on your web page which
are of type button so that you can do by
using the tag name as button there for
example again on your facebook page i
know that there is a single button here
which is of type button and which has a
tag as button and this is the only
button which is available on this page
so if i want to access this particular
element i can simply use a locator
technique called tag which is button in
this case next locator class name so
locate an element using its class name
attribute so you can use this identifier
only if you find that a class name is
unique for a web element which you want
to work with class names are sometimes
unique a web element can also have
multiple class name or even you will
find some elements which has no class
name so depending on what is available
in the attributes you can use this class
name for identification so example the
shown on your screen here where it says
find element by class name input text
basically this is going to list out all
elements on your web page which has a
class name called input text the next
identifier is by xpath now expert is a
language used when locating xml nodes
what is xml extendable markup language
it can access almost any element even
those without any class names or names
or even id attributes so whenever you do
not find a unique attribute for id name
or class name you can construct an expat
to create an unique identifier for that
particular element now for example on
this facebook page if you observe here
there is a label here called create an
account so if you inspect this
particular label it has no attributes
other than a tag called spam so if you
want to identify this particular element
and say display it this is one of the
ways to do it is through xpath css
selector so css selector are string
patterns used to identify an element
based on the combination of either the
html tag id class or any other
attributes locating by css selector is
little more complicated than any of the
previous method however the advantage is
css selectors work much faster than the
xpath the performance of your test
scripts is much better when you use css
selector than any other locating
technique now again as an example if you
see the facebook again you can identify
the same email here right i used an id
here or a name attribute here to
identify it so assume that if you did
not have any of those things or if you
want to use a css selector here you can
still do that by using this syntax this
is how you use the css selector to
identify an element question 8 what are
the types of weights supported by
webdriver now before even you answer
this question you should know why do we
need weights in selenium weights play a
very important role in executing test
cases most of the web applications are
developed using using ajax and
javascripts so when a page is loaded by
the browser the elements which you want
to interact may load at a different time
intervals not only this makes it
difficult to identify the elements but
also if the element is not located it
will start throwing element not visible
exception and how do we resolve this by
using the weights so there are three
different kind of weights available in
selling it first one is the implicit
weight the implicit weight tells the
browser or your web driver to wait for a
certain amount of time before it can
throw a no such element exception now
the default setting is zero for this
once we set a time what webrt webdriver
does it it will wait for that time so if
you have mentioned 10 seconds it will
wait for 10 seconds until it finds the
element and even in the 10 seconds it is
unable to find that element only after
that it throws an exception now what is
the syntax of this implicit weight is
this is the syntax of this where you use
driver.manage timeouts implicit weight
and there is a timeout value say 10
seconds and the unit whether it's in
minutes seconds or milliseconds is what
you can mention implicit weight is
applied globally to all the elements
which means it is available for all the
web elements throughout the driver
instance implicit weight is defined only
once and it will remain same throughout
the driver object instance now let's see
what explicit weight is so explicit
weight is used to tell the web driver to
wait for certain conditions before
throwing an element not visible
exception it is defined to wait for
certain expected conditions only now
these expected conditions can check
whether the element is displayed on the
web page or not or can be clicked or not
so any kind of conditions you can
mention there so these are called as
conditional weights and they are applied
on a web element on a single web element
unlike the implicit weight which was
kind of applied globally to all elements
it is definitely recommended to use this
explicit weights when your elements are
taking longer time to load and also for
verifying the property of the elements
like say visibility of the element
located element to be click clickable or
element to be selected then we have
fluent width now fluid weight is used to
tell the web driver to wait for a
condition that is very similar to the
explicit weight as well as a frequency
with which we want to keep checking the
condition before throwing the not
visible exception so fluent weight is
used to define the maximum amount of
time you want the web driver to wait for
a condition then if you look in the
syntax then there is polling every
second so polling every and you give a
timeout this could be like five seconds
so start pulling to see whether the web
element is available or not say once in
three seconds once in four seconds
depending on your use case and then dot
ignoring so you can also try to ignore
specific type of exceptions while
waiting now for example such as no such
element exception which is sometimes
thrown when searching for an element on
page so you can mention even that here
so fluid weight takes two parameters one
is the timeout value and the polling
frequency so when we have web elements
which sometimes are visible after few
seconds or sometimes it takes more time
than usual like we have ajax
applications as an example we can set a
default polling period based on our
requirement and then as i said you can
also ignore some of the exceptions by
pulling this element question nine
mention the types of navigation commands
available in selenium so webdriver
provides a basic
browser navigation commands that allows
the browser to move forward backward
refresh and using the browser history
and this is done using some of the
driver.navigate methods right so these
are some of the commonly used navigation
methods first one is navigate to so this
method loads a new web page in the
existing browser window and it accepts
string as a parameter and returns
nothing so it's a void so the url you
mentioned here needs to be a fully
formed url driver.navigate.refresh
so this method refreshes or reloads the
current webpage in the existing browser
window it neither accepts anything so
there is no value path or it returns
nothing forward so this method enables
the web browser to click on the forward
button in the existing browser window
again this has this has no arguments to
be passed or it returns nothing
driver.navigate.back so this method
enables the web browser to click on the
back button in the existing browser
window again this returns nothing nor it
needs any argument question 10 what is
the major difference between
driver.close and driver.quit so this is
again a very important question and
pretty confusing also sometimes so
selenium webdriver provides two methods
for closing the browser window one is
browser.close and the other one is the
browser.quit so you might think to use
them interchangeably and that's that's
what everybody thinks that both anyway
does the same function so it can be used
however it is not so both are two
different methods now driver.close
command is used to close the current
browser window which is having the focus
and in case if there is a only single
browser window open then calling this
driver.close actually quits the complete
browser session now it is used when you
are working with say multiple browser
tabs or windows and you want to just
close one of them which is in focus in
the test whereas the driver.quit is used
to quit the complete browser session
along with all its associated windows
tabs pop-ups and everything so when do
you use browser.quit it is best to use
use browser.quit or sorry driver.quit
when you no longer want to interact with
the driver object along with all its
associated windows tabs and pop-ups
generally it is one of the last
statements of your automation scripts so
in case you are like working with
selenium with test ng or geoj unit we
usually call this driver.quit in the
after switch that is at after switch
method of our test suite thus by by
doing that we close the complete browser
session at the end of the test fit
execution now let's look at some
intermediate level questions question 11
how to type in an input box using
selenium so selenium provides a method
or a command you can say to insert value
into any of the input box and this
command is called as a send keys command
so send keys is a method available in a
web element now this is how you use the
send keys so here is an example so first
you need to find the element using any
of the eight locating techniques and
once you find the element in this case
which is an email field you need to call
a method called send keys send keys
takes an argument which is of type
string so you can pass the value which
you want to pass to the web element so
in this case you will be passing a gmail
id or any id which will be your email id
here and then similarly you do it for
your password field so first you find
the element password and then you send
the password using send case this is a
very simple method to use question 12
how to click on a hyperlink in selenium
so whenever you are testing an
e-commerce application you are going to
find lot of hyperlinks on your web pages
which you will obviously need to test
now selenium provides two locating
techniques using which you can identify
this hyperlinks and using these is what
you need to operate on the hyperlinks on
your web pages so one is using link text
and other one is using partial link text
so using link text you give a complete
text in the link text that is if you
look at in your e-commerce site let's
say amazon dot in let's let's go to that
website and see what it means so in the
amazon dot in if you look at uh some of
these hyperlink text called today's
deals or amazon pay or sell or customer
service if you inspect this element you
will see that this is associated with a
linked text which is called as today's t
along with this h ref and of course an
anchor tag so one way of identifying
this link is to use this complete text
which is today's t also there is another
way by using partial link text for say
example you have a link text which is
pretty long and you do not want to use
this complete text instead you can use
the locating technique called partial
link text and give a partial text from
that in this example instead of giving
the complete customer service here you
can just say use a customer or you can
just use service as your text only thing
whatever will be required here is this
has to be unique on this page there
shouldn't be two elements which would
have this text which you are going to
use so let's quickly see this in action
how do we use this link text and partial
link text now we will be using the same
example of amazon.com so my use cases
first i will click on this today's deal
and after a sleep of two or three
seconds i will also click on customer
service and i am going to achieve this
one by using link text so if you see in
this program so i have this method
written which is going to click on
today's deal and this is using a
locating technique link text and then i
also have another method here by using
partial link text i'm going to be
clicking on the customer service link
right so let's see how this works so
i'll just go ahead and execute this so
this launches the amazon dot in and the
first thing what we are doing is it is
going to click on today's tale all right
that is done and then it will click on
the customer service link right so this
is how you can achieve clicking on the
hyperlinks in your web applications
question 13 how to scroll down a page
using javascript
this is a very important question and
usually this gets asked quite often in
the interview you should know that you
can run java scripts through selenium
and selenium provides a way to do this
selenium provides an interface called
javascript executor javascript executor
and this helps in executing any kind of
javascripts through the selenium web
driver so this javascript executor it
has basically two methods one is execute
script and the other one is execute its
async script to run the javascript on
the selected window or on your current
page but why do you need this right so
if if you're answering this question you
should also have a background that why
at all this is required because
sometimes you need to perform certain
functions which cannot be done using the
locators what has been provided like say
scrolling down the web page itself also
sometimes you will see that you are
unable to even identify some web
elements using all the locating
techniques which is made available by
selenium so in such situations what you
can do is you can directly write a
javascript and execute it using this
javascript executor and if you look at
it the syntax is something like this so
it says javascript executor js is equal
to javascript executor and driver now if
you look at this javascript executor is
an interface that means you cannot
create an object of it and hence you
type cast it to your driver object now
how do you do this now first thing what
you do is you launch your web
application on whatever web application
is under test and then on that current
window you call this particular execute
script method using the javascript
executor and then you can perform any
functions here in this example we are
seeing a function which is crawling down
vertically so this function takes an
attributes or arguments like x
coordinate and the y coordinate now in
this example our x coordinate is 0 and y
coordinate is 1 000. that means when
this command gets executed the page is
going to get scrolled down vertically by
1000 pixels so why don't we just see
this in action so let's go to
another program here called the
scrolling test.java so basically what
i'm doing here is i'm going to be
logging into amazon.10 and then i will
show you how to scroll down by 600
pixels so it's a very very simple code
to write you launch your application
then you create your object of
javascript executor right actually you
type caster to the driver and then you
just use an execute script command or a
method this you see is your actual
script which gets executed which says
windows dot scroll by zero comma 600
which is x coordinate and y coordinate
let's go ahead and execute this so
amazon dot in is launched and you should
see the screen scrolling down yes there
we go so it just scroll down by few
pixels and that is 600 pixels what we
mentioned see i could scroll back again
and that is how you can achieve
scrolling functions and when do you
usually use this say if you have a very
long web page and you want to go and
identify or do some operations on the
web element which is probably available
to you towards the end of the page and
that is when you can use some of the
scrolling functions question 14 how to
assert the title of a web page selenium
web driver provides web driver methods
and one such method is called get title
so what get title does is it fetches the
title of the current page how to use
this command get titles returns a string
which is nothing but your title of your
page that means you need a string
variable in which you can store this
value so what you do is you define a
string variable like it is defined in
this example to store your title and
then you execute this command
driver.gettitle which is going to fetch
the title and that value gets stored in
your actual title once you get the title
you can do any operations with that in
this case what we are doing is we are
trying to verify the title there are two
ways which you can verify that one is
using an if else statement where you
compare your actual title with the
expected title or alternatively you can
also use assert statements here right so
selenium provides a search statement so
using assert you can validate whether
your title of the web page is as
expected question 15 how to mouse over
over an element
in automation many times it is required
to perform some action on the element
which gets visible only on the mouse
hovering on those elements now in
selenium action is a class which we can
use to achieve this functionality so
action class is defined in a package
called as selenium.interactions
this has a set of apis to emulate
complex user gestures it helps in
building the patterns of action and then
perform that action on a web element now
this action class provides a rich set of
apis like so for mouse events and even
the keyboard events so say for to
perform any kind of mouse event it
provides a method called move to element
now in this example what you do is you
initiate an object of mouse class and
then use this move to element method and
what it does is the element is scrolled
into the view first even before the move
operations happen so you could have
multiple actions like here in this
example we are just using move to
element but also you can if you want to
do a drag and drop observation you can
still have that so in such case where
you have multiple actions like a drag
and drop then you use a method called
build along with this so you say actions
dot move to element dot build and then
dot perform so dot build method is
called before the perform method and
what it does is it generates the
composite actions which has all those
multiple actions which you want to
perform on a web element then after the
building action is done you call a
perform method which actually performs
that action on your web element and this
is how the move to element method of the
action class is used why don't we just
see that in action let's say let's go to
our eclipse here and i have a mouse over
test written here so let's say we go to
amazon.website so in the amazon uh if
you go to the shop by category you see
that so the moment i mouse over it it is
going to give me this drop down list so
for me to select any element from this
my first action on this web page should
be to go and just hover my mouse over
this web element called shop by category
and that's exactly i'm going to achieve
through my automation now here in my
methods here what i have written i have
said okay first launch your website
which is amazon.n and then i'm finding
that element which is shop by category
using an x path so you could use any
available locating technique to find the
element first and then i instantiate an
object of actions and then simply i'm
doing is i'm using the method move to
element and then i'm just going to say
perform that means my mouse would
actually get moved or over onto that
particular element okay so let's see
this in action so i'll just execute this
test case okay so amazon. has launched
and now we should see yeah the mouse
actually moved to shop by category and
because of that we got this drop down
list so and this is how you can achieve
your mouse over functionality question
16 how to retrieve the css properties of
an element now css is nothing but
cascading style sheets it's a style
sheet language used for describing the
presentation of a document written in
your markup language it basically
describes your html elements as how they
need to be displayed on the screen it's
basically the look and feel like your
font size the width height color and so
on so it provides a special and easy way
to specify various properties of the
element now why do we need this we need
to use a special method called get css
value to retrieve such chs properties of
web element why because we already have
a method called get attribute which can
retrieve the value of the attributes
right however the get attribute method
can only retrieve those properties where
the attribute and its value are
mentioned in your dom and hence all this
font size color cannot be retrieved
through the get attribute method and
that is why we use the get css value so
basically it works like your get method
and you need to provide the attribute
which you want to fetch using the get
css value so in this example what we are
trying to do is we have a web element
called the email id and of that we are
trying to fetch the font size so let's
again check this in action so if i go to
my web page here
let's close this so if i go to my
facebook and if i inspect this
particular element which is the email id
and on the right if you see there are
multiple other attributes of that
element you see right so you see the
background color you see the color here
then you see something called as font
size and say for example we want to
retrieve the font size of this
particular web element and you will also
see on the left where you are seeing the
dom here you do not see that font size
anywhere as an attribute and its value
here and that is why i cannot use the
get attribute method to retrieve it now
instead of that what i am going to do is
i am going to use the get css value and
use this font size for that so let's go
to my eclipse i have a method written
here where i log into the facebook and
then i'm going to first find that
element which is by id and i'm going to
retrieve the css value and i'm just
simply printing it on the console so if
i execute this so it's going to launch
the facebook and since i'm not going to
do anything on the facebook web page as
such let's go to my console here because
this is where i am expecting the output
so here it has given me that an output
in the console saying 12 px which is
nothing but your actual font says what
you see here in your html page right and
this is how you can extract your css
properties of any web element on your
web page question 17 what is page object
model popularly known as pom page object
model is a design pattern that helps
create object repositories for web
elements so writing selenium test cases
without say using any patterns may lead
to co-duplicacy and also the code
becomes unmaintainable after some time
and say if you have web element locators
which changes over time then you will
have to go through the entire code base
to make all the required changes so
under this model for each web page in
the application there should be a
corresponding page class and this page
class will have all the web elements of
the web page and also it contains the
page methods which perform operations on
the web elements and the verification
steps required in your test cases are
the separate test cases they are not
combined in the same class now the tests
that use the methods of this page object
class whenever they need to interact
with the ui of that page the benefit
here is if the page ui changes that the
tests need not be changed only the code
within this page object class needs to
be changed that is you go and just
change the web elements or the locators
of the web elements only in one place
which is your page class and not in any
of your test classes or not test classes
so how does this form help so it makes
the code more readable maintainable and
reusable so there are two ways you can
implement a bomb or a page object model
one is done using the page factory which
is offered by selenium and then you can
also achieve a page object model without
using the page factory right using
directly the objects and the classes
question 18 can capture be automated
this is again a very favorite question
of the interview capture is a security
feature that prevents bots and automated
programs from accessing sensitive
information yes and captcha cannot be
automated you will see that there are
many applications today who have captcha
why because it's a security feature it
is a concept to differentiate between
human and computers the idea of capture
itself is to prevent any automated
process or a robotic process to do any
kind of actions and say if you're going
to automate it then the entire idea of
having the captcha is lost so you should
never attempt to automate it but then
what do you how can you handle this then
one either you can ask your developers
to disable it in the test environment so
that you can test the whole application
without having to hit on this captcha
other way of doing is you can use static
data for your captcha so that you can
hard code that value in your test for
the time being and then since your
application has captcha as one of its
functionality if you really need to test
that you can just test that separately
as a manual testing itself but not
automated question 19 how does selenium
handle windows based popup selenium is
an automation tool for automating web
applications it cannot handle windows
based application however we can use
tools like auto it and robot class along
with selenium to handle such pop-ups so
what are these tools robot class is a
java class which along with selenium can
simulate your keyboard and mouse events
it also helps in upload and download of
files and also to manage the pop-ups so
wherever you have a requirement of doing
a file upload operation in which if your
native dialog box opens up then one of
the way to handle it is using robot
class other tool which is available for
us is the auto it tool it is a freeware
and what it does is it uses a
combination of your mouse movement
keystrokes and window control
manipulation to automate any such task
which is not possible by selenium
webdriver and again this auto it tool
can be integrated with selenium and thus
you can achieve the automation of native
window based pop-ups question 20 how to
take screen shots in webdriver take
screenshot interface can be used to take
screenshots in webdriver so selenium
provides us this interface for managing
our screenshot operations now
screenshots are desirable for bug
analysis so selenium can automatically
take this screenshots during your
execution you know that it is very
important to take screenshots when we
execute the test scripts say if we have
a huge number of test scripts running
and if some of the test case fail we
need to check why this test case failed
so using the screenshot functionality it
helps us debug and identify the problem
by looking at the screenshots so
webdriver has this built-in
functionality to take the screenshot
across the page and it's pretty easy to
use take screenshot interface is used to
capture the screenshot during the
execution now this interface has a
method called grid get screenshot as
which captures a screenshot and it also
stores in a location specified by us so
let's take an example of our facebook
page and say we fail a particular test
case on the facebook application and
then let's see how we take a screenshot
at that particular moment when the test
case fails so let's go to the facebook
page first and let's understand the use
case so in this facebook page say if i
am signing up on this page i need to
enter all this field now as a part of
demo what i will do is i just enter the
first name and the surname and i will
click on the sign up button with this
test case it should basically not sign
me up rather it should give me some
error saying that you need to enter all
the fees and at that minute we are going
to take a screenshot okay so that's our
use case so let's see how do we achieve
that so if i go to my eclipse and let's
say we go to my screenshot test.java i
have a method written here so and these
are the operations which i just
described which i'm doing it here so i'm
going to just send keys my first name to
the first name field second name into
the search name field and then i'm just
going to click on the sign up button now
there are few things required for us to
do before we use the take screenshot
interface along with its method which is
the get screen shot as so i said that
this method stores the screenshot taken
in a file so that means i need to
provide it a file name and also a
location where it needs to be placed so
in our demo here in this test class what
i have done is i have created a folder
called screenshot in the same project
directory and then i am giving it a file
name called fblogin.png so that means
after the screenshot is taken it is
saved in a file called fblogin.png
and then it is stored in the location
screenshot folder and these are the
simple file operations of java which i
use to achieve this so let's execute
this and see how this happens so right
now i have this screenshot folder and
it's an empty folder so after the
execution i am expecting that this
particular file would get created so
let's see that in action so i'll go
ahead and execute this java program okay
so we have launched the facebook.com and
then i entered the my first name second
name and it has also clicked on signup
after which it has given all this red
marks here and now this is what i'm
expecting in the screenshot so let's go
back to our eclipse i will refresh this
folder so i'll say right click and
refresh
okay i have this file created so let's
open this file and see right so do you
see this this whole image has been
captured so now as a tester if at all
this test case fails for me i can always
open this png file and see what actually
happened and i can debug my test case so
this is how you use screenshot
functionality in selenium level
questions question 21 can you type in a
text box without using send keys so you
need an alternative way to use instead
of using the send keys function and one
such alternative is using javascript
executor so selenium provides an
interface called javascript executor and
this helps in executing any javascripts
through your selenium webdriver so you
can do any kind of function using this
javascript and one of the functions
which we can do is the send keys kind of
a function now how to replicate a send
keys function using javascript so let's
see an example here now since this
javascript executor is an interface you
cannot create an object of this
interface so what you do you type cast
it to your driver object the way it is
done here in this example and then you
use document dot get element id to get
the actual element on which you want to
perform the operations of sending the
keys now what is this document so it is
an object right so this document it's an
object that represents your html
document which is displayed in that
window and this document object has
various properties that refer to other
object which allows you the access to
modify any of your document content so
the argument which you are passing
through the java execute script is
nothing but your javascript now this
javascript uses the document object to
identify your element and then send the
value which you need to send to that
element so let's see this in action as
how it works so let me show you a small
program here all right so i have a
method here wherein i am trying to
identify the email field of your
facebook page so if this is your
facebook application this is my email
field and instead of using send keys
here i'm going to pass an email value to
this and how am i doing that using a
javascript executor right so if i
execute this particular java program it
is exactly going to do the same function
what i would do otherwise using the send
case so let's execute this and see if i
can see my user's id email in the
facebook application so the facebook
application is launched and there we go
so we this is the value which i have
sent using my javascript okay so this is
how you can use a javascript executor to
replicate a send keys method question 22
how to select a value from your drop
down list in the selenium web driver so
select class is a selenium web driver it
is used for selecting and deselecting
options in your drop down list the
objects of select type can be
initialized by passing the drop down web
element as a parameter to its
constructor like in this example i am
saying select drop down equal to new
select of test drop so test drop is
nothing but the web element which i have
identified using any locating techniques
after you create the select object then
you have three different methods
available for actually selecting your
methods and what are these methods one
is select by index now the index starts
with zero in the list so you can select
any element from your list using the
index side and then the second one is
select by values so this is used to
select an option based on its value
attribute select by visible text so this
is an option wherein you can select a
particular list item or an option based
on the text displayed in the option so
that means whatever text you can see on
your drop down list is what you will use
it to identify that particular element
so let's see the demo for this so i have
again a same facebook application which
i have considered here for demo so if
you go to our facebook application first
you know that there is a drop down menu
here now this drop down is for selecting
your bird date this has a day values
which you can select the month values
right and the year now what i have done
in my code is first thing is i've
identified all these drop down boxes
using one of i'm using mostly the id
locating technique here so you can use
any of your choice so once i identify
the element i created the select object
class for each of this and i pass that
web element to the constructor of the
select class so now my select element or
the object is ready to use so my next
step what i need to do is i need to go
and select the actual dates now in this
use case what i want is i want to select
a date which is 10th june 2005 that
means on my select drop down of the day
i should be able to select the day 10
now this i'm achieving by using select
by value and then i'm selecting the bun
month based on the index which is the
index in this case is 6 which will
select the june for me and then the
third one i'm trying to select it by
visible text wherein i am selecting the
year 2000 y so when i execute this
program let's see how the date selection
happens
okay there we go so it selected the 10
the day 10 the june month and the 2005
so this is how you use select objects in
selenium question 23 what does the
switch to command do so switch to
command is used to switch between
windows frames or even the alert pop-ups
within your application right so there
are multiple things which you can do
with switch to now sometimes in your web
application say when you click on a
button it opens up a completely new
browser window or you'll also see it
opens up another tab in your browser say
for example let's look at one of this
application which i have let me go to my
browser
and say i
launched hdfc bank.com all right so this
is my application say which you want to
test now when you launch this first
thing is i see this advertisement pop-up
which comes up which is right now an
unwanted pop-up so right now i'll just
close this and now if i want to enter
this hdfc bank application first i need
to do a login so if i click on this
login button see there is a new window
which opens up and i need to go and
operate into this window so for any
further operations i want to do it on
this web page i need to switch to this
window and then say i want to click on
continue to netbanking and then continue
with my use case so now in this
application there are two windows open
one is your base window from where we
actually logged in and after i clicked
on the logging there is a new window
opened up right so this is where your
switch to command will help us to
switching to this particular window to
do any of the operations on this web
elements present on this window okay now
let's see how do we actually do this so
in order to do this first you need to
get the handle of the window by using a
command called driver dot get window
handle all right so now when you use
driver.get window handle what you get is
a unique alphanumeric value which is an
identifier for that window and once you
get this you use a command called
driver.switch2
dot window and you pass that handle
which you have fetched previously and
this command will actually switch to the
current window which is in your focus
now you will also come across a case
where there are multiple windows open
right now the example what we saw we
just had a single window but say if you
whenever you launch an application say
there are multiple windows which are
open so in such case you can use
something called as get windows handles
right now get windows handles what it
does it picks up all the active windows
at that point of a time and using a for
loop you can read into every handle and
then you do your operations specific to
your window handles also there is
another way wherein you can switch back
to your parent window so if ever you
want to switch back to your parent
window you have to use the same command
driver.switch2 and the handle what you
need to provide here is your parent
handle all right so this is about
windows then i also said switch 2 can be
used for your frames so what are frames
frames are usually used to divide your
web application or your web page or the
on the same domain into various
different windows or sections right so
for us to operate on elements which are
in different frames we need to first
switch to a particular frame and then
use the web elements on that so the same
command will be using now instead of
window here i would say driver dot
switch to dot free similarly even the
alert pop-ups can be handled using the
same command so in the case of alert
what you need to do is you have to say
driver dot switch to dot
question 20 how to upload a file in
selenium webdriver right a very
important concept in selenium webdriver
we know that selenium webdriver is
designed for automating web application
right and file upload is a very common
scenario which we get with every web
application which we are working with
now there are two ways to do a file
window file upload operation one is
using the send keys which is the
simplest method and the other way is
using robot class now there are certain
prereqs required for you to work with
the send keys option now if you are
using the send keys option what you
basically need to do is you need to type
in the complete path of the file along
with the file name right in the file
select input field now this element
where you're going to enter your file
name should have certain attributes one
of the attributes it should have the tag
as input right and also it should have
an attribute called type which should
have a value of file only then it is
possible for you to enter a file name
and upload the file okay that is by
using the send keys method then the
other way is using robot now when when
is that we need to use robot where
whenever you have an application and in
your application usually for your file
upload you have a button which says
upload a file and when you click on that
it opens a new window and this window is
your windows explorer window or a finder
window depending on what operating
system you're working and these are the
native windows and we know that selenium
web driver directly cannot handle the
native applications so in such case the
robot class helps us in managing these
native windows so what happens in the
robot classes it helps you manage your
file upload dialog box by simulating all
the actions required for selecting a
particular file from your dialog box and
then you go and upload them all right so
this is the example of using the send
keys question 25 how to set browser
window size in webdriver so you can
either maximize the window or set it to
a certain value now to do this you use a
simple functions provided by
driver.manage one of the functions using
driver.manage is
driver.manage.window.maximize
now this command maximizes the current
window and say you want to set a
particular window size rather than
maximizing it and then for that you have
a command called
driver.manage.window.setsize
now this set size takes an argument of
the type dimension class so this is
basically when you create a dimension
class you are passing the size of the
window which you want to create here
right so we use the dimension class
define the new dimensions of the window
and then pass the object of this
dimensions to the set size method this
is one way of doing it we also saw that
using javascript executor we can do any
kind of functionality so if you want to
minimize or maximize or set a different
size to your browser windows this can
also be done using a javascript okay
let's see a quick demo on how do we use
this driver.manage dot set size or the
maximize command so let's go to my
eclipse here so i have this method
written here so i have two methods one
method where i'm saying i'm going to
maximize the window this one it's in an
array i'm just going to traverse through
the array using an enhanced for loop so
in this program in this test case i'm
just picking each and every element and
printing the attribute id of each
element so if i execute this now we
should see all the elements on the
facebook page which has the class name
starting with input and we should see
all the ids of that so this is what we
are getting so you are around getting 9
to 10 elements it has picked up and all
of them have the class name starting
with input and these are their different
ids
question 27 what is pause on exception
in selenium id so pause on exception is
a new feature of selenium ide it is one
of the brilliant debugger function which
this new selenium id provides us what it
does is it enables us or when this
particular option is enabled the
execution of your test pauses if at all
there is any exception which occurs in
your test scripts and because of this
what you can do is you can go and handle
that error by say changing your command
in the script and then continue your
test execution so this helps in
debugging your code pretty well so
whenever there is an exception say for
example and web element which you are
trying to identify has a wrong
identifier or it changes on your web
page then you can correct that command
which caused the exception and then
resume the test execution from that
point onwards so let's look at a simple
use case and see how exactly this works
so for example let's go to my browser
here okay so i have a simple use case
here where i want to login into facebook
using my email id and password and what
i have done is i have created a script
or recorded a script using my selenium
id so these are all the steps which it
has wherein it logs into the facebook
account then it clicks on the email
field enters the email this is my value
which i'm passing clicks on the password
field enters the password and then
clicks on the login button now this is a
clean test script and all my web
elements are correct here so whenever i
am running this test with this test
script is going to pass now say as an
example say this particular element
which is my password element say this id
changes so now deliberately what i'm
going to do i'm just going to give a
wrong id here so if i give a wrong id
and if i execute this test script now it
is going to throw an exception at this
point so let's do that so it's going to
throw an exception but now since i want
to use the pause and exception feature
what i do is it's available here it says
pause and exception by default it is
switched off so when you select this
that means this is been switched on and
now if i execute the script this is
going to come into a debug mode at this
point where my exception is going to be
through so let's see that so now i have
this i've changed this id to wrong id so
i'll just say go and run this current
test so let's see how it operates so let
me just bring this side by side so you
can see here it has entered the email
and if you look here in the console it
is saying trying to find the id for
which i've given pa and 4s which is a
wrong id so it will look for some time
whether it can find an element with this
particular id so let's wait for it to
throw the exception
there we go so now it tried enough and
actually that step has failed and there
is an exception saying that that
particular web element is not found
however my test case or the test script
did not exit it has come and paused and
it has entered into a debug mode here
paused and debug now as a tester or an
automation scriptwriter what i can do
here is i can simply go and correct this
now i know this is my correct id once i
correct this i can execute the rest of
the script right from this point so now
i have this option here if you go here
it says resume test execution so i'm
just going to click on that so it is
going to go ahead and enter everything
yes if you see here i entered email
password and in this test script what
i'm doing is i'm entering my first name
and my surname instead of clicking on
the login button so it went ahead and if
you look here it says fb test completed
successfully this is how the pause and
exception feature helps us question 28
how to login into any website if it is
showing an authentication pop-up for
username and password which will be
something like this so this is a typical
authentication pop-up which you normally
see when you are dealing with some web
application right and to handle them we
use something called as an alert class
and alert class comes with a method
called authenticate using basically by
using this method what we are trying to
do is it helps us skip the basic http
authentication box so how do we handle
it it is handled exactly the way we
handle any kind of alert box and
selenium now in this example first what
we need to do is we need to create a
weight object using an explicit weight
now this weight is for what it is for
the alert to pop up so we basically wait
until that authentication alert pops up
and set the conditions in this explicit
way for as alert is present so that
means you're going to wait until your
authentication pop-up is seen on your
screen and then once you have that
authentication pop-up which is on your
screen that is when you need to go and
handle it now to handle it for your
alert class you're going to call a
method as i said using authenticate
using and to this you pass a parameter
now this parameter has to be your
username and password however the way
the parameters are passed here is using
a class object called user and password
now this user and password class it is a
part of selenium security package all
right and this is implemented from an
interface called credentials so you
create this object of class user and
password using the authentication
information which you have and then pass
this as parameter to your method called
authenticate using and this way you can
handle your authentication pop-up
question 29 what is the difference
between single and double slash in x
path a very important question and it's
a very important thing for each of you
to understand single slash is used to
create an x path with absolute path that
is the x path would be created right
from the starting node and the starting
node is slash html and the double slash
is created or it's a x path with
relative path now relative path this x
path would be created
using any starting location or anywhere
within the document for example i could
start with a div tag wherein if i
mention double slash and div so this is
going to be treated as a relative path
and whatever conditions i am going to
give it is going to try and match those
attributes with the stack right this is
called as a relative path so why don't
we just go and take a look at how do we
identify an element using a relative as
well as an absolute path so if i go back
to the same application of the facebook
this is my facebook application now i
have this crow path installed which
helps me in identifying x parts of an
element now say i want to try and see
what is the x path of my element first
name so in the inspector tool i can see
that it has a tag input and it has a
long class name and it has multiple
attributes which i can use to identify
this element so if i go to my crow path
and again try to match this element so
if i just hover my mouse here now here
you can see this scroll path gives me
both the path one is the relative x path
and one is the absolute x path now look
at the big difference between these two
now relative path was as simple as using
a slash slash input which is the tag and
an attribute called id we are able to
identify this particular element same
thing if you want to use an absolute
path and you if you see here it will
start right from the slash html which is
your starting node of your html page and
then it travels down looking into each
of the parent and child under this until
it found this element input right so
this is absolute path so you can use
either of these paths to identify your
elements question 30 how do you find
broken links in selenium webdriver now
http is designed for what to enable
communications between your clients and
servers and if you know there are few
commands like get put post now get is
used to request data from a specified
resource put command is used to send
data over your server and post is used
to send data to the server right now
while using these links and trying to
figure out if the link is valid or not
what you can do is you can use something
called as head requests now what are
head request head requests are nothing
but they are something like a get
request but they do not have a response
body and usually this is used for
checking that what a get request can
return before actually making a get
request like say before downloading a
large file you would send a head request
before sending the complete git just to
know whether the link which is provided
for downloading a large file is a
genuine link or not and then looking at
the response code is what you decide
that so how do we do this
programmatically now selenium provides
something called as http url connection
class which has some methods to send
http request and to capture the http
response codes like the ones which you
see it on the screen so if we have to
see how do we do that now first thing
the logic behind how do we get this
broken links is you get all the urls on
your website first after getting all the
urls now how do you get the urls by
using the tag a like it is done here so
once you get the complete list of all
urls you also check for a non well or
non null or a blank ones that is one
kind of a check which you can put after
that you create an http connection
object with each of the url and you open
the connection of the url and you send
the request now this request whatever
you're going to send you are going to
send the header request to just to get
the head and not the complete get
request now only thing what you're
interested in getting a response code so
once you get the response code what you
have to do is you have to check the
response code against all your response
code now typically when you're checking
for your response code any response code
above 400 is treated as a client error
rest all the links below 400 are all the
valid links so here if you see 404 you
have a response called as link not found
400 is a bad request 401 is unheard rest
so you can do a simple check there where
it says if your response code is above
500 then that particular link has an
error and that is probably going to be
your invalid link so let's see that in
action as how exactly the code is going
to look and how do we achieve that now i
have a test case written here called
broken links.java now here what i'm
doing is i'm logging into facebook.com
and then i'm fetching all the elements
with the tag a now when i say i'm
fetching all the elements with the tag
that means i'm going to get all the href
element from the page and once i get
that using a for loop i'm going to
inspect each and every url what i'm
going to fetch as i said my first check
would be to see if it is a null or is it
an empty if i find an empty or a null
value in the url i am just going to
ignore that and continue the loop and
this is where i actually do the
connection with my url so i create an
http url connection with the url which i
have picked it up from my website then i
do this i send a request here the head
request to get a response code so once i
get this response code is what i put a
if-else statement and check if my
response code is greater than or equal
to 400. so if i find that if my response
code is more than 400 that means this
particular url link is broken and that
is how i identify so once you identify a
particular url which is broken you can
make use of that information share it
with your developers and get it fixed so
let's go ahead and execute this so in
this test case basically what i'm going
to do is i'm just printing out all the
urls and i'm printing the ones which are
valid and ones which are broken since
it's a
facebook.com website i do not have any
broken url but this is just a logic of
how do we find a broken url so if you
look here a lot of websites which is
getting listed which says is a valid
link so that means it is getting a
response code which is more than 500 so
this is what we saw in the demo as how
do i i trade after i select all the
links on the page and then how do i
determine whether it's a valid link or
it's a broken link docker is a popular
devops tool used to automate the
deployment of applications in
lightweight containers so that
applications can work efficiently in
different environments
docker was initially released in 2013
and since then has become the go-to
solution for containerization
in this video we have compiled the most
important docker interview questions
that you might face in a docker or
devops interview
so without further ado let's get started
so let's go through and you're going to
be asked to explain what the
architecture of docker is and docker
really is the most popular
containerization environment so docker
uses a client server architecture and
the docker client is a service which
runs in a command line and and then the
docker daemon which is run as a rest api
and within the command line will accept
the requests and interacts with the
operating system in order to build the
docker images and run the docker
containers and then the docker image is
a template of instructions which is used
to create containers the docker
container is an executable package of
applications and its dependencies
together and then finally the docker
registry is a service to host and
distribute docker images among other
users so you'll also be asked to provide
what are the advantages of docker over
virtual machine and and this is
something that comes up very
consistently in fact um you may want to
even extend it as having what are the
differences between having a dedicated
machine a virtual machine and a docker
or docker-like environment and really
the the arguments for docker are just
absolutely fantastic you know first of
all docker does contain and occupy
docket containers occupy significantly
less space than a virtual machine or a
dedicated machine the boot up time on
docker is significantly faster than a vm
containers have a much better
performance as they are hosted in a
single docker image docker is highly
efficient and very easy to scale
particularly when you start working with
kubernetes easily portable across
multiple platforms and then finally for
space allocation docker data volumes can
be shared and reused among multiple
containers the argument against virtual
machines is significant and particularly
if you're going into an older
environment where a company is still
using actual dedicated hardware and
haven't moved to a cloud or cloud-like
environment your arguments for docker
are going to be very very persuasive be
very clear on what the advantages are
for docker over a virtual machine
because you want to be able to
succinctly share them with your team and
this is something that's important when
you're going through the interview
process but also equally important
particularly if you're working with a
company that's transitioning or going
through a digital transformation where
they aren't used to working with the
tools like docker you need to be able to
effectively share with that team what
the benefits are so how do we share
docker containers with different nodes
and in this instance what you want to be
able to do is leverage the power of
docker swarm so docker swarm is a tool
which allows the it administrators and
developers to create and manage clusters
of swarm nodes within the docker
platform and there are two elements to
the node there's the manager node and
then there's the the worker node the
manager node as you'd assume manages the
entire infrastructure and the working
node is actually the work of the agent
as it gets executed
so what are the commands to create a
docker swarm and so here we have an
example of what a manager node would
look like and once you've created a
swarm on your manager node you can now
add worker nodes to that swarm and again
when you're stepping through this
process be very precise in the execution
part that needs to be taken to be able
to effectively create a swarm so start
with the manager node and then you
create a worker node and then finally
when a node is initialized as a manager
node it can immediately create a token
and that token is used for the worker
nodes and associating the ip address
with the worker nodes question 17 how to
run multiple containers using a single
service it is possible to run multiple
containers as a single service by using
docker compose and docker compose will
actually run each of the services in
isolation so that they can interact with
each other the language used to write
out the compose files that allow you to
run the service is called yaml and yamos
stands for yet another markup language
so what is the use of a docker file so
docker file actually is used for
creating docker images using the build
command so let's go through and show on
the screen what that would look like and
this would be an opportunity where if
you're actually in a technical interview
you could potentially even ask hey can i
draw on a whiteboard and show you what
the architecture for using the build
command would look like and what the
process would look like again when
you're going through an interview
process as someone who interviews a lot
of people one of the things i really
like is when an interview candidate does
something that's slightly different and
in this instance this is a great example
of where you can stand up to the
whiteboard and actually show what can
actually be done through actually
creating images on the whiteboard very
quickly little square boxes where you
can actually show the flow for creating
a build environment as an architect this
should be something that you are
comfortable doing and by doing it in the
interview and suddenly you want to ask
permission before you actually do it but
doing this in the interview really helps
demonstrate your comfortable feelings of
working with these kind of architecture
drawings so back to the question of
creating a docker file so we go through
and that we have a docker file that
actually then goes ahead and creates the
docker image which then in turns creates
the docker container and then we are
able to push that out up to a docker hub
and then share that docker hub with
everybody else as part of the docker
registry with the whole network so what
are the differences between docker image
and docker containers so let's go
through the docker image so the docker
images are templates of a docker
container an image is built using a
docker file and it stores that docker
file in a docker repository or a docker
hub and you can use docker hub as an
example and the image layer is a read
only file system the docker container is
a collection of the runtime instances of
a docker image and the containers are
created using docker images and they are
stored in the docker daemon and every
container is a layer is a read write
file system so you can't replace the
information you can only append to it
so while you can actually use yaml or
writing your so a question you can be
asked is instead of yammer what can be
an alternate file to build docker
compose so yaml is the one that is the
default but you can also use json so if
you are comfortable working with json
and my that is something that you should
be uh get comfortable with is you want
to be able to use that to name your
files and as a frame reference uh json
is a
logical way of being able to do value
paired matching using a javascript like
syntax
so you're going to be asked to how to
create a docker container so let's go
through what that would look and we'll
break it down task by task so the task
is going to be create a my sequel docker
container so to do that you want to be
able to build a docker image or pull
from an existing docker image from a
docker repository or hub and then you
want to be able to then use docker to
create a new container which has my
sequel from the existing docker image
simultaneously the layer of read write
file system is also created on top of
that image and below at the bottom of
the screen we have what the commands
lines look for that so what is the
difference between a registry and a
repository so let's go through that so
for the docker registry and repository
for the registry we have docker registry
is an open source server-side service
used for hosting and distributing docker
images whereas in contrast for
repository it's a collection of multiple
versions of a docker image in a registry
a user can distinguish between docker
images with their tag names and then
finally on the registry docker also has
its own default retreat called docker
hub for the repository it is a
collection of multiple versions of
docker images it is stored in a docker
registry and it has two types of public
and private registry so you can actually
create your own enterprise registry so
you're gonna be asked you know what are
the cloud platforms that uh support
docker really you know list them all and
we have listed here amazon web services
microsoft azure google cloud rackspace
but you could add in their ibm bluemix
could put in red hat really any of the
cloud service providers out there today
do support docker it's just become an
industry standard so what is the purpose
of expose and publish commands in docker
so if we go through expose is an
instruction used in dockerfile whereas
publish is used in docker run command
for expose it is used to expose ports
within a docker network whereas with
publishers can be used outside of a
docker environment for expose it is a
documenting instruction used at the time
of building an image and running a
container whereas with published is used
as to map a host port to a running
container port for expose is it's the
command used in docker whereas for
publish we use the command-p for when
we're doing our command line used in
docker and examples of these are expose
8080 or with docker we would put in or
for publish would do the example docker
run dash d dash p and then
0.0.0.80 a colon 80 as our command line
and so with that we conclude this
session i hope this video was helpful if
you have any doubts or queries let us
know in the comment section below also
watch out for new videos from us until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you